embark on the thrilling Journey Through
the vast world of python with this
comprehensive full course this learning
experience takes you from a beginner to
a profession pythonista exploring the
languages versatility and power uncover
the Elegance of python syntax create
applications Master data analysis and
derive into the fascinating Realms of
machine learning and web development
whether you are a sales encoder or a
complete noise this course provides you
with the skills and confidence to
conquer any coding challenge get ready
to unleash your creativity and embrace
Python's boundless possibilities let
let's dive in and begin this exciting
adventure together but before we begin
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn the demand of
python developers is soaring as
Industries increasingly seek skill
professional to leverage the languages
versatility and efficiency in various
applications from web development to
data science and artificial intelligence
if you are looking to be one of them
then yes you are at the right place
introducing you with caltic postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning let's
take a quick walk through with this
amazing program some key features of
Caltech postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning include pgp and AIML
completion certificate from Caltech ctme
master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts caltex ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEOs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box so without
any further Ado let's begin over to our
tutors Python's popularity has grown
exponentially over the past few years it
is widely used as evidenced by high
rankings in service such as the Tioga
index and the vast number of python
based GitHub projects python is renowned
for its simple programming syntax code
readability and english-like commands
that make programming a lot easier and
more efficient Python's large Library
System makes it a best choice for data
science machine learning and artificial
intelligence projects considering the
job opportunities in Python Tech giants
like Google Map data Bosch and many
others higher python developers with
handsome salaries with salary in India
starting from rupees 5.1 lakhs per annum
and may get as high as rupees 10 lakhs
per annum whereas the average base
salary of python developer in US is 105
000 and may get as high as 170 000
annually if you are watching this video
I believe you are one of those aspiring
persons dreaming to build a secured
career with a strong fundamentals and a
powerful portfolio to crack your dream
job opportunity we from Simply learn
bring you this complete python full
course here we will cover the
fundamentals of python that includes the
Python Programming Concepts like data
types variables conditional statements
strings operators lists tuples
dictionaries and much more note just
that this phone course will also dive
into the most crucial programming
paradigms that involve the advanced
Python Programming Concepts that is the
oops concept except option handling fine
handling sorting techniques and much
more to make things more interesting we
are also covering the Spotify data
analysis project and a lineup of
interview question and answer that will
help you get your dream job now I have
an insight for you guys if you are
aiming to get certified in Python
Programming and want to build a python
software development career in that case
you can check the python certification
course by simply learn which will open
the doors for the best career
opportunities to find the details of
this course check the link in the
description box below so stay tight you
are going to learn with simply learn and
if you love these kinds of videos then
hit the Subscribe button and press the
Bell icon to now miss the upcoming
videos from us
thank you
in this introduction to python video we
will learn what is python the features
of python and where python is used
we will also look at the popular python
Frameworks and libraries and get an idea
about the best python Ides
then we will see the top companies using
Python Programming and get some hands-on
experience by learning the basics of
python on a jupyter notebook
so let's get started with what is python
python is a high level object oriented
programming language developed by Guido
van Rossum in 1989 and was first
released in 1991.
python is often called A batteries
included language due to its
comprehensive standard Library
a fun fact about python is that the name
python was actually taken from the
popular BBC comedy show of that time
Monty Python's Flying Circus now let's
look at the top features of python
first so python has a simple structure
and a clearly defined syntax this allows
the Learners to pick up the language
quickly so it is easy to learn and use
python can run on different operating
systems such as Windows Linux and Mac
making it a portable language it enables
programmers to develop the software for
several competing platforms by writing
the program only once
third python is freely available at the
official website since it is open source
this means that source code is also
available to the public
a python uses an object-oriented
approach that encapsulates code within
objects
python provides a collection of
libraries for various tasks such as
machine learning web development and
data analysis
and finally
in Python you don't need to assign the
data type of the variable when you
assign some value to the variable it
automatically allocates the memory to
the variable at runtime
with that
let's move on to the uses of Python
programming
so Python programming language is used
to develop desktop applications and
build web applications too
it is popularly used in the field of
data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence to analyze data
build predictive models and make
business decisions python is also widely
used in game development now let's see
some of the popular python Frameworks
and libraries
python can be used for web development
using Frameworks like xango flask
pyramid and cherry pie
now you can build graphical user
interfaces using libraries and
Frameworks such as tkinter or just
kinder
you can also use spy gtk by qt or pygs
or python JavaScript
now python is also used to perform
machine learning tasks using libraries
such as tensorflow by torch scikit-learn
matplotlib and sci-fi
you can also perform mathematical
computations using numpy and pandas
now let's look at the best Ides that you
can use to write programs in Python and
perform specific tasks so we have
jupyter notebook which is part of the
Anaconda distribution that is widely
used these days even for our demo in
this video we'll be using Jupiter
notebook I'll show you in a while then
we have the visual code editor from
Microsoft this is also one of the
preferred
Ides by Learners and companies
then we also have the popular text
editor called Sublime Text Editor
then we also have pycharm followed by
python ideally and spider as our top
Ides now let's look at the top companies
that are using python in our day-to-day
work
so we have Google quora Facebook even
Netflix Spotify and Instagram now there
are other top product based service
based and startups that also use Python
programming
it so let's start as you all know python
is an interpreted language so you need
to install a python interpreter so for
that we'll go to the browser and search
for python.org
now we will move to the downloads page
and choose the latest version of python
to download and the latest version is
python 3.9.5
we'll click on the download
once the installer has downloaded open
it
now you can see the installation window
for python
you have to double check both the boxes
add python 3.9 to path
and click on install now
as the installation completes you can
see a screen that says the setup was
successful now click on close
now to check whether the python has been
installed successfully on the system or
not we will run a command on the command
prompt let's open the command prompt
click on start and write CMD
now to check whether the python is
installed or not we will run the command
python minus minus version
python space minus minus version and
press enter so here we can see that
python 3.9.5 version is installed in the
system so yeah python is working in the
system now we'll run some commands for
python
so for that first we will type py
and press enter
and now we will write the basic command
that is
print
it
hello world
semicolon and press enter
as you can see hello world is printed
here so yeah python is started working
in our system
now we will install libraries of python
we will be using pip to install numpy
sci-fi matplotlib and pandas library and
before installing the libraries make
sure the latest version of pip is
installed in your system so to check
that we will run a command in command
prompt
we will open the command prompt
and write a Command Web space minus
minus version
and press enter
as you can see the PIP version is 21.1.1
and it's being downloaded with the
python 3.9 so it's the latest version we
have downloaded
so now
we have to keep one thing in mind before
installing sci-fi matte dot lip and
pandas Library first we need to install
numpy Library
so for that we will run a command
pip space
install
numpy and press enter
depending on your internet speed it will
get installed
as you can see the numpy library has
been installed and there's a warning
that our pip version is 21.1.1 and we
should upgrade it to 21.1.2 that is the
latest version available so we'll
upgrade the PIP version for that we will
write a command python
space minus m space pip space
install space minus
upgrade space pip enter
okay so we made a mistake here in the
command so the mistake is we have
written only one minus sign before the
upgrade we have to write two minus signs
before the upgrade so we'll write the
command again python
space minus m space WIP space install
space minus minus upgrade
space pip and then press enter
and now depending on your internet speed
the PIP version the latest version will
be installed on your system
as you can see they have uninstalled the
paper version 21.1 and they have
installed
the latest version that is 21.1.2
we have installed the first library that
is numpy and that's the basic
requirement
for the installation of scipy Library so
now we will install the scipy library
so for that we'll write the command pip
install scipy
pip space
install
space sci-fi and press enter
and depending on your internet speed it
will be downloaded
now you can see that this Hi-Fi library
has been installed successfully and here
you can see that the requirement already
satisfied numpy so we have firstly
downloaded the numpy library so that we
can easily run the scipy library now we
will download and install pandas library
for that we will write the command
fifth space install
pandas
and press enter
and this will also install depending on
your internet speed
we can see that the pandas library has
been successfully installed now we are
left with matplot Live library so now we
will install that for that we'll write
the command
fifth space install
met
float live and press enter
as we can see the matplotlib liability
has been successfully installed
now we have installed all the four
libraries
so if you want to check whether the
library is installed on your system or
not
you can write a command to check that
first you have to write Python and press
enter
first we will check for numpy library
and for that we will create a array
so that will write the command
import
numpy
S and P and press enter
if you don't get any error it means that
the library has been installed
successfully so now we will create an
array
a equal to NP Dot
1 comma 2 comma four
comma
5 comma 7 comma 9
coma
D type
equal to we'll set it for float
press enter and we want to print this
array
like print
created
comma a
and press enter
you can see the output array created one
to four and five seven nine so the numpy
library is working fine so we will check
for other libraries for that
we will write import
space
mat.lib and press enter
if you don't get any error it means that
the library has been installed
successfully
so for the rest also we can
write the same commands import
pandas and press enter we do not get any
error so the library has been installed
successfully and we are left with sci-fi
so we'll write import space sci-fi and
press enter so here also we didn't get
any error so the library has also been
installed successfully
now we'll see what Anaconda is
Anaconda is a free and open source
distribution of python and our language
here we have conda which is a package
manager system similar to Pepin python
so now we will see how to download
Anaconda and then we will explore its
features
to download Anaconda first we will open
the browser
and search for the keyword Anaconda
we have to visit the official website
that is www.anaconda.com
and now we will click on the product
section and choose the individual
Edition as it is open source Edition and
it is free of post
now we'll scroll down
here is the toolkit for the individual
Edition and will click on the download
on clicking the download we are directed
to the bottom of the web page and here
we can see the different versions
available for Windows that is 32-bit and
64-bit
we will download the 64-bit and it is of
size 477 MB so it will take ample amount
of time to download
we will download it
as the download completes click on the
application file
now click on next
the license agreement will appear now
click on I agree
then you have to select the installation
type if you want to install for a single
user click on just me and select for all
users and click on next I am installing
for me so I will click next
then it will ask for installation
location
after selecting location click on the
next
me the location is fine so I will click
then Advanced installation options will
appear if you have already installed
python on your system as we have
installed already so we do not have to
click on this section
we will only click on this section and
press install
it will take time to install
to the installation is complete click on
next
then click on next
and uncheck both these options and click
on finish
as you can see the installation has been
completed
now
we'll go to start and type Anaconda
we can see that Anaconda prompt and
Anaconda Navigator are visible
first we will open Anaconda Navigator
it's initializing and adding features
here you can see some pre-installed
applications and tools that are already
installed in the Anaconda and if you
want to install any other tool you can
like you can install ask Studio python
professional Orange 3 blue is
in the Anaconda
and you already have spider QD console
Powershell from Jupiter notebook
Jupiter lab IBM motion Studio cloud data
lore cmd.exe prompt
so now we will open and open the prompt
now we'll see which version of conda is
installed in the system for that we'll
write a command conda space info
and press enter
here we can see that the Honda version
is 4.10.1
now we will launch Jupiter notebook for
that we will write the command
jupyter notebook
and press enter
you can see that the jupyter notebook
has initiated now create a folder where
you want to store the projects and
rename accordingly
so to create folder we'll create the
folder in OneDrive
sorry
I will create the folder on desktop
new
folder
we will take the Untitled folder and
rename it
and rename it as python one
now minimize the window
and
open the desktop
you can see that the python One
Directory is created and now we will
click on the python 1 folder
and
create a Python 3 notebook
as we have created a Python 3 file in
the jupyter notebook now we can run the
python commands on it
so we will run some commands and first
we will run a basic command that would
be print
India
and we'll run this command window is
printed here if you are looking to be
one of them then yes you are at the
right place
introducing you with Caltech
postgraduate program Ai and machine
learning let's take a quick walk through
with this amazing program some key
features of Caltech postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning include pgp
and AIML completion certificate from
Caltech ctme master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts Caltech ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEOs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
before writing a program in Python
ideally we will write a program on
command prompt
so for that first we will open command
prompt
we'll click on start and write CMD and
click enter
now the command prompt appears
first we will check the python version
with space minus minus version
and press enter
you will see the python version 3.9
now we'll start writing the Python
program
for that first you have to write the
command p y and press enter now we can
start writing a program we will write a
basic program on Division
for that we will assign a value 5
to a variable a
and
value 10 to the variable B
and we will divide B by a
and we'll print the value
of C
press enter
as you can see we have got an output 2.0
now we have run a program on command
prompt successfully now we will write a
program in Python ideally
so to write a program in Python ideology
we will see some steps
first you have to open the python
ideally then click on file menu and
choose the new file and after writing
the program we have to save the program
with DOT py extension and then we can
click on the Run menu and then we will
see a run module and we have to click on
that
now we'll see it practically for that
we'll click on start
and search for ideally
and now we will click on python ideally
now we will follow the steps as we have
seen now
we will click on file menu and choose
new file a new window will appear here
we will type the program to get two
numbers inserted by user and add them
but before writing this program let's
understand this program
so Python program on adding two numbers
first we have to get an end value
inserted in variably for that we'll
write the command equal to int around
brackets input around bracket started
for the message we have to put it in
inverted commas and the first number
colon round bracket close and another
round bracket close
now we will insert an INT value in
variable B for that we will write the
command b equal to in round bracket
started input around bracket started for
the message we'll put the message in
inverted commas and the second number
colon
and then we will close this message by
round bracket and another round bracket
closing then we will assign a variable C
and add the operation a plus b for that
now we'll print
a message that would be addition of two
numbers equal to that would be an
inverted commas comma C
as C variable will store the result of a
plus b
all the statements in the program will
get executed lineman line now we will
execute this program on python ideally
so for that we will write a program here
that would be a equal to
and
round bracket start input
round bracket
inverted commas
enter first number
inverted commas close
around bracket close
b equal to
end
input
ground bracket started inverted commas
for message
enter second number
inverted commas round bracket goes
now we will assign the operation a plus
b in variable C for that we will write c
equal to a plus b
and now we will print C
before executing this program we will
save this program file
save as
we will save it as demo one
and we will write the extension p y
and press save
as the program is saved now we will run
this program by click on this run menu
and then click on run module
you can see the program has been
executed now we will write the first
number that would be 10 press enter and
second number will write 6 and press
enter we will get 16 as an output
so we have executed the program on
python ideally
now we will see some best python IDs in
the market
for that
the best python IDs in the market are
jupyter notebook Visual Studio code
Sublime Text pycharm
python ideally inspired a notebook among
all these IDs we have worked with python
ideally now we will write a program in
jupyter Notebook
for that you have to install Jupiter
notebook I have installed Anaconda
distribution and it has python ID
already installed if you want to know
how to install Anaconda distribution go
and check the video in Python playlist
so let's open jupyter notebook for that
first we'll click on start
and write Jupiter notebook
and click on the jupyter notebook
Anaconda 3.
and will wait to get it started in a
browser
now we'll select the location where we
want to store the program
we will select the location in OneDrive
desktop
and I've created a python 1 folder there
so here we'll create a new Python 3
notebook
and name it as
first python
program
and now here we can start writing a
here we will write a program to multiply
three numbers
so for that we will get all the three
integers inserted by the users in three
variables and then we will operate the
operation multiplication
so for that we will write the command a
equal to end round bracket started
input round bracket and here we will
print the message
enter first number
colon
and then naughty commas close and around
bracket close now we'll enter another
integer in variable B
for that we'll write the command equal
to end
round bracket
input
down bracket started inverted commas
enter second number
colon
and then we'll close the inverted commas
and the round brackets
and now we will get the third interior
inputted by the user in variable C for
that we'll write the command c equal to
int round brackets input round brackets
inverted commas
enter
third number
colon inverted commas close and round
Bucket close now we will assign the
operation of multiplication in variable
d that would be by the command D equal
to
a
into B into C
now we'll print the variability
and for that we will also print the
message
multiplication of three numbers
and close the inverted commas and then
we will insert a comma and then write
the variable d as D contains the output
of a into B into C now we'll click on
the Run command
and now we will
enter a first number that would be 5
and press enter then the second number
four then the third number six and then
press enter
and then we will get the output of
multiplication of three numbers as 120.
now we have successfully run the program
on jupyter Notebook
so in this video
we will learn what is a variable in
Python
then
we'll understand what are object
references
we'll also see the different rules for
python variables and finally
will understand variables in detail with
Hands-On demonstration on The jupyter
Notebook
so variables in Python hold an object of
a particular data type
python variables are containers for
storing data values we do not need to
declare variables before using them or
declare that data type like we do in
other programming languages such as Java
or C plus
python is not statically typed a
variable is created the moment we assign
a value to it
a variable is a name given to a memory
location
so here we can see
we have a variable called car and it has
a value called BMW now this value is of
type string since it is written within
double quotes
variables can have values of multiple
data types
now python also allows you to assign
values to multiple variables in one line
so here you can see I have assigned x y
z to Audi BMW and Mercedes in one single
line
all right
now let's look at object references in
Python
a python variable is a symbolic name
that is a reference or pointer to an
object
once an object is assigned to a variable
you can refer to the object by that name
so here we are assigning an integer
value of 50 to the variable a so
assignment creates an integer object
with a value of 50 and assigns the
variable A to point to that object as
you can see here so a is the variable
and it is pointing to the object that
has 50 value
now let's see another example so in this
case we have assigned
a variable a which has a value of 50 and
then we have created another variable
called B that has the value stored in a
python does not create another object in
this case it creates a new symbolic name
or reference called P which points to
the same object that a points to so here
you can see
both A and B are pointing to the same
object that is 50.
okay now
in this example
python creates a new integer object with
a value of 100 and B becomes a reference
to it we will explore all of these in
our demo
now
there are some rules for python
variables let me just read all the and
we will explore all these rules in our
demo session
so first a variable name must start with
a letter or the underscore character
a variable name cannot start with a
number
a variable name can contain only
alphanumeric characters or underscores
so you can see from A to Z 0 to 9 or
just underscore
variable names are case sensitive so
here you can see I have written date
in three different types and these
are read as different variables and not
the same variable
and then there are several techniques to
write Multiverse variables you have the
camel case you have the Pascal case and
we have the snake case don't worry about
it we'll explore these
in the demo now let me take you to my
jupyter notebook where we will
understand variables in detail
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook and
I have my title as variables in Python
so let's start
with my first variable let's say I have
a variable called a
and I'm assigning
50 to it
now you must be aware fifties of type
integer
so this a variable is now
holding an integer value
now if you want you can just print a
if I hit shift enter it will give me the
value of 50
now to check the data type of a you can
use the type function now if you have
covered data types in detail in our
previous video if you want you can have
a look at it
so I will write type of a if I hit shift
enter it gives me the integer type
okay
now
let me show you another function called
ID if I write ID of a
let's run it it gives me a number this
is a long number now the ID function in
Python returns a unique ID for the
specified object so here object is a
so all objects in Python have its own
unique ID the ID is assigned to the
object when it is created
now what if
I assign
100 to a this time and let's see
the ID of a
if I run it you can see here the values
are different than the previous one
so every time the ID function will
return a unique ID for the specified
object
all right
now we learned in our Theory section
that you can assign multiple variables
in a single line now let me show you how
to do it
suppose
I'll write X comma y commas C so these
are the three variables and I want to
assign
three values to them so let's say x will
have 50
in y I want to store let's say 100 and
68.6
and
my Z
will have
a string or a text value let's say
simply learn
all right let's run it okay now you can
print them one by one you can see here x
has 50
y has
168.6 and Z has simply learn of type
text you can check the
data types if you want let's say I want
to check the data type of Y
it gives me a float because
68.6 is a float
you can check the DD type of
Z result type string
okay now you can also perform the same
operation of assigning multiple
variables in a single line in another
way let me show you how to do it
suppose I want to assign
the same
value to three different variables let's
say I want to assign the value of 10 to
X Y and Z so I'll write
x equal to y equal to Z equal to
I'll write 10.
if I run it
and let me print them one by one you can
see here x is 10 Y is 10 and Z is also
10.
now there is
another way to do it that is
I'll pass in my variables X comma y
comma Z
and then
I can write 10 comma 10 comma 10.
this will return the same result
okay
now let's look at the
rules for writing variable names
so these rules we had discussed in the
pbd section
now we'll explore them one by one
so the first rule is a variable name
must start with a letter or the
underscore character
so
let me just give a comment first rules
for
variable
naming
so the first rule says the variable name
must start with a letter or the
underscore character so if I write let's
say
some random variable in ABC equal to 100
this is valid you can print it
ABC it gives me 100.
now
you can also write the variable Limas e
followed by any number
it should be integer number if I write 1
0 2 equal to let's say this time I'll
give a string let's say India
and let me print it
it works perfectly fine
now we also said the name must start
with an underscore
I can start with an underscore and then
write let's say one two three
is equal to 70.5
now let me print it
now this works as well so you can start
your variable name with an underscore
followed by a letter or numbers
let me show you another example this
time I follow the underscore with
letters let's say
dog
I'll just give
any random dog name let's say I have a
dog called puppy
and let's say I'll print it
this also works okay
now you can have multiple underscores in
your name as well suppose I'll write
underscore
name underscore each
this is my variable name I'll write
let's say
Stuart
and let me print it
I wrote underscore name underscore each
this is also a valid variable name so
you can have multiple underscores in
your variable name
now
the next rule is a variable name cannot
start with a number
so if I write
let's say 4
name equal to
okay
and if I try to print it
it will throw an error so you cannot
have a variable name starting with a
number
all right
now
let me scroll down
the next rule is a variable name can
only contain alphanumeric characters and
underscores
so if I write at the rate
then let's say
each
equal to
40. if I run this it throws me an error
because at the rate is not recognized
and it is not a valid variable name
similarly let's say I'll write name
dollar
each
equal to let's say 40.
again this is not recognized dollar you
cannot use it in a variable name
the next rule is
variable names are case sensitive
so suppose I have a variable called car
which is all in lower case and
my car has a value let's say BMW
now if I were to print car it gives me
BMW
now suppose I have another variable
which starts with a capital letter
C followed by lowercase AR
if I were to assign
CR2 let's say Tata
and I print it
it returns me Tata and not BMW so you
should keep in mind that variable names
are case sensitive
similarly I can also have a variable in
all Upper Keys let's say my
car is of Toyota brand
I made a spelling mistake
okay now if I print car
it gives me Toyota
so
these are the different
types of using case sensitive variables
now another important thing to note is
in Python Reserve words cannot be used
as a variable name
so let me open a new tab and here you
will search for
Reserve
keywords
in Python
let me open this link
or any other link for your reference
you see here
these are all
your keywords in Python and these cannot
be used as variable names let's try
using a few of them let's say I use
break
let's assign
a value to variable break equal to let's
say
60 if I run it it gives me an error
invalid syntax break you can't use
similarly let's use
another keyword let's say I'll use for
this time we have a keyword called for
you can see it here
suppose I write
for
equal to
I have let's say Virat
if I run this it throws me an error
again
let's try one more keyword
do we have try as a keyword yes we have
you can see here try is a keyword
if I write try equal to
any random value I'll pick this time I
am giving a floating number let's say
140.5 if I run it again it throws me a
error but you can use
an underscore and then
you can give that keyword let's say try
I'll assign the same value
and let's say we'll print it
this will work fine since
the variable name is no more a keyword
because we have an underscore
in the beginning
okay
now let me show you some
basic operations that you can perform
on python variables let's say we have a
equal to 100 and let's say b equal to
200.
you can assign
an operation to another variable called
result let's say I want
the operation to be an addition
operation
and let's go ahead and print result
you can see it has given us 300 because
in result we are storing the addition of
A and B so 100 plus 200 is 300.
now similarly
you can perform
many operations like let's say this time
will perform a subtraction operation
so this time I am storing
a minus p in result and let's go ahead
and print result you can see here 100
minus 200 is minus 100.
then you can also have
let's say result equal to a by B
and let's print it
fair enough we have 0.5 because 100
divided by 200 is 0.5 similarly you can
also have integer division suppose I
write 100
divided by
say 40
and I'll print the result you see here
it has given us 2.5 but what if I want
to perform an integer division so I'll
add one more forward slash here and
let's run it it gives me only two so it
has truncated the 0.5
okay
now moving ahead
let's say I have a variable called
country
and
I have
India in it
so country is my
variable name and it is pointing to the
object that has
India has the value
I can print the
variable
you see here I have India and now if you
want you can perform some
extraction operation
suppose if I write country
within square brackets if I write
three
it gives me the character that is
present at the third index so I is
present at the zeroth index n is at the
first index D is at the second index and
I is at the third index let's say I want
everything that is present
until the third index it gives me IND
so this 3 is exclusive it will only
return us
the values present at the zeroth index
the first index and the second index
okay
let me show you another interesting
example suppose I have a list that is
called cars and I have a list of
car names
let's say I have
BMW
then I have
Ferrari
and let's say
I have Toyota
I'll run it and I'll print my
list that is cars you can see here there
are three car names
and now what if I want to
put each of these car names in different
variables so I can write X comma y comma
Z and
I'll write equal to cars if I run this
now what it will do is it will assign
each of these values to
X Y and Z respectively now if you want
to print X you can see here x has BMW
then y has Ferrari and Z has Toyota
so this is another way to assign
values to variables
from a list
okay
no
you can also
use variables in the print
function or the print statement suppose
I write X
equal to let's say it has simply loan
now
I can print a message let's say
welcome
to
give a space
close the quotations
do a plus sign and I'll give the
variable name
if I
run it you can see here the message is
printed welcome to and the X which has
the value of Simply loan so welcome to
Simply loan
okay
now another thing to note in Python is
that you cannot add an integer and a
string suppose I have X as the variable
and it has a value let's say 20. and
then I have Y which has
the string simply learn
now string can be put in double quotes
or in single quotes you can use
whichever way you want
suppose I print
X Plus y
let's see the result it gives us an
error so you cannot print
or add an integer and a string so you
need to convert one of these values
now there are several techniques to
write multi-words variables you can use
the camel keys to write Multiverse
variables
so here each word except the first
starts with a capital letter
so I'll just give a comment here and
write
camel case
and
the way to write is
apart from the
first word
all the words
start with the capital letter
suppose I write my department equal to
marketing
so here
the first word my
the M starts with a small letter while
the second word Department the D starts
in a capital letter so this is an
example of a camel keys
Phi
want to print it I can write my
department
run it it gives me marketing let's see
another example I have let's say car
brand
so you see here
car brand are two words
but
the first word starts with a
small letter while the second word has
an uppercase B
let's say my car brand is Hyundai
now you can print it
there you go all right
moving ahead
we also have Pascal case where each word
starts with a capital letter
suppose I have a variable called my name
is
let's say Nathan here you can see my and
Nema two different words and both the
words start with a capital letter so
this is an example of Pascal case
if I run it
let me just print it first okay you see
here I have my name similarly let's say
we have another Pascal case multi-word
variable which is each now where age has
a caps and now has n caps so this is
also an example
of a pascal case variable let's say my
age now equal to 30 I'll print each now
it returns me
30. now one thing to note here is if I
write let's say each now
if I do this it gives me an error
because your variables names are case
sensitive so we haven't created any
variable which has small a and small n
in each now
okay
now the third way to write a multi-word
variable is called as sneak case
so
if you want I can
give a comment saying snake case
so here each word is separated by an
underscore character
so let's say I have a multi-word
variable which is City underscore
address
and let's say the city is
New York
now if I print it
you have New York so this is an example
of a snake case where
each word has a underscore in between
you can have multiple underscore between
each word suppose I write my
current
each
equal to 35 let's say
so I have
my current age
I run it
okay there is some mistake here I have
missed an R you see here it says 35 so
this is also an example of a snake case
where each word is separated by an
underscore so here we have two
underscores
all right now let me go to the top and
let me brief you what we did so first we
saw an
integer
value variable
you saw how you can check the
data type of the variable using the type
function then we explored about the ID
function
we saw how you can
pass in
variables or multiple variables in a
single line
then
we saw how you can assign the same value
to three variables in one line
now this is another method to do the
same operation
now then we looked at the
different rules for naming variables
your variables can start only with a
letter or an underscore
and that letter can be followed up with
numbers as well and you can have
similarly numbers after
underscore you can also have characters
after underscore
you can have multiple underscores
but your variable name cannot start with
a number
and it cannot have special characters
like at the rate or
dollar symbol
these will throw an error
you can see your variable names are case
sensitive so here we defined car in
three different ways
and all the three
give us different results
another important thing we saw was
you cannot use
keywords python keywords as variable
names we saw brick for and try
now we perform some
basic mathematical operations we also
saw how you can perform some extraction
operation using string values in Python
then we saw another way to assign the
values of a list to different variables
we saw how you can use the variable name
in a print statement
then we saw how
you cannot add an integer
with a string
we explored the camel case then we saw
how you can
write multi-word variable using Pascal
keys and finally we looked at
snake case
so in Python every value
has a certain data type
the variables in Python hold an object
of a particular data type
since everything is an object in Python
data types are actually classes and
variables and instances of these classes
now there are various data types in
Python
first we have the numeric types which
are essentially numbers so under numeric
types we have integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
then we have text type data which are in
the form of strings
the third type of data that is available
in Python are called as sequence types
which consists of lists tuples and range
we have already seen about lists and
tuples in our previous video
and in Python we also have dictionary
objects as mapping data types in the
previous video you saw how to map key
value pairs using dictionaries
next
we have set data type now sets are
unordered collection of unique items
python also supports Boolean data types
and finally we have binary types of data
which include bytes byte array and
memory View
now let's head over to the jupyter
notebook where we will learn about these
data types in detail so here I am on my
jupyter notebook and I have titled my
notebook as data types in Python Recs
for recording so let's first start with
numeric data types
I'll give a comment using
a hashtag
I'll write
numeric data type
okay
let me Define a variable called num
in which I'll store a value of 7.
now
let me go ahead and print
the data type of
my variable num so for that I'm using my
function as type
if I
run this using shift plus enter you can
see here it tells me that
num variable is holding a value of type
integer
now you can also
use a print statement
I can write something like print
num
comma
I can give a message as ease of
type
I'll give another comma and then I'll
use my function type of
num
let's see the output
you can see it here
it
first
gets the value that is stored in the
variable num so 7
is of type and then it prints the
classes of type class integer
all right
I've just increased my
size of the notebook
next
let's declare
the same variable num and this time
we'll store the value as let's say 10.8
now you can see here there's a point
which means
this is a decimal
or a floating value if you can check the
type of num it gives us
num is holding a value of type float
now let's see
I'll take a negative number let's say
minus 10.8 and we'll see the
type of num
again minus 10.8 is also of type float
now let's say I'll declare
a complex variable let's say 8 plus 6 J
now this is a complex number
which is again of type
numeric data type
if I want to check the data type of num
it gives me complex because 8 plus 6 J
is of
complex data type
okay
now if you want to extract the real and
the imaginary parts of a complex number
you can do it something like this you
need to pass in the variable name
followed by a DOT and
the attribute name is real to extract
the
real part of the complex number if I run
this you can see here it has written the
real part of the complex number which is
8 now if you want to print the imaginary
part you can use num Dot
imeg which is for Imaginary if I run
this there you go it gives us the
imaginary part which is 6.
okay now in Python you can also perform
conversion of data types so you can
convert between different data types by
using type conversion functions such as
end float Str Etc
so let me Define a variable called num
which has a value 7.8
now
what I'm going to do is
I'm going to create a variable called B
which is going to store the
integer part of num which means
initially I had defined number 7.8 which
is a floating Point number I want to
convert this num to integer type now
and
let me go ahead and
print
my B and I also print
the type of num
and
I'll then print
the type
B
let's run this and see the result okay
so if you see here clearly
when I see
print P it has written me 7 which is of
type integer so it has truncated the
decimal part
present in 7.8
again if I print type of num so num is
holding 7.8 it is of type float after
converting the float value into integer
it has given me int
okay
similarly
let's say we have another number
minus 90.5
and
if I were to check the
type
I would write print type of num
then
let's convert
this to integer
so I'll write print in top num let's see
the results okay so initially minus 90.5
is of type float after we converted
R num to integer it gives us minus 90 so
it has truncated the decimal point part
all right
now let's say I'll create another
variable let's say c equal to
let's say I'll write float
of
B
now if you remember
RB holds a value of 7 if I were to
convert B to float again
I can use the float type conversion
function
and let's go ahead and print C if I run
this you can see here
previously B was holding an integer of
seven now it has converted that integer
into a float value so it is 7.0 now
okay
now moving ahead
let's see
about
Boolean data types
so if I have a variable let's say
r equal to
let's say it has a value called true
which is a type of Boolean value
and let me go ahead and print
the type of r
it gives me Boolean
now let's say I'll write num greater
than C
let's
go to the Top If you see here
num is holding a value of minus 90.5
and my C is holding a value of 7.0 I am
checking if num is greater than C if I
run this it gives me false because
minus 90.5 is less than 7.0 and not
greater than 7.0
suppose
I create a variable Boolean or B Double
L and I'll store that value num greater
than C
and let's
print
the type of Boolean
I'll use type
of my variable That is bull
let's run it you can see it here it
tells us that this particular operation
is now holding a data type of Boolean
if you are getting confused we can
change the
variable here let's see I'll write
B underscore bull
and similarly I'll write here B
underscore bull
let's run it
you get the same thing
all right
now moving ahead
let's explore how
string data types work in Python
I'll give a comment as
string data types
scroll down okay
so string data types or string values in
Python are
passed Within
quotations suppose I have a string
called str1
and it has a value let's say
Python Programming so this is a text
value
I have another string let's say str2
which has a value
let's just simply learn
now
let's run this
okay
now if I were to check
the type of str1
it should give me string so Str here is
a string
now you can also perform extraction
operations from the stream suppose you
want to extract
the value that is present in my first
string that is str1 at index number five
let's run it
okay there is some error here okay so
this should be str1 and not strl
let's run it again
it returns us n
now let's count what is present at the
fifth index so from our previous
introduction to python video you might
be aware that in Python the index number
starts with 0 so if you count
p is at index 0
y is at index 1 T is at index 2 H is at
index 3
o is at index 4 and then
n is at index 5. so hence Str one of
five returns and
similarly if you can
check for
other string that is string two let's
say I want to see the value that is
present
at minus 4.
let's run it
it gives us e
now if you use a negative indexing
operation it will start counting from
the backward position so here n is at
minus 1 R is at minus 2 then you have a
at minus 3 and E is present at -4 so
hence str2 of minus 4 returns e
cool
now you can also perform slicing
operation
suppose
I write str1
I want everything that is present
between the zeroth index to
the fifth index
I'll run it
it gives me
p y t h o so if you check
in string one
it will start counting from the zeroth
index and go up to
the fourth index and exclude the fifth
index so in my string one if I start
counting from the zeroth index so it is
0 1 2 3 and 4 so it will
print from P till o
and that's the result
okay
now you can also use some inbuilt
functions with string suppose I write
str2
Dot
find
so I want to find the index where my
m is in simply learn
so I'll
write M within quotations and print it
it returns me 2.
if you check again
so s is at zeroth index 1 is at the
first index and M is present at the
second index
okay
moving ahead
let's explore a few sequence data types
so we'll start with
list data type
okay
now
first of all let me go ahead and
declare a variable called split one
equal to
and this will have some
text let's say this
is
Orange
then
we're going to create another variable
called L1
equal to
I am going to
split
my variable or my string that is split
one using the split function
and I am going to split using the comma
so you can see here my string has comma
I'm going to separate each of these
words with a comma
and let's print L1
if I run this you can see it here
initially my split one was of type
string
and now we have converted split 1 to a
list you can see this this is a list and
it is present inside square brackets
verify
you can use the type function so I'll
write type of
split one
it should return string you can see it
here Str
and now if I write
type of L1
it gives me a list
okay
now let's see a few more examples I'll
create another list called list one and
let's see it has some values
the alphabet a
we have
the number one which is in terms of
string again because I have passed in in
quotes
let's see I have India
let's make it consistent with single
quotations
and
let me
print what is inside list one
if I run it I get my list
now you can check the data type
if I write type of list one it gives me
it is of type list
now you can also perform certain
operations on list suppose you want to
add a few elements to your original list
for that I am going to create another
variable called list two
and let's say list 2 has some values
let's say B comma 2.
now
if I write
list 1
plus equal to
list 2.
and let me go ahead and
print
list one
let's see the result
there you go so our initial list had
three elements A1 and India and now we
have merged or concatenated two more
elements B and 2 and hence this becomes
our final list
okay
now moving ahead let's see one more
sequence data type that is Tuple or
Tuple
Now list 10 tuples we have already
covered in our previous video on
introduction to python if you need to
brush up what list and tuples are you
can check the previous video
so I'm going to create a tuple that is
top one and I'm going to
store some values
Tuple you can create using braces
I have some value let's say e b
C
d
and let's say e
or let's just restrict it to D
now you can check the type of top one
you can see here tup1 is of type Tuple
now
I'll create another Tuple let's say tup2
and
it has some values let's say e
f
and let's say G
now
if I write
tup1 Plus
equal to dup2
and if I print
my tup1
I get the result
of a merged
Tuple which has values of both top one
and tup2 you can see here our original
Tuple had ABCD and then we merged the
second Tuple and it has
and it has given us EFG as well and
hence this becomes the final Tuple
you can also perform some basic
operations on Tuple let's say I'll write
up one multiplied by 2.
you can see the result here
it has printed
my original Tuple twice
okay
now moving ahead
let's see our mapping data type
that is dictionary
again dictionary is also covered
in our previous
introduction to python video
you can also have a look at that video
now the way to declare a dictionary
is
I'll create a variable dict1
and dictionaries are
written using curly braces and have key
value peers
so I'll write my first key as 1 and
let's say
this dictionary is about animals
and I have let's say lion
as my first animal in the dictionary
then I'll create my second key
let's see the second Animal I Have Is
tiger
and let's say
my third element
is
a dog
let me run it
and print
my dictionary you can see this
we have the dictionary printed
now if you want to check the type you
can write type of
dict1
it returns us dict which means
dictionary
you can also print the length of
dict1
and it gives us 3 which means our
dictionary has three elements
okay
now moving ahead
we'll explore
our set data type
now as we understood that sets are
unordered collections of
values
and these values are always unique
so I'll write set one let me give a
space
equal to
again sets are written within curly
braces
I'll create a set
let's say it has some duplicate entries
as well
and I'll print my set one
it returns only the unique values so it
has dropped
this 5 which was duplicated
you can check the type of set one
it gives us it is of type or the object
is of type set
now suppose
I have
another set called set 2
which has values let's say
a
comma
p
and let's say we have some numbers 3 and
4.
I'll tell you the operation that I'm
going to do
I'm actually going to
do an or operation
so I'm going to print
set one
or
set
2 so this is an R operator in Python
let's print the results you can see here
it has printed
all the values that are present inside
set 1 or set 2. so in set 1 we have one
two three four and five
and in set 2 We Have A and P
so it has dropped 3 and 4 because these
are not unique and
3 and 4 are also presented set one
suppose I were to perform an and
operation
I'll write set one
Ampersand set 2.
if I run this
you can see here it has only printed
the unique values that are present in
both set 1 and set two so three and four
are the unique values and hence it has
printed three and four
let's say
I'll write set 1 minus set 2.
let's see the results
it gives us only those values that are
present
in set 1
and are not present in set 2 which is
this
let's see the result if I write set to
minus set 1.
so this will return the unique values
that are present in set 2 and are not
present in set one
so A and B are the unique values that
are present in set to hence it has
printed as a comma B
okay
now
another data type we had discussed was
range
so range is basically a function if I
write x equal to
range
and I'll print X it gives us from 0 till
4 because in Python the first index
starts from 0 and goes
till 4 so the range is from 0 to 4.
now you can also print that type of x
it returns us a range
now
we'll see some binary data types
binary data types are not very often
used in Python but it is better if you
know
binary data types can be written as x
equal to B let's say I have a string
I'll write within double quotations
hello world
and let me go ahead and
print
my variable X
you see here
we have hello world
and now
let's print the type of X you see here
this is a binary type which is bytes
I'll show you another operation let's
say you want to extract a specific
value
from a particular index
from this binary data
so again you can use the indexing
operation
suppose I write print
I want to extract the value present at
the fourth index
it gives me one one one now this is very
interesting let's
deep dive into this
let's check
what is present at the fourth index of
my string
so H is present at the zeroth index E is
at the first index L is at the second
index the second L is at the third index
and we have o
at the fourth index
so
when we are trying to print the index
position it is actually returning us the
ASCII value of small o now here I have a
dock open which is from IBM
documentation if you see
the
ASCII value of small o or lowercase o
you will find that the ASCII value is
one one one and hence it has written
does one one one
let's try for
another
index number let's say I want to find
the value which is present at index
number
minus
2 and if I run it it gives me 108
so minus 2 means it will start from the
last index
so minus 1 is D and minus 2 is L let's
see what is the ASCII value of L
if you see it here the ASCII value of L
is 108.
and hence it has written as 108
so this is how the binary data types
work in Python
now let's convert some
sequence objects to other type of
objects let's say I have a string
called s which has
something like
messy is from
Argentina
now you can check
the type of s fair enough it tells us
that Messi is from Argentina is of type
string
now
what I'm going to do is I'll use my list
function and pass in my variable that is
s so that it converts s to a list and
let me go ahead and print my l
you can see here my string s has now
been converted into a list and this is
the result
see here these are all
list elements present inside square
brackets
now if you want you can check the type
of file
it should return us
list
and you can see it here
now suppose
I have
another list let's say L1 which has
some
numbers let's say
15 3 6 0 8 4 and 3.
Let's see we also have one
okay so this is a list you can check
type of L1
fair enough it tells us that this is a
list
now I want to convert this list L1 to a
set now as we know that set only
contains
unordered unique elements
so if I write s equal to
I'll use the set function and then I'll
pass in my list variable that is L1
and let's print as
it only returns me the unique values
present in the list so it has dropped
the duplicate elements such as 3 and 1.
now you can check the type
of s it gives us set
okay so that brings us to the end of
this demo session on data types in
Python let me go to the top and
I'll brief you what we did in this demo
so first we looked at the different
numeric data types so we saw integer
data type and then we saw floating data
type
we also had complex data types
we saw how to extract a real part in
imaginary part from a complex number
then we used
some type conversion functions to
convert the numeric data types from one
data type to another so here we
converted a floating type data to an
integer type data
similarly
we saw how to use Boolean data types
then we saw about string data types we
also performed some basic operations of
using indexing method to extract
different values
we also saw how you can use slicing to
extract a range of values from your
string use the find function to find the
index of a particular
character in the string
then we learned the important sequence
data types like list
then we had
tuples
and then we learned about mapping data
types such as dictionary
we also looked at set data type
now
later on we explored about range data
type and we looked at binary data types
we saw how binary data type returns
ASCII value of a certain character
finally we converted strings to list and
then we saw how to convert
list to sets
so we are going to talk about object
types in Python then we'll see the
different type conversion functions that
are available in Python
then we see the different types of type
conversion
all right
now let's look at the different types of
objects in Python
so we have less
you have tuples numbers strings
dictionaries sets you even have file
objects
then you can see we also have other code
types such as Boolean and none
then we have program unit types like
functions modules and classes
now we will touch upon most of them in
the demo section of this tutorial then
we also have implemented related types
all right
now let's see how you can convert one
data type to another using type
conversion so python provides two types
of data conversion techniques one is
called the implicit type conversion and
the other is called the explicit type
conversion now in implicit data type
conversion python can automatically
convert one data type to another data
type this process does not need any user
involvement
while in external conversions
users convert the data type of an object
to require data type by using predefined
functions that are listed here so you
can see here we have the different
functions so if you want to convert a
specific value to an integer you can use
the int function we have the float
function
now we have something called this ORD so
the ORD function accepts a string of
unit length as an argument and Returns
the Unicode equivalence of the past
argument now we also have
hex and OCT so the hex function
is used to convert an integer number to
its corresponding hexadecimal value
similarly the oct function will convert
the corresponding
or let's say We'll convert an integer
number to its corresponding OCTA decimal
value
we have double list set dictionary Str
is for string you can convert a number
into a complex number by providing its
real and imaginary part we also have
this CHR or the character function
now this is how the basic General syntax
looks like you have the required data
type followed by the expression
okay
so let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and learn the different types
of objects as well as look at the type
conversions in Python
okay so here I am on my jupyter notebook
let's first look at
number objects so I'm giving a
comment
as number objects all right let's see I
have a variable called num
which is equal to let's say 2.
now
is very simple that 2 is an integer
so we want to check the type
you can just use the type function and
it gives us int which means integer so
here 2 is of
a type called number object
let's say you want to pass a floating
value
that's a 2.2
see the results
2.0 is of type float and again 2.0 or
2.0 is a number object
now you can perform various operations
on number objects suppose you want to
add a few numbers
so let's say 321 Plus 365.
and I'll say add
it gives us the addition of these two
numbers which is 686.
now let's see
you want to
perform a multiplication operation
let's say 62 multiplied by 2.5
if I hit shift enter it gives me the
multiplication of the product of these
two numbers that is 55.0
now python by default will
convert the result to a floating Point
number if there is one integer and this
one float
if you want to return the exponent of a
number let's say I want to know 2 raised
to the power 4
so I'm using double asterisks to
represent the exponent operator if I hit
shift enter it gives us 16 so it's
basically 2 multiplied four times
now you can also
import specific libraries so let's say I
want to import the math library and I
want to print
the value of pi so here I have written
import math and then using the module
math I am
trying to find the value of pi let's run
it you see here it says 3.141 so on and
so forth
now you can also
import the random module let's say I'll
write import
random and then let's say I want to
print a random number
you can use the random Dot
random function let's run it you see
here this is a random value that
python has generated if I run it again
this value changes let's run it again
again this value changes
okay
now we'll shift our Focus to
understanding string objects in Python
so I'll give a comment string objects
let's say I have a string
e is equal to and let's say the string
has India
okay
now if you want you can print a it says
India
now suppose I want to
extract
the value that is present at the zeroth
index of the string so the way to do is
I'll pass in my variable name that is e
and within square brackets I'll give the
index value that is 0. now one thing to
remember in Python the index value
starts with 0 and not one so if I do a
of 0 it gives me I because I is present
at the 0th index now let's say I want
the last value
in this string India so I need to return
a for that I can use negative indexing
by using minus 1. if I do minus 1 it
gives me a which is the element present
at the last index
now let's say
I'll write a 1 and colon
let's run it you see the result here it
says n d i a which means python has
returned everything starting from the
first index
till the last index so here colon means
you need to return everything that comes
after the first index
now let's see
I'll write
print
a
and I'll add
let's say x y z
let's run it
you see here this x y z has been
concatenated with the value that was
present inside a that is India so the
result is India followed by x y z okay
now
if I write e multiplied by 7
it will print India seven times without
a space you can see it here
cool
now let's say you want to replace
certain values in the string you can use
the replace function so if I write a DOT
replace let's say I want to replace ie
that is present in India
with let's say
x y z
let's run it you see here
IND is fine after that we have I a and
that I a has been replaced by XYZ
now let's move on and understand
list objects in Python so I'll write
list objects
okay
so let's go ahead and declare a list L1
within square brackets
let's say we have
values like 1 0 1
let's say America
and then let's say we have another
floating value let's say 2.05
foreign
if you want to print the list you can
use
L1 to print it you see here this is my
list L1 now if you want to find the
length of L1 you can use the Len
function
if I run it you get 3 which means there
are three elements in the list 101
America and 2.05
now if you want to extract certain
values from the list for that you can
use the indexing method let's say I'll
write
L1 of
1.
that gives me America because
at index position 1 we have America so
101 is at the zeroth index America is at
the first index and 2.05 is at the
second index
next
let's say I write L1
and then
I give colon -1 let's print it so that
gives me
101 in America so what it does is this
colon -1 will exclude the last index and
print the other two
elements in the list
okay
now if you want to append
some elements to the list you can use
the append method so I write L1 dot
append within brackets I'll give my
value let's say
USA
now let's go ahead and print L1
if I run it you can see the difference
earlier my list had three elements 101
America and 2.05 now we have added the
fourth element that is USA
cool
now you can also use the pop function in
python let's see what it does
so I write L1 dot pop and I'll give
let's say three
if I run it it returns me
USA because USA is present at the third
index of my list
if I write pop one
it gives me America because
America is present at the first index
all right now you can also reverse the
elements in a list if I write L1 Dot
reverse function
if I run this and then I'll
print L1
you see the result here we have 2.05 and
101 which is printed in reverse order
the reason being
we have already popped America and USA
out and we are only left with 101 and
205 and if we reverse the current list
it will be printed as follows so 2.05
comes at the beginning and then we have
1 0 1. let me just
read on my list again to show you the
difference
I have run my L1
let's run this append query
and now let's use the reverse function
there you go
so now our original list has been
reversed so you have us at the beginning
and 101 towards the end
okay
now moving ahead let's see
the next type of object in Python that
is dictionaries
okay
let's say I'll create a dictionary
called dict1
and you might be aware that dictionaries
are created using the curly braces
so I'll have my key value pairs let's
say my key is 1 and the value it whole
says let's say
the names of animals
tiger
comma
will have the second key and that second
key will have the value let's say lion
and let's say we have another element
with the third key
Let's see we have
Mouse
okay
now
let's print our dictionary
so this is how
my dictionary looks like
now
you can display the keys
by using the keys function
so this will return all the keys present
in the dictionary you see here one two
and three are my keys similarly
you can display the values in the
dictionary
you need to change this keys to values
if I run it you see here tiger lion and
mouse are the three values
now suppose you want to add another
element to your dictionary for that you
can write dict1
and give the fourth key
equal to the value let's say that
now let's run
dict1 and see the difference
there you go so here we have added
another element to the dictionary which
is cat
now moving ahead let's explore
double objects
okay so we'll create a tuple called T1
equal to
we'll have the values 1 comma 2 comma 3
comma four
and let's say you want to print the
length of Tuple T1 it gives you 4
because we have four elements in the
Tuple T1
now let's say I'll declare
one more Tuple called T2 and this time
we'll have two more elements in the
Tuple so I'll write T1 Plus
followed by the two elements that I want
let's say seven comma 9 and I'll print
T2
if I run it you can see here we have
added 7 and 9 to our original Tuple that
had one comma 2 comma three comma four
now you can also use the indexing method
or the slicing technique to extract
values from the topper let's say I write
T2 of 3 it will return the third element
that is present in Tuple
T2 so if you see here
my third index has the element 4 hence
it has returned 4.
cool
now moving ahead
let's see
how file objects work in Python
all right
Now using python you can create files
let's say I want to create a text file
in Python using the jupyter notebook for
that I can write F1 equal to
I'll use a function called open
and inside this open function I want to
create a text file and first I'll write
something into that file
let me show you so this is a folder that
I have
the folder name is called object types
and it is present in my desktop so I'll
use this location
and here you can see now this folder
contains no files as of now but we are
going to create text file using python
let's see how to do it
so here I'll paste my
location that I've just copied
now one thing to note is you need to
convert everything to
forward slash or you can use
double backslash also
I'll give another forward slash and
let's say I want to
create a file in the name of data.txt so
it is going to be a text file make sure
everything is
inside single quotation
and I want to open the file in
write mode so I'll write w here let's
run it and see the difference now if we
check our folder you see here earlier
there was no data file now we have
created a text file in the name of data
you see here
there are no
information or data inside this text
file next we are going to add some data
to this text file
let's
go back to our jupyter notebook okay
so we'll write some data to that file so
I'll write F1 Dot
after that I'll use the write function
and within single quotations I'll write
let's say hello
simply learn
and then
I'll give backslash n to go to the next
line
I'll write again F1 dot write
and I'll pass in another message let's
say welcome to
python
programming
and we'll give another backslash
followed by n
and then finally we'll close the file so
I'll write F1 Dot
close function
let's run this
and we'll see the difference now
if I open this there you go we have some
data in this text file that is hello
simply loan welcome to Python
programming
so this is how file objects work in
python
all right
now moving ahead we'll see how
sets work in Python
suppose I create a set called s
and I'll use the set function
and I'll pass in
India
so this is a string
and I want to convert this string to a
set
let's say I have another
set called S1
and here I have
a list of values let's say U
s
and let's say a
now if I write s comma
S1
so what set does is it will return only
the unique values that are present
inside each set so here if you see India
all the elements are unique except I
because I is repeated twice so it will
return I only once in the result but USA
has all the elements present only once
so
set will return all the elements
now what if I'll
write let's say s
am percent
S1
so
this will give me only the
common element that is present in both
the sets so if you see here in India and
in U S and E
only a is repeating in both the sets so
it gives me a
suppose I write
s
is the or operator and I'll write S1
if I run it it gives me
all the elements that are present inside
set s and S1
excluding the repeating elements so here
I is repeating so it has printed only
once
similarly you can write
s minus S1
so you get
only those elements that are present
inside
s and are not present in set S1
now in set s e is present as well as is
present in set S1 so it has excluded E
from the result
okay
now we'll see some operations let's say
I'll write equal to 7 and be equal to
let's say 2.2
I'll
add e and B and store the result in
my variable R which stands for result
let's see
the output if I write print
are
it gives me 9.0 and if I check
type of R it gives me
there's a spelling mistake I'll write
type of R it gives me float so here
python is performing implicit
type conversion so if you add an integer
with a floating Point number the result
will be a floating Point number and not
an integer
now if you
see equal to 7 and let's say b equal to
C 2.0
and this time I am explicitly defining
my result to be an integer so I am using
an integer function so if I write a
Plus
B
and if I print r you see the result it
has given me an integer which is 9. now
to verify you can also use
type of r
it gives me integer but earlier
it returned us float
so this is how
implicit and explicit conversion work in
Python
now this example was for numbers
similarly you can
also
perform for Strings
and for less tuples and sets
now moving ahead
one thing I wanted to tell you was you
cannot add a string and an integer
suppose
I'll give a comment string and integer
Edition
suppose I have a variable called e which
has a value of a 7 so 7 is an integer
here then I have a variable called P
which has a value 2 but this time I'll
assign this 2 Within
quotes So this becomes of type string
now if you want you can check that as
well if I write type of 2
rather type of P it will give us Str
which means string
so let's see
I'll write R which stands for result
equal to
a plus b
now if I print r
it will give us an error because you
cannot add a string with an integer so
it says unsupported operand
the way to fix this is you need to
convert this string into an integer
explicitly
so this time we'll say equal to 7
B
equal to
2 so it is a string
now I'll write r equal to
a plus I'm going to use the integer
function or the int function to convert
my B to an integer
and then I'll print R again let's do
this there you go so here we have
converted my string value to
a numeric value
of 2 and this time it works fine so 7
plus 2 is 9.
okay
now let's see how you can convert a
float value or a floating number into an
integer number let's say I have a
variable called a which has a value
let's say 77.9
and I'm going to create another variable
called int underscore e and I'll pass
this to my integer function
so it has int of a now let's print
int underscore e
so you have 77 so my integer function
has truncated the decimal point value
that had 0.9
if you want to check the type you can
use
type function I'll write type of
int underscore e
so it gives us integer
now you can also convert an integer to a
floating point value
so if I have a variable called a that
has a value of let's say
and if I write
float underscore a equal to I'll use the
float function to convert the variable e
to a floating point value
and let's print float underscore a so it
gives us
50.0 instead of 50. you can also check
the type
of float a
it gives you float
okay
now you can also convert an integer to a
complex number
let's say I'll take the same value equal
to 50 I'll write comp underscore e which
stands for complex e I'll use the
complex function
and pass in my
variable that is e
now let's print
comp underscore a
so it gives us 50.0 J so 50 is the real
part and 0 J is the imaginary part
you can also convert an
integer to a string
I'll take the same value let's say 50
I'll write Str underscore a equal to
Str of a so I'm using the string
function to convert my integer to a
string
let's print Str underscore e
it should be an underscore and not an
hyphen
let's run it there you go you have 50
within single quotes
you can also check the type of a
Str underscore a it gives you string
cool
now
we learn how to convert a string to a
tuple
so let's say I have a string that has
India as its value
if I write TS equal to
I'll use the Tuple function and pass in
my variable that is s
and then we'll print TS
you can see here
python has converted my string s which
had India into a tuple of individual
elements and my Tuple is present inside
brackets
cool
now similarly you can convert a string
to a list
I'll use the same string as equal to
India
and then let's say I want to convert it
to a list I'll use L1 equal to
followed by the list function and inside
the list function I'll pass in my
variable that is s
and let's print L1 and see the
difference
you see here my string has now be
converted into a list you can also check
the data type of L1 or the object type
of L1 it returns you list
similarly you can also check the type of
TS
it gives you Tuple because we converted
that string to a tuple
now let's explore how you can convert a
tuple to a list let's say you have a
tuple called T and it has a list of
names let's say John
we have Mary
then we have let's say mark
now to convert into a list we'll use the
list function again let's say L2
equal to list of
t
and let's print L2
so this is a list because it is present
inside
square brackets
you can check the type of
t
so T is a tuple you see here
if I change this to L2
it gives you list
cool
now
moving to the next section where we'll
see how to convert
integer to binary
suppose I have a variable called a equal
to 10.
and then
I have P equal to bin of a
let's say we have another variable which
is C
and here I want to convert my integer
into a
hexadecimal value or a octa decimal
value for that you can write D equal to
use the oct function for
OCTA decimal value
okay now we are going to print them one
by one so I'll write print of B
print of C
and then we'll print what is there
inside d
will run it and you can see the results
here so binary of 10 you see here
hexadecimal of 10 you see the value here
this is an extra decimal value
then you have the OCTA decimal value of
a
okay
now moving to the final section of this
demo
you can convert a number to its
corresponding ASCII character
let me show you how to do it suppose I
have
N1 equal to
76.
now if I write
CHR of
N1 and run it it gives me l
now let's see our ASCII table so this is
my ASCII table and
for 76 you can see here the character is
l
so this CHR of N1 will return
the corresponding ASCII character for
that particular number so here 76
belongs to l let's say we have another
number and 2 equal to let's say 100. now
if I write CHR of N2
and run it it gives me
lowercase D we'll see the table again
and if you see for 100 we have lowercase
D now here you have a list of characters
these are special characters you have
uppercase characters you have at the
rate you have numbers each of them have
their own ASCII values
cool
now
you can convert string character into
Unicode values now let me tell you what
Unicode value is so computers on a basic
level deal with numbers so letters that
appear on computers are stored by
computers as a list of numbers so the
Unicode standard provides a unique
number for every character and supports
multiple languages and all special
characters
so let's see I have a string s which has
the value of capital A or uppercase E if
I write R which stands for result equal
to ord so this is the function which
converts a string to a Unicode value
I'll write ORD of s and we'll print our
if I run it it gives me 65 so
65 is the Unicode value of a
you can also have digits let's say I
have seven
I'll run it so 55 is the unique code
value of the string 7.
let's try for any other letter let's see
V and run it you have 86 okay
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session
first we will learn different number
data types in Python then we will learn
type conversion between number data
types and after that we will understand
how to represent binary hexadecimal and
octal numbers in Python and then we will
understand different number functions in
Python
a programming language needs to have
support for numbers to carry out
calculations in Python the numbers are
categorized into different data types
types are implemented in python as
classes there are three numeric types in
Python and for integers float for
decimal numbers and complex for complex
numbers let's explore these data types
in jupyter Notebook
I have opened my jupyter notebook and
now let's see different data types in
Jupiter notebook
for example first we'll assign a number
to a variable
num variable equal to 7
and now we will check the type of this
num variable for that we'll write the
command type round brackets num round
bracket close and then we will run this
command
we will get int as the data type
now we will assign a decimal number to
the num variable that would be num equal
to 7.7 and now we will check the type of
the num variable
and run this command
what we get is the float float as the
data type for the num variable
now we will assign a complex number to
the num variable
and we will check the type for this num
variable
and run the command
we will get the complex data type as the
result
now if you want to get the real part of
this complex number
you just have to write the command num
dot real
and just execute the command you will
get 6.0 as the real part of this complex
number here you can see you just code
the number in float data type
the complex number in Python are stored
in flow data types whether it's the real
part or it's the imaginary part now
we'll see the imaginary part
num dot image and now you will run this
command you will get 7.0
here also you can see that the imaginary
part is also stored as float
in Python for complex number
now we will perform different arithmetic
operations with these data types
first we will mention
arithmetic operations
now we will assign numbers to the
variables and perform different direct
metric operations for that we will
assign
17 as a number to the variable num1
num1 equal to 17
and the second variable num2 we will
assign the number 25
and now we will perform different
arithmetic operations first we'll start
with addition
so we'll write the simple command that
would print
num1 Plus
num2 and just run that command
you can see the result as 42 it's as
simple as that in Python you just have
to write print and in round brackets
just write the operation you wanna
execute
now we will see the subtraction part
we'll write print
num2 minus num1
and execute this command and we'll get
the result as 8.
now we see multiplication
print
number
into
num2
and execute this command and we'll get
the result as 425
now we will divide
print
num2 divided by num1
and execute this command
and we will get 1.47
here you can see as we have assigned int
values to the num1 and num2 variable we
got the result for addition subtraction
and multiplication as in data type only
but for division we quoted as float
this is because python always gives the
output for division in decimal numbers
only just to have minimum accuracy laws
so if you want to just get the output of
the division as an end value you just
have to perform this
print
num2 and 2 slash signs and then number
one and then execute the command
you will get 1 as the output
so to just get int as the output of the
division you can use two slashes
next command we'll see is to raise a
number
to another number
so to just get 2 to the power of 4 we'll
write the command print
to
two asterisk symbols and four
and just execute this command you will
get the output as 16.
we got 2 to the power of 4 by just using
two asterisk symbols now to get the
remainder of the division
we just have to use the modulus symbol
so for that print
for modulus 2 and just execute the
command
you will get 0 as the remainder
you can perform the same operations on
float numbers and complex numbers now we
will see an arithmetic operation on
complex number
so we will assign a complex number to
variable
that would be G equal to 1
Plus
5j
and another variable we will assign the
value 2 plus
3j
and we'll assign the operation I equal
to G slash H that is the reason
and
print the output
and we'll execute the command
we will get the following result for the
division of two complex numbers
now we will see type conversions in
Python for that we will move
there are mainly two types of
conversions between numbers in Python
first is using arithmetic operations
that is implicit type conversion and
second is using built-in functions that
is explicit type conversion
let's understand the concept of
conversion with the help of Jupiter
notebook
so here
we will write first conversions
first we will assign a number to a
variable that would be a equal to 196
and we have seen in the previous
examples that its type is int now if we
put this number in two double quotes
and now we'll check its type
that would be type
a
and run the command we'll get it as
string so in Python when we just put a
number in double quotes it will see it
as a string
and to get this number as an INT we just
have to use explicit type conversion for
that we will write
B
equal to
end
a
and now we will check its type
B
and run the command we'll get into the
data type for the B variable
the a variable is still the string data
type and B variable has now turned as
int data type
and now
to turn a as a flow data type we can
write c equal to
float
a
and check its type
type
C and run the command and here we can
see that it has turned into the flow
data type so a still the string data
type but C has been converted the a
variable into the flow data type
we can also convert the a string data
type into complex data type
just
we have to write t equal to
complex
and in Brackets we have to write a
and we can check its type
and we can
print
the T complex number and we have just
execute the command
and we can see
that the complex number is 196 plus 0 J
and we can also check its type by just
writing
print
type D
and we'll run the command and we can see
that the class is complex for the
variable d
we can Define the complex data type by
different methods one of the method is
we just have to write print
complex and then round brackets we just
have to assign both real and the
imaginary numbers that would be 3 comma
6. and just execute the command
and here we go to complex number that is
3 plus 6 J
now we have seen the explicit type
convergence
now we will see some implicit type
convergence that is using arithmetic
operations for that we will assign
a float number that would be 2.6
to a variable equal to 2.6
and b equal to 6
and we will assign an arithmetic
operation that would be c equal to a
plus b
and
print the output
and execute the command
by using just arithmetic operations we
have seen that the addition of a float
number and the integer number turns out
to be a float number so now we have seen
the implicit type conversion example
now we will see the representation of
binary hexadecimal and octal numbers in
Python
all the integer numbers can be
represented as binary hexadecimal and
octal
to represent it as binary in Python we
have to prefix it by using 0 small b or
0 capital B and for octal we can prefix
it by using 0
small 0 or 0 capital O and for
hexadecimal we can use 0 x or 0 capital
x let's see this representation in
Jupiter notebook
first we will write representation of
binary hexadecimal and octal numbers
now
we will first see binary to decimal
conversion
for that
we will first write
B
1 1 0 1 1 0 0.
and then we'll just run it and see 216
as the decimal conversion of this binary
number
now we'll see the same for the outer for
that we'll write 0
12 and just run this command
and we can see that it has turned 10 in
the decimal number system
for hexadecimal we will write 0
small X
and 12 and just run the command
and we can see 18 as the decimal
conversion of the hexadecimal number
system
we can also use 0 capital X
12 and just run the command we'll see 18
the same output as of 0 small X 12.
let's see some operations with fractions
for that first we will comment fractions
now we will import the fraction module
for that we'll write from
fractions
import
fraction
as f
and first I will
execute the addition operation for
fractions for that we'll write print
f
1 comma 3
just for the fraction numerator would be
1 and the denominator would be 3.
now we'll write the operation addition
and F the second fraction that would be
okay we will write the same only 1 comma
3 and on execution of the command we
will get 2 by 3 as the output
we can also perform different operations
okay we will just see the reciprocal of
the fraction for that we'll write print
well
1 upon f
5 comma 6
and just run the command
here we can see the reciprocal function
that would turn out to be six by five
now you will explore different number
functions
first one that would we would explore
would be absolute
absolute function would turn any
negative number into the positive number
for that we'll just assign a number that
would be x equal to minus
9.8
and
we will just apply the absolute function
abs
on the variable X
and just run the command
here we can see that has turned x equal
to minus 9.8 to 9.8
now
we will see some different functions for
that we will import the math module
import
math
and we have different values stored in
the math module for example by
going to print the pi value print
math dot pi
and run the command
here we can see the value of the pi
3.1415 nine two six five three five
eight nine seven nine three
we also have exponential value in math
module for that we'll write the command
print
math dot e and execute the command
here we will get the value
2.718281828459045
for the value of e in the math module
now we will also see exponential to the
power 10. for that we will write the
command print
math dot exp round brackets
and execute the command
we will get the value 22 0 to 6.465
we can also perform log operations
for that we will write the command print
and we will get the logo of 1000 to the
base of 10. for that we'll write
math
Dot
log
to the page 10
the value would be
a thousand and we will execute the
command and we will get 3.0
you can also get the factorial by the
math module
we'll write print
math
dot factorial
factorial of 6.
and we'll execute the command and we
quote the factorial of 6 that is 720.
now if we want the square root of a
number we will write the command print
math Dot sqrt
and in round brackets we will write the
number for which we need the square root
we'll write 25 and execute the command
and we will get 5.0
this square root number gives the float
number as its output
and we can also find out the maximum
numbers from a bunch of numbers for that
we have to write the command
Max round brackets and the bunch of
numbers from which you want the maximum
value
1 comma 33 comma 55 comma
7 comma 99 and just execute the command
you will get the maximum number that
would be 99 and if you want the minimum
number you can write the command main
and in round brackets just write the
bunch of numbers
1 comma 3 comma 66 comma 88 comma
7.
and just execute the command
you will get the minimum number that
would be 1.
now we'll see the ceiling function for
that we'll write the command
print
math
dot seal and in down bracket so write
the number for which we want to use the
sending function minus 43.5
and execute the command
you will get minus 43. so what the
ceiling function does is it would give
the highest value or the greatest value
for the number we have entered in the
ceiling function
now we'll see the floor function for
that we'll write the command print
bracket math dot floor
and we'll write the number for which we
want to use the flow function
minus 43.5
and execute the command
we'll get minus 44.
so the floor function will give the
output value just below the or just the
lowest value
of the value entered by us in the flow
function
now we will see the power function for
that we'll write the command print
math dot pow and in round brackets we
will write the number
to
and the power which we want that would
be 6 and just execute the command
here we can see that 2 to the power 6 we
have got the output value is 64.
now we'll see some trigonometric
functions
first we will see COS of x
like python number method course Returns
the cosine of x radians for that we will
write the command
print
math Dot
COS of 0
and just run the command it will give
one as the output
so this method returns a numeric value
between -1 and 1 like which represents
the cosine of the angle
we will see another example for course
for that we'll write print
math dot course and in Brackets we'll
write the angle math
dot pi
and we'll execute the command
and we will get the output as -1
now we'll see 10 trigonometric function
so the python method 10 it Returns the
tangent of X radians
for that we will write the command
print
math dot 10
of angle 0 and we will execute the
command
we will get 0 as output this method
returns a numeric value between -1 and
1. which represents the tangent of the
perimeter X
we will also see another example for Tan
we will write
print
math dot 10
math Dot
5 by
4 and execute the command
which gives us 0.99999 that turns out to
be 1.
now we will explore some random number
functions for that we will write the
command
import random
and import the random module
now we'll see the first function that
would be Rand range for that we'll write
the command print
random Dot
Rand range and in circular brackets we
will write the range from which we want
the random number
that would be 10 comma 20
and execute the command here we go 12 as
the random number
now we will Define a list that would be
x equal to
square brackets
one
two
three
four
and five
now we'll see another function
that would be choice and it would give
any random number from string
list or Tuple
so for that we'll write the command
print
random Dot
choice and in circular brackets we'll
write
or we will pass any list string or Tuple
here we will pass this list X and
execute this command
we will get the random number three
okay
so we'll understand what is the string
in Python and how to create strings in
Python then we look at the different
string Methods and how to perform string
indexing and all these we'll see with
the help of Hands-On demonstrations on
The jupyter Notebook
so let's understand what is a string
so a string in Python is an object that
represents a sequence of characters
in Python we have Str as the data type
of string
now you can create strings
using single quotes or double quotes so
here is an example
where we have used a single code to
write a string so our string is hello
India which is inside a single code
below if you see we have the same string
written within double quotes so these
are the two methods in which you can
create strings in Python now you can
also use triple quotes which are
generally for multi-line Strings or doc
strings so here is an example we have a
string called str3 and the content it
has is human psychology is an
interesting subject now if you print the
string it will be printed in two lines
and not in a single line
now we'll be exploring much more in
detail in our demo session so please
wait for a while next we have string
indexing so if you want to extract a few
characters from your string you can use
the indexing method so in Python
a string starts with the index number 0
so here we have a string which is
healthy
and
the first element is present at the
zeroth index so at the bottom you see
the forward index on the top you have
the reverse index or the negative
indexes
so in python as I said the first index
is at the zeroth position so H is at 0 E
is at the first index a is at the second
index so on and so forth
now similarly if you look at negative
indexing it starts with minus 1 in
reverse order so we have minus 1
for y minus 2 for H minus 3 for T and so
on and so forth now let's head over to
our jupyter notebook where we'll learn
about strings in Python in detail
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook
first I'll create a
new notebook I'll click on new and then
select python 3.
okay
so here let me
rename my notebook as
strings in python demo
I'll click on rename
okay
now let's start with our first example
I'll create a variable called str1 that
will have a string
you can see here I am using single
quotes now I'll write hi
Sam
so here
str1 is holding a string called high Sam
and let's go ahead and print the string
str1
I'll hit shift enter to run it you see
here I have my string printed high Sam
now if you want to check the
data type
that str1 holds you can use the type
function
and inside the type function I'll pass
in my variable str1 if I run it you see
here it gives us Str which means
it is of type string
now let's create another string str2
using double quotes this time so I'll
write let's say
hello
Angela
I can give exclamation mark
okay now let's just print the second
string you see here this is my second
string which is hello Angela if you want
you can also use the print function here
and run it you get hello Angela
now let's
write a multi-line string using triple
quotes so I'll write str3 equal to
I'll use triple quotes
and then
I'll say
hi everyone
go to the next line I'll write today
we will
learn about
I'll go to the next line and I'll write
strings in Python
then I'll again give triple quotes to
close my string
and let's just print this str3
if I run it you can see it here I have
now written a multi-line string hi
everyone today we will learn about
strings in Python let me just add a s
there you go okay
now coming to the next topic we'll learn
about indexing
all right
let me declare a string str1
which has
value as simply loan
now
to use indexing and extract
certain
items in a string or values in a string
you can use square brackets and inside
the square brackets you can give the
index position
for example if I write str1
and in the square bracket I'll give
let's say I want to find the element or
the value present at the zeroth index
let's run it it gives me S because as we
learned in the slides
the first index in a string starts with
the zeroth number so I have S in my
zeroth index so hence it has printed s
let's explore a few more if I write str1
of let's say I want to know what is
present at the third index if I run it
it gives me P you can check now so s is
at the zeroth index I is at the first
index m is at the second index and P is
at the third index
let's see I'll write str1 of
let's say 12.
we can see the difference now it gives
us an error it says string index out of
range the reason being simply learn
does not have any value at the 12th
index so it's printing an error saying
string index out of range
now let's change this to
6 and see what we have at the sixth
index we have L if you count here
s is at the zeroth index I is at the
first index m is at the second Index P
is at the third index
the first L is at the fourth index again
I is at the fifth index and then we have
the second L at the sixth index so we
have L printed here
now let's see how to use
a slicing operator using colon I'll
write
slicing operator
okay
I'll use the same string str1 let me
print it once again we have simply learn
suppose I write str1
within brackets I'll use the slicing
technique now I want everything starting
from the zeroth index
I get simply loan so here I am printing
everything that starts with the zeroth
index
next let's see what we have if I print
my string str1
and write 1 is to 6. I'll run it it
gives me impli so if you notice here
I want to extract whatever is present
from the first index till the sixth
index but excluding the sixth index so
in Python
the indexing method or the slicing
method will exclude the last index so
here if you see I is at the first index
m is at the second Index P is at the
third index
L is at the fourth index and then we
have i at the fifth index and we have
excluded the sixth index that is the
second l so hence it has written as
impli
now similarly let's say
we'll see another example I'll write
str1 this time I'll use colon 6.
if I run it you get
simply so it has printed everything
starting from the zeroth index till
the sixth index but excluding the sixth
index so you have all these values
from zeroth index till the fifth index
okay
now you can also reverse a string for
that you can use negative slicing using
two colons
if I write print
str1
and within square brackets I'll give
colon colon
-1
let's run and see the result
there you go if you see this it has
printed my original string which is
simply learning reverse order now
so this is a very simple method if
someone asks you to reverse a string or
print something in reverse order you can
use the negative slicing method
now let's explore a few more example if
I write str1
and within brackets I'll give
-1 and run it it returns me n because in
my original string if I go on the top I
have n at the last index which is here
minus 1.
similarly let's see what we have at
minus
we have a here if I go to the top
you see here
n is at minus 1 R is at minus 2 and a is
at minus 3 and hence it has given us a
foreign
str1
I want to print
-2
colon and let's see the result it has
given us R and n
so here we are printing only the
last two elements in the Stream hence we
have used minus 2.
okay
now
python does not allow you to reassign
values in a declared string let me show
you what I mean
I'll give a comment here
reassign
strings
suppose
I have the same string str1 which is
simply learn
say I write Str
and I want to replace
the value
present at the third index with let's
say
o
and
if I were to print
str1 now
python will throw an error saying Str
object does not support item assignment
so it is immutable like tuples where you
cannot reassign any values
you can also delete a string
say I have another string called str2
which has a value of
let's say Python programming
you can use the DL keyword
and write str2
and now let's print str2
you will see that it says name str2 is
not defined because we have already
deleted str2
the above step
okay
now let's go ahead and see some of the
important string operations
okay
say I have str1
which has python the one thing to note I
am using either single code or double
quote you can use whatever you want
let's say I have another string which
has programming
so these are my two strings
let's
perform a few operations on these
strings
see I write
str1
multiplied by 3.
and I'll run it
you can see here it has printed python
Thrice because I have said str1
multiplied by 3 so in str1 we have
Python and multiplying three returns
python three times
now let's see I'll write str1 Plus str1
it has merged python twice so I have
Python and python repeated
let's say I write str1 Plus str2
we see the result it gives us Python
Programming so basically
if you use the plus operator with two
strings python will perform a
concatenation operation which means it
will merge both the strings
now if you want to find if a specific
character is present in a string or not
you can use the in operator for this
let's say I'll print
whether
W is
present in
Str
to run it it gives us false because in
str1 we have Python and if you see here
we do not have the letter W in Python
and hence it has given us false let's
now let me copy this
I'll paste it here
let's try whether o is there in string 1
or not it gives us true because we have
an O here
you can see here we have an o
similarly
let's say I want to find whether
l e
is there in string 2 or not
if I run it it gives us false because in
string 2 we have programming and we
don't have any l a
present in programming
let's say we'll see whether Ro is
present in string 2 or not this time it
returns us true because if you see here
we have Ro in programming and hence it
has given us
true
now you can also
print a raw string using the
R alphabet
so the way to write this I'll write r
give a
single quote
let's say I'll give a location C drive
to forward slash and let's say I'll
write
python 3.7
and run it it gives me a raw string
no
let's see some formatting methods I'll
write
a comment saying
format methods
okay
I'll write a print statement
I'll give double quotes and here
let's see the first example where I'm
using curly braces I'll write
and I'll give another curly braces
you'll get to know what I'm doing once I
finish this
let's say I have a message both are
best
friends
then I'm going to use my format
method
and inside this I'll pass in my two
values for these braces
so these curly braces will be replaced
by
the words that I pass in or the values
that I pass in within the format method
so here I'll write let's say
James
and my second person would be
Brad
now let me run it you see here
what python does is it replaces
the curly braces with
the names that I have passed within the
format method so it takes the first
argument for the first curly brace and
the second argument for the second curly
piece
so my statement becomes
James and Brad
both are best friends
now let me just copy this I'll show you
another example
this time I'll
give one and zero inside the curly
braces
now if I run this
there you go
so here
James is at the zeroth index so this is
basically a list where James is at the
zeroth index and Brad is at the first
index so if I write 1 and 0 it will take
Brad here and then
for 0 it will take James so now my
message becomes Brad and James both are
best friends
now let's try out another example I'll
paste it here
I'll use
two variables let's say A and B
and inside my format method
I'll write a equal to James
and I'll assign b as Brad
let's run it there you go we have our
message printed James and Brad Buddha
best friends so here e refers to James
and P refers to Brad
cool
let's explore another example
I have a variable called name and that
has a value
Angela
and then I have another variable
it's a salary
of
hundred thousand dollars
I'll use a print statement
I'll print a message her
name
is
I'll use
percentage s for string
give
a backslash n for next line and I'll
write her
salary is
then I'll write
percentage T this is for numbers
and then I'll give another percentage
and let's see I'll write
my two variables Neiman salary
let's
see what we have in the result
I need to close my double quotes here
I'll exclude it from here let's run it
there you go
so I have my message here her name is
Angela her salary is
hundred thousand dollars
I'll just delete this piece here we'll
run it again okay
now this percentage s refers to the name
and we have declared her name is Angela
so my first statement or the message
Becomes Her name is Angela and the next
message is her salary is percentage T So
percentage T here refers to the salary
where we have hundred thousand
so the next message is her salary is
hundred thousand
so these are the very basic and
important print methods or formats that
you can use
while working with strings
now we'll explore a few
functions that are readily available in
Python to operate with strings
I'll take my same string str1 as simply
learn
and then
I'll create another variable called str2
I'll write str1 Dot I'm going to use the
capitalize method
okay
let me make one correction I'm going to
write everything in lower case so that
we can see the difference how we can
capitalize the string
so I'll write my print statement print
old value
this is going to my message
I'll give a colon
followed by my double quotes and I'll
pass in my variable str1
okay
now I'll copy this
in the next line we have
a new value as str2
let's run it and see the difference
there you go so here my old value has
simply learned in all lower case but
when I used the capitalize method
so python has converted my first letter
in simply learn to Upper Keys or Capital
keys
cool
now let me copy this
I'm going to use the same example for
the next three methods
let me show you how the case fold method
works this time I'm going to pass my
input string in all upper case I'll
write simply learn in upper case
and instead of capitalize I'll write
case fold
let's run it and see the difference
there you go
initially we had simply learn in
Upper Keys and now we have converted
into case fold so all the letters are in
lowercase
now moving ahead
you can also use the
upper method to convert a string into
Upper Keys let's say I have a string
where
few of the letters are in uppercase and
few of the letters are in lowercase
this time I am going to convert
everything into upper case so I'll use
the upper function instead of case fold
let's run and see the result there you
go so this time
python has converted my original string
into upper case
and likewise you can also use the lower
case
instead of upper if I write lower you
see here everything has been converted
to lower case
cool
okay
now I'll show you how the title method
works so in title method all the words
basically the first letter of all the
words will be in uppercase so suppose I
have
a string which is simply learn
company so I'll write
let's say
this is my string and I'll
I'll convert my str1 to title keys
let me run it so this is the difference
you can see
the first letter of the first word is
uppercase
again
the first letter of the second word is
also in upper case so this is how the
title case works
you can also count the occurrences of a
particular element in a string suppose I
have string 1
that has Python programming
in str2
I'll write str1 Dot
and use the count function to count how
many times let's say n the letter N is
present
then I'll print
saying
occurrences
give a colon here
and then I'll pass in my variable that
is str2 so this will count the number of
times n is present in my original Stream
So if you see here
in Python Programming we have n present
twice
similarly let's check for
G
the letter G is also present twice
let's see for y
now Y is present only once which you can
see here
okay
next
let's see how the replace function Works
in
python
and giving a comment as replace
so let's say I have a string str1
which has
Hamburg
is
located in France
so Hamburg is a city which is actually
located in Germany and not in France so
using the replace method we are going to
replace France with Germany so what I'll
do is I'll create another string str2
equal to I'll write str1 Dot and then
I'll
use the replace function
and I'll say replace
my string friends with
country Germany
and then we'll print str2 and see the
result
there you go
so we have changed
Hamburg is located in France too Hamburg
is located in Germany
now coming to the final method that we
are going to explore in this
python strings demo which is using the
split function
okay
so you can split the values for each
word in a string as separate words and
store it in the form of a list
so I
write str1
I'll just copy this
I'll paste it here
and I'll change France to Germany
because Hamburg is actually present in
Germany and not in France
and then I'll create another variable
called str2
I'll write str1 Dot and then use the
split function
now let me print both the strings first
I'll print str1
and then I'll print
str2
if I run it you see my original string
was Hamburg is located in Germany and
then using the split function we have
segregated or divided
each of the words present in the
original string into separate words and
this time it is present in the form of a
list
okay
let's see what operators are in Python
now operators are generally used to
perform operations on values and
variables in Python
these are standard symbols used for
logical and arithmetic operations
the value that the operator operates on
is called the operand
so here on your screens you can see the
different types of operators available
in Python first we have arithmetic
operators so arithmetic operators are
used to perform mathematical operations
because it returns either true or false
according to the condition
so these are the comparison operators
you have less than greater than less
than equal to greater than equal to we
have not equal to and we have equal to
equal to third we have assignment
operators so assignment operators are
used in Python to assign values to
variables so these are the assignment
operators you have equal to you have
plus equal to
so for example you have a variable
called X and if you say X Plus equal to
7 this means
it is x equal to X Plus 7. similarly if
you say x minus equal to 7 this means x
equal to x minus 7 and similarly you can
see the other assignment operators here
next up we have the logical operators so
logical operators are used in
the expression evaluation to make a
decision if both the expressions are
true then the condition will be true
foreign and operator
for an or operator if one of the
Expressions is true then the or
condition will be true
now for not
if an expression a is true then not e
will be false
we also have bitwise operators so
bitwise operators act on operands as if
they were strings of binary digits it
acts on bits and performs bit by bit
operation so hence it is called bitwise
operator
so here each value is evaluated as zeros
and ones
then we have identity operators so
identity operators are used to check if
two values are located on the same part
of the memory
two variables that are equal does not
imply that they are identical will
understand each of these operators in
the demonstration on the jupyter
notebook and finally we have membership
operators so membership operators are
used to test whether a value or variable
is in a sequence so you have is
and is not as identity operators in
membership operators we have in and not
in now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll see
and explore all these operators one by
one
so I am on my Jupiter notebook operators
in Python
so let's first start with arithmetic
operators
I'll just
give a comment here saying arithmetic
operators
okay
first up we'll see the addition operator
for that let me assign
two variables so I have assigned a
variable X to a value 10 and let's say
we have the second variable y equal to
4.
now
if I say print
X Plus y
it will perform an arithmetic operation
that is addition and will sum the result
of X and Y N gives me 14 because 10 plus
4 is 14.
now let's see
I'll write print x minus y
that gives me 6 because 10 minus 4 is 6.
similarly you can have
multiplication as well so I'll write X
asterisks y that gives me 40 because 10
multiplied by 4 is 40. similarly let's
say x divided by y
it gives me 2.5 which is basically the
quotient
of these two operands
all right
now
if you were to find the remainder you
can use the modulus operator so I'll
write x modulo y
it gives me 2. so you divide 10 by 4 the
remainder is 2.
now you can use the double asterisk
operator which is basically known as
power
so the left operand is raised to the
power of right
I'll write print X
give to asterisks and then say by
it gives me 10 000 so what basically
python does is it will raise 10 to the
power of 4 so 10 is Multiplied 4 times
and the result is 10 000.
you can also try out another example
let's say 2 raised to the power of 4
this gives me 16.
if I say 2 raised to the power of 3
that is 2 Cube and the result is 8.
you can also perform flow division
so flow division results into whole
number adjusted to the left in the
number line so if I write print
X and flow division is
given by 2
forward slash then I'll write y
that gives me 2 so it returns a whole
number
a generic division gives me 2.5
that has the floating point value but a
flow division will give me a whole
number
adjusted to the left on the number line
all right so these are some of the basic
arithmetic operators that are very
popular in Python
next we'll move on to assignment
operators
I'll give a comment as
assignment operators
okay
let's assign a value x equal to 7. so
here we are assigning the value of
7 to X
and you're equal to is an example of
assignment operator
now if I print X it will give me 7.
now let's say I'll again write x equal
to 7. and in the next line I'll write X
plus equal to 3.
and will print X
so what python does is
it adds 3 to my original value that X
holds that is 7 so here X Plus equal to
3 means x equal to X Plus 3.
so
x equal to X plus 3 can be written as X
Plus equal to 3.
similarly
you can also
write x minus equal to something say x
equal to 7 and then I write x minus
equal to
3.
then we'll print X
this gives me 4
because
we are subtracting the original value of
x by 3.
so here x minus equal to 3 means x equal
to x minus 3. okay
similarly let's say I'll write X
Asterix equal to 3. if I run it
and print the value of x it gives me 12
because I have previous x value was 4
and now we have multiplied X by 3 so x
value now becomes 12.
let's say I'll write X
divided by 3.
and I'll print X it gives me 4.0 this is
a floating Point number
so we are dividing 12 by 3 and the
result is 4.0
cool
if you want you can also perform
an exponent operation or a power
operation so let's say I have x equal to
and then I write X
double asterisks equal to
say 2.
and then we'll print X
okay there is an error here let's debug
the error
I have put a space here let's delete
that space you have to keep this in mind
now let's run it there you go so 7
raised to the power of 2 which is
basically 7 square is 49. you can change
the values and
run other examples let's say 10 raised
to the power of
3 we have 1000 as the result
okay
now moving ahead
now we'll understand about
comparison operators so I'll give a
comment
as comparison operators
okay
let's say I have x equal to 7 and then I
have y equal to 3.
if I print
x equal to equal to y
it will give me false the reason being
the value that X holds is not equal to
the value present in y these are two
different values that X and Y hold so X
is not equal to y
and if we print x equal to equal to Y it
will give us false
now
I'll just copy this code
I print it here
and instead of equal to I'll give not
equal to
so not equal to is represented by an
exclamation mark followed by n equal to
if I write X not equal to y
this gives us true because X and Y are
two different values and they are not
equal
I'll print
my code again and this time let's say
I'll write
X
greater than
by
it gives us true
because 7 is greater than 3
if I write X less than y and hit shift
enter that gives me false because 7 is
not less than 3.
I'll print the code again this time
we'll see
if x is greater than equal to 3
if I run it it is true because 7 is
greater than equal to 3
and
now let's check for less than equal to
this is false because
7 is not less than equal to 3.
okay so these are some of the basic
comparison operators that are available
in Python
now moving ahead we'll see
how logical operators work in Python
okay
first we look at the and operator
in Python
suppose I have a value
of 7 store in x and then I have a value
of 12 student by
if I write print
X
greater than
and Y
less than 10.
let's run it and see the result it gives
us false now
and logical operators
will return true
if both the conditions are true
and it will return false even if one of
the condition is false so here
X is greater than 2 which means 7 is
greater than 2 is true
but
y less than 10 which is 12 less than 10
is false and hence our entire expression
becomes false
next let's say I have x equal to 5
and then
I'll print
X greater than 3 or
X
less than 10 if I run this it returns us
true the reason being
X greater than 3 is true which means 5
is greater than 3 that is true
but 5 is not less than 10 but since one
of the conditions is true so the or
operation in Python returns us true
now
let's see another example
I'll write x equal to 5 and
y equal to
I'll print
X greater than 10 or
by
less than 20.
if I run this it returns true
so let's see our expression X greater
than 10 that is
5 greater than 10 is false but
y less than 20 so 10 is less than 20 is
true so our or operation will give us
true since one of the condition is true
now moving to the next logical operator
we have not
I'll given
comment here as R and now we'll see not
let's say I have x equal to 5 and then
I'll
print
X
greater than 3 and X less than 10 this
would ideally give us true the reason
being X is greater than 3 and X is less
than 10
let's run and verify okay so this is
true now let me copy this and I'll paste
it in the next cell
now I'll replace
my above print statement with a not
operator
and we'll close our print function with
another bracket now let's run it
so this will give us false because
my expression evaluates to true but not
true is false
okay
now moving ahead
let's discuss
identity operators in Python
all right
so we'll start by assigning a value of
let's say
505 to X
and then in y I will have
500 plus 5
so which is also 505
so X and Y hold the same value of 505
I'll print
comma y
so you can see here both the values are
same 505
for X and Y
now I'll use the
logical operator that is
double equal to or equal to equal to
I'll write x equal to equal to Y this
will give us true because X and Y hold
the
same value of 505 but
let's check with the identity operator
so I'll write X is y
if I run this it gives me false the
reason being
X and Y both refer to objects whose
value is
they are equal but they are not
referencing to this same object
now this you can verify using the ID
function in Python if I write ID of x
this will give me the memory location
that X has
you can see this is the memory location
of x if I write ID of Y
there you go so this is a separate
memory location in which
Y is holding the value of 505 and hence
X is y is different and hence it is
false
now suppose I write x equal to 100 and I
have y equal to 200
if I write X is not y
this gives us true the reason being
X and Y both are holding different
values so X is not Y is true
let's see another example this time
we'll Define
2 less
so I have a list called a that has value
let's say
5 comma 6 comma
3 comma 7
comma 1 comma let's say 9.
and then
I'll have
another list
that will also have the same elements
I'll copy this and I'll paste it here
okay
if I write
c equal to a
and then we'll print
a is C
if I run this it gives us true because
we are assigning
the variable e to C and hence
the memory locations are the same for
both and hence
AC gives us true
what if I write e is B
now this gives us false
so here e and B are both less they are
equal but not identical it is because
The Interpreter in Python allocates them
separately in memory although they are
equal
okay now let's talk about
membership operators in Python I'll give
a comment as
membership
operators
okay
let's see I have a list
a that has
the above values five six three seven
one and nine I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
okay I have
another list B that has different types
of elements we have four
next element is python
then we have
two
comma 7 comma let's say
simply load
and then I have
I'll run this first so I have my 2 list
e and B I have printed them
let's explore how the membership
operator works so
we saw in the slides in and not in our
two membership operators
if I write 5 in a and run it it returns
me true because you see here
5 is present in a and hence 5 enable it
on true
what if I write 55 in a
this gives us false because you see here
in the list a we don't have an item 55
in e
so it gives us false
modify write 4
in
p
this gives me true
you see here in B we have the element 4
so 4 and B is true
one thing I wanted to show you is what
if I write python
in b
you see here
it gives us false
though we have python
in our list B
but
the python I'm trying to check is not
present in B the reason being here
python is written in lower case
but
what I am checking
python p is in uppercase
so it is case sensitive and hence this
gives me false
let's see
I'll declare a dictionary by equal to
and within curly braces I'll
give my key a
and I'll assign the value of India
let's say I have another
key B
and that has a value let's say USA
now if I check e in y
it gives me true because your key a is
present in y
now what if I check
India
in
y
now this gives me false so here
the membership operator won't work on
the values it only works on keys in a
dictionary
now let me go ahead and change the keys
to numbers I'll give one
that has India and the second key I'll
have 2.
now
if I change a to 1 it will work fine it
gives me India
but if I write
USC in y it gives me false as I said
the membership operator won't work on
the
values it only works on the keys in the
dictionary
cool
now coming to the final section of our
demo
we'll explore about bitwise operator
okay
so Python bitwise and operator returns
one if both the bits are 1 otherwise it
will return 0. so first let's see 7
ampersant 2.
if I run it it gives me the value of 2.
so what python does is it will first
convert the numbers 7 and
2 to the binary equivalence that is in
the form of zeros and ones and then it
will perform the bitwise and operation
so 7 Ampersand 2 the value is 2
if I write 3 ampersand
the value is 1 again it will first
convert 3 and 5 to Binary equivalence in
the form of zeros and ones and then it
will perform the and operation the
bitwise and operation
now the python bitwise or operator
returns one if any of the bits is one
if both the bits are zero it will return
0.
so if I write
or
it gives me 15 so first it will convert
10 and 5 to Binary equivalence and then
it will perform the bitwise or operation
let's see another example I'll write 4
or 8.
I'll run it so the bitwise or operation
gives us 12 as the result
all right
first we will learn about the lesson in
Python its characteristics and explore
it in Jupiter notebook then we will
learn about tuples in Python its
characteristics and we will also explore
tuples in Jupiter notebook after that we
will have a look at dictionaries in
Python its characteristics and will head
to Jupiter notebook to understand the
dictionaries
so let's start with listen python
imagine you have different values you
have numbers you have strings now if you
want to group them together you can do
this job in Python with the help of
lists or you have work with arrays in
any other language like C plus plus or
Java this is the similar stuff in here
which is list
a list can be defined as a collection of
objects values or items of different
types and these collections are enclosed
within the square brackets and are
separated by commas let's understand
this with the help of an example
we will create a list and name it as
list one and insert the elements in
square brackets and separate them with
the help of commas
list 1 equal to square brackets 1 comma
atom comma 107 comma USA
and in less we have our first element at
zeroth index and we have one at zero
index atom at one index 107 at second
index USA at third index
and talking about the reverse index it
starts with -1 index value we have USA
at -1 index value 107 at minus 2 index
value atom at minus 3 index value and 1
at minus 4 index value
we will explore the list with various
examples in jupyter Notebook in a while
till then let's look at the
characteristics of list
first the lists are ordered when we say
that lists are ordered it means that the
items have a defined order and that
order will not change if you add new
items to a list the new items will be
placed at the end of the list
second elements of the list can be
accessed by index values
third list can store various types of
elements for example numbers strings or
lists itself
fourth lists are mutable the list is
changeable meaning that we can change
add and remove items in a list after it
has been created
lists allow duplicate elements since
lists are indexed list can have items
with the same value let's have a look at
some methods of list in Python
the first one is append it adds an
element at the end of the list
for syntax we can write list 1 dot
append and in round brackets we have to
write the element which we want to
append
the next is insert it adds an element at
the specified position its syntax is
name of the list dot insert and in round
brackets we'll write the index at which
we want to insert the element and comma
and after that the element which we want
to insert
third is extend
it adds the element of a list to the end
of the current list
its syntax is list 1 don't extend and in
noun brackets we will add the element
like list 2 which we want to extend in
the list the next is index it Returns
the index of the first element with the
specified value
and its syntax is list one dot index and
the element which you want to fetch the
index
the next is remove it removes the item
with the specified value
its syntax is list one dot remove and in
node brackets we write the element which
we want to remove from the list
the next is sold
this method is used to sort the list its
syntax is list one dot sort
the next is reverse it reverses the
order of the list
it syntax is list 1 dot reverse
let's move to jupyter notebook to
explore these methods
let's start with creating a list we'll
name the list as list one
and we will create
equal to
and we'll start with square brackets
and we'll write our first element that
would be apple
comma space next element
Orange
comma space the next element
banana
kiwi
now we will get this list printed for
that we'll write the syntax
print and in round brackets you'll write
the list name that would be list one and
run the command you can see here that
the list is printed
now let's create a different list with
some different elements
list 2 equal to
and in square brackets we'll write
Apple
now we will insert a list in a list
for that
we will write a list in square brackets
8 comma 4 comma 6.
and comma the next element that will
write Orange
the next element banana
now print this list
to print this you will write print round
brackets will write list two
and run the command here we will get the
list to print it
we can access any element in the list so
for that we'll write the syntax print
we want to access the second element
that will be the third element from the
last one for that you will write the
syntax print
list one and in square brackets we'll
write the index 2 and run the command we
will get the third element from the list
one that is banana
now we will access an element from the
list to for that we'll write the command
print
list to
and in square bracket we will write 1
and in square bracket we'll write 2 and
run the command what we get is 6.
so to access an element from a list that
is already inserted in analyst we have
to write the syntax so this syntax tells
us that we will first access the first
index element that is 846 the list and
in that we will access the second index
value that would be 0 1 and 2 that is 6.
so this is the syntax to access an
element in a list that is already
inserted in a list
now we'll see a reverse index order for
that we'll write the command print
list one and in square brackets we'll
write the index -1
and we'll run this command and we get tv
as output
now we will see slicing in Python we can
access a range of items in a list by
using the slicing operator
now we will see an example
to see the slicing operator work in
Python for that we will write the syntax
print
list one
and in square brackets we'll write one
slicing operator 3 and run the command
what we see is orange and banana as an
output from the list one
when you write 1 ratio 3 that is one
slicing operator 3 it gives you the
elements at index 1. 2 and node 3. so we
get the output as orange comma banana
now we will
see another example for the slicing
operator will write print
list one
and in square brackets we'll write 3
and slicing operator
run the command here we can get only TV
when we write a single number before
slicing operator it would print the
value at that index value and all the
other elements that are present in the
list but in this list we have only QV as
the last element so it would print third
index value and note more than that
now we'll see append function for that
we'll write the syntax list 1 Dot append
and in round brackets we will write the
element which we want to insert at the
last of the list
we'll write quava and
run it and now we will print the list to
see the result
here we can see that guava is added at
the last of the list
now we'll see extend function for that
we'll write the index list 1 Dot
extend and in round brackets
we will write
in square brackets the particular
elements we want to insert in the list
so we will write watermelon
and the next time when we want to insert
would be muskmelon
that would be in inverted commas
and we also want this list to be printed
so I'll write print list one and execute
this command here
we can get watermelon and musk melon add
it just after the list just at the last
elements of the list
now if you want to delete a particular
element from the list you can delete it
with the syntax
DL space the list name you want to
delete the element
and in square brackets you will write
the index for the element you want to
delete
we have written the fifth index value so
we'll run this command and we'll get the
list printed
we can see that the fifth index value
that is watermelon is not there in list
one it's been deleted
now you can also do this with another
method that is removed for that we'll
write list one dot
remove and in round brackets we'll write
the particular element we want to remove
we'll write that that is kiwi
and we also want the list to be printed
so we'll write print in noun brackets
list one
and run this command
we get that the Kiwi has been removed
from the list one
now there is another method that is pop
we'll write the command print
in round brackets you will write list
one dot
pop
and we'll write the index value
but we want to remove from the list that
is one
and also want the list to be printed so
for that we will write the command print
list one
we will run this command
okay we have not written the name of the
list correctly so now list one
now
so at the one index that was orange that
has been removed from the list
and now this is the new list
now we will can see another method that
is clear that moves all the elements
from the list so this we would reply on
the list to list 2 dot clear method
and we will also write another command
that would be print list to
and execute this command we can see that
the list 2 is empty now all the elements
from the list 2 have been removed now
we'll see another method that is reverse
for that we'll write the command list
one third reverse
and round brackets and we also want the
list one to be printed for that we will
write the command
print list one and execute this command
here we can see that the list one has
been reversed muskmelon guava banana
apple
now if you want a particular index
element to be accessed you can
have the Syntax for that you can write
that print
list one dot index
and in noun brackets you just need to
write the element for what you want to
get the index
and just run this command you will get
the index of the element
guava that is 1.
we have another method analyst that is
count so count is used to give the
number of times the particular element
is present in the list so for that we
will write the syntax print
sorry print
and in round brackets you will write the
list name list one dot count and round
brackets you will write the particular
element for which we want to get the
number of times that has been present in
the list write musk melon
and run this command it would give us
the value 1 because it's been present in
the list for only a single time now
let's move to the tuples so Tuple Tuple
is almost same as list we can have
different types of values in tuples the
difference in list
is we can change value because list is
mutable and Tuple is immutable that
means you cannot change the value
a tuple can be defined as a collection
of objects values or items of different
types and these collections are enclosed
within the circle brackets and separated
by commas let's understand this with the
help of an example we will create a
tuple and name it as tough one and
insert the elements in round brackets
and separate them with the help of
commas
so tough one equal to round brackets the
first element is 1 comma and the second
element is atom third element is 107 and
the fourth element is USA
now interpulse we have our first element
at zeroth index and we have one at zero
index and atom at one index and 107 at
second index and USA at third index and
for the reverse index it starts with -1
index value we have USA at -1 value 107
at minus 2 say index value and atom at
-3 index value and 1 at minus 4 index
value
we will explore the tuples with various
examples in Jupiter notebook but till
then let's look at the characteristics
of double
so the first is the tuples are ordered
when we say that tuples are ordered it
means that the items have a defined
order and that order will not change
elements of the tuples can be accessed
by index Tuple items are indexed the
first item has index 0 the second index
has one
third tuples can store various type of
elements that is strings arrays and many
other elements
the next is tuples are immutable tuples
are unchangeable meaning that we cannot
change add or remove items after the
Tuple has been created
next is tuples allow duplicate elements
since tuples are indexed they can have
items with the same value
let's have a look at some methods of
tuples in Python
first that is index we can use the index
operator to access an item in a tuple
where the index starts from 0. its
indexes the name of the Tuple note index
and in noun brackets will write the
element for which we want to access the
index
the second is slicing we can access a
range of items in a tuple by using the
slicing operator for that we'll write
the syntax top 1 and the range for which
we want to slice the Tuple
the third is concatenation here we will
add two tuples that is we just have to
write the name of the tuples to add them
and we'll place the plus Operator just
between them
the next is repetition we can have the
same item multiple times in a tuple for
that we'll just have to write the syntax
the name of the Tuple and the
multiplication operator into the times
we want that value to be present in the
Tuple
the next is count it Returns the number
of items a specified value occurs in a
tuple
so for that we have the syntax Step 1
dot count and in Drive brackets we will
just write the element for which we want
to count the number of times that
specified value has been occurred
we also have another method that is
indexed it searches the Tuple for a
specified value and Returns the position
of
that where it was found now let's move
to Jupiter notebook to explore these
methods so let's start first we will
comment
Networks
and we'll
go to the next column and first we'll
create a tuple
for that we'll write the command to P
one that would be the name of the Tuple
and in round brackets we'll
insert the elements that would be
Apple
comma
Orange
banana
comma
KV
now we'll print this double
we'll just have to write print and in
round brackets the name of the topper
and run the command
will get the Tuple
print it
now if you just want to insert a single
element in a tuple for that you will
write the command tab 2.
equal to in round brackets you will
write a single element that would be
apple
and run that command
the Tuple has been created but this
Tuple is not been considered as Tuple in
Python it's been considered as string so
let's check the type of this double for
that we will write print
type
and noun brackets we'll write the name
of the Tuple we want to check and run
this command here we can see that it is
showing a string so a single element is
been shown as string
in Python if you want that it should be
Tuple for that you just have to
insert a single comma in the Tuple and
now run this command you will get this
type estable
now if you want to access any element in
a Tapper for that you just have to write
the command print
top one and in square brackets the index
value that is 0
and here you quote the value Apple that
is at zeroth index value and Tuple
now you can also access the element in
the reverse order for that we'll write
the command print
up one
and in square brackets we'll write the
index value minus 1.
and run the command here we can get the
value key V from the reverse index
folder
now we also have the slicing operator in
tuples also
for that we'll write the command print
F1
in square brackets
the index values there
and we'll run this command print tab 1
index value 1 slicing operator 3. so it
has printed orange and banana
so what does it means it prints the
index value 1 and 2 and node 3.
you also have a repetition method in
tuples for that we just have to write a
simple syntax
like print
in square brackets the element you want
to repeat
we will write the element as repeat only
and
comma to just considered as Tuple and
just after the bracket we would have to
write the multiply operator and the
number of times the element should be
repeated in the Tuple now we'll run this
command
you can see that the Tuple has been
created with the element repeat and the
number of times is 3 that we have
written just after the element
so the Tuple has been created now we'll
see the count method for that we'll
write the command print
the name of the Tuple dot count
and in round brackets we will write the
element for which we want to know the
number of times it being present in the
Tuple
and we'll execute the command it gives
us 0. as R top 1 doesn't consist guava
as an element
so it gives us the count as 0.
now you see another method that would be
index for that we'll write the command
print
top one dot index
and in round brackets we'll write the
element for which we want to fetch the
index of that element
banana and we'll run this command we
will get the index of the element banana
that is to
0 1 2.
so we get the index of the element
banana
now if we want to use the append method
in tuples we have to first create the
Tuple into list for that we will write
the command y equal to list
and in down brackets we will write
the name of the Tuple
which we want to convert in the list now
we will use the append method
to the list that is why
dot append
and will insert an element that would be
guava
and now
you would just assign
the Y list to a variable top one
we have now converted
the Y list to the Tuple with this syntax
that is
Double Y and we have assigned it to the
top one value now we will print this
Tuple
and execute the command here we can see
that we have used the append method
in the Tuple
first we have changed the Tuple to the
list by this command y equal to list tab
1 then we have used the append method y
node append and append it The Element
guava then we have changed the Y list to
the Tuple that is Step 1 equal to Tuple
the name of the list and then we have
printed the Tuple
we can also add two tuples by another
method for that
we will
write another Tuple that would be top
three
equal to we will insert an element that
would be cherry
and now we want it to be added in top
one so we'll write
top 1 plus equal to
top three
and now we will print
the final Tuple that would be top one
and run the command here we can see that
we have added
two tuples that is double one and Tuple
three which consists of cherry and here
we get the whole Tuple as double one now
to execute Loops interples we'll write
the command
for that we will write the Syntax for
space
a variable X and
the name of the Tuple
colon
and then we will print
the particular element one by one and
we'll run this command here we can see
that all the elements have been printed
from the Tuple
now let's understand dictionaries in
Python
in less you can fetch the elements with
the help of index numbers but if you
want to specify a different type of
index for it example if you have a list
of 8 values and you want to fetch the
fifth one you will use the index but if
you have key for each element then you
can use the key to access that element
example phone book if you want to fetch
a number you will use a name and you get
a number and officially if we talk about
dictionary if you want to understand the
meaning of a word you go to that page
and you look at the word and understand
the meaning of it so this type of
concept where you have a key and
corresponding to that you have a value
we can achieve this with the help of
dictionaries
python dictionary can be defined as a
collection of objects values or items of
different types stored in key value pair
format these multiple key value pairs
created are enclosed within the curly
braces and each key is separated from
its value by the colon let's understand
this with the help of an example
indict 1 equal to curly braces the first
key is a and corresponding to that we
have value and that is separated by
colon and after the key value pair that
is separated by a comma the next is b
key and that has a corresponding value 2
after that we have inserted a comma
to separate it from other values now we
have a third key that is C and
corresponding to that we have a value 3.
let's see some characteristics of
dictionaries
the dictionaries are ordered from python
version 3.7 when we say that
dictionaries are ordered it means that
the items have a defined order and that
order will not change
second that is elements of the
dictionaries cannot be accessed by index
third dictionaries can store various
types of elements fourth dictionaries
are mutable dictionaries are changeable
meaning that we can change add or remove
items after the dictionary has been
created
fifth one is dictionaries doesn't allow
duplicate elements dictionaries cannot
have two items with the same key
now let's see some methods in
dictionaries
the first is clear method
it removes all the elements from the
dictionary and its syntax is the name of
the dictionary dot clear
the second is get it Returns the value
of the specified key the syntax is dict1
dot key and in square brackets we have
to write the key name
the third is case it returns a list
containing the dictionary's key it
syntaxes next one dot Keys the next is
pop it removes the element with the
specified key its syntax is dict1 dot
pop and in round brackets you would
write the particular key name
and the next method is Pope item it
removes the last inserted key value pair
from the dictionary and it syntax is
dict1.pop item let's move to the jupyter
notebook and execute these methods
first we will add a comment that would
be dictionaries
and now we'll create
a dictionary
for that we will write the syntax name
of the dictionary
equal to
curly braces
first we'll write the key value
then colon
and the value corresponding to it
will write Apple
then separated by comma
and then the second key value colon
and
the value corresponding to that key that
would be orange
when it would be separated by comma then
we'll assign another key value that
would be three colon
and
the value corresponding to that would be
banana
comma
next with
the Q value would be 4 colon and in
inverted commas we'll write the value
corresponding to it
and we'll print this dictionary
print take one and execute this command
here we can see that the dictionary is
printed
with one key value we have the
corresponding value apple with two key
value we have the corresponding value
orange with three key value as the
corresponding value banana and with four
key value we have the corresponding
value kiwi now to access a particular
element
we can't do that in dictionary but we
can access a particular value with the
help of key we can do that in dictionary
for that we would write the syntax print
the name of the dictionary
and in
square brackets we'll write the key
value that would be 1 and run the
command would get the value
corresponding to the key value
that is Apple that is corresponding to
the key value 1.
now
we will see a cat method in dictionary
for that we'll write the command print
name of the dictionary dot get
and in round brackets we'll just write
the key value
and run this command we'll get the
corresponding value to the key value
that is Apple
now we will use another method that
would be pop for that we will write the
command print
dick one dot pop and and down brackets
will write the key value
for the value
we want the element to be removed from
the dictionary
we will execute this command and we get
kiwi as the output now if you print the
dictionary
print dick one
we can see that the fourth key value and
the value corresponding to that key
value has been removed by the Poke
method
no
we can also print the length of the
dictionary for that we'll write the
command print
Len
and in round brackets we'll write the
name of the dictionary
and just execute the command you will
get 3 as the output as it has been
considered one unit second unit and
third unit so the length is 3. and we
have another method that is sorted for
that to write the command print
sorted and the name of the dictionary
date 1 will execute this command
it would give us all the key values in a
sorted manner
when executed with this command
now we can see another method that is
case for that we have to write the
command print
round brackets name of the dictionary
Dot
keys
round brackets and we'll run this
command and we'll get all the keys at a
present in dictionary
there is another method that is values
for that you will write the command
print
date1 dot values
round brackets and we'll execute this
command we'll get all the values that
are present in the dictionary now we'll
see another method that is update
that is used to update the particular
value corresponding to the key value or
update the dictionary with more values
to be inserted in the dictionary for
that we'll write the command dict1 Dot
update
in round brackets first we will write
the curly braces
the key value
semicolon colon
and corresponding to that will write its
value which you want to update
watermelon
and will also
print the dictionary
you will execute this command
we will get
that the second value that is watermelon
that's been updated
previously it was orange and now it's
watermelon
so it's been updated by this command and
we can also use this command to add more
elements to the dictionary
for that we'll write the syntax dict1
dot update
round brackets curly braces and the key
value colon corresponding to that we
will write the value
musk melon
and we'll print the dictionary
I will execute this command
sorry we just
augmented the name of the dictionary
deck one dot update now we will execute
this command
here we can see that the value has been
added to the dictionary
now we'll see another method that is pop
for that we'll write the command dict1
Dot pop and in round brackets the key
value
for which we want the value to be
removed from the dictionary and we will
print the dictionary
and execute this command here we can see
that the second key value has been
removed from the dictionary
and we will see another method that
would be ticked one
Dot
pop item
and then we will print the dictionary
and execute the command here we can see
that the pope item has removed the last
element from the dictionary and we are
left with only two elements in the
dictionary
now we will see some Loops in the
for that we'll write the command for
X in the name of the dictionary that is
text1 colon
and then we will write print
date one
and in square brackets
the variable X and we'll execute this
command
so with this Loop we can print all the
values corresponding to the key values
in the dictionary now to print both the
key and values corresponding to it we
can run a loop for that we'll write the
command for x comma y
and
dict1
dot items
colon
print
X comma y
and run this command
we can get the key and the values
corresponding to it
now if you want to copy the particular
dictionary in another dictionary you can
write the command
first you will name the dictionary you
want to create and copy the elements
we will name it as mydect
equal to
now we'll write the commandict one dot
copy
and then
we will print the new dictionary
that is
mydect
and we'll run this command
okay we have not inserted the wrong
bracket here now then this command here
we can see that we have printed the
mydic dictionary and it has the same
values as dict1
now we'll see another method
to delete
the whole dictionary
for that we will write
one
Dot clear
it would remove all the values from the
dictionary and will also
print the dictionary after that
then this command here we can see all
the elements from the dictionary have
been removed
in programming languages conditions play
a very crucial role to help us develop
programs that can satisfy all the
business conditions and perform well
so conditional statements are useful
when we have to decide that a certain
condition or certain part of a code
should run only if the condition is true
so the if statement is an example of
conditional statements the program will
first evaluate the test condition
and will only execute the code block if
the test conditional expression is true
so here you can see the syntax of if
statement first we have the if keyword
and inside
parenthesis we are going to pass the
condition and if this condition
evaluates to true then we go inside the
body update statement which is this part
of the syntax
now while developing a code for a
business problem you might have to use
multiple conditions so the alif
statement is used when we have to check
multiple conditions so here you can see
if the first test expression evaluates
to false then you have the alif
condition
and if the L if condition evaluates to
true then we go inside the body of the
alif statement which is this part of the
statement or the syntax that I'm
highlighting
next
so sometimes you want to evaluate a
condition and take one path if it is
true but specify an alternative path if
it is not so this is done with an else
clause
so the else code block will run if the
expression is false so here you can see
if the
condition for the alif statement returns
false then we have the body of the else
statement
and finally
after
all the if elephant L statements have
been executed we'll execute if there are
any other statements which are present
outside the if condition now moving
ahead
we will use if else and alif statements
to write a program that will solve a
business problem
So based on the location and total
amount of the items we are going to find
the shipping cost
the locations are a few states in the
United States
in the if statement project we will ask
the user to enter the amount of the
package or the item and we'll also ask
the user to input the state name
so for the different states we'll Define
the conditions using the total amount of
the items and print the shipping cost
so let me take you to my Jupiter
notebook where we'll do this project
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook let
me just rename this notebook I'll say if
statement
and
project
all right
so
let me go ahead and
give a comment I'll say
package
delivery
cost
based on
the location and
total amount
all right
first and foremost I'll go ahead and
create a variable called total now this
will be
a user input so I'm using the input
function
and here I'll pass the message as enter
the
amount
for
the item
all right
next
I'll assign
another variable called State this is
also going to be a user input so I'm
using the input function
and I'll say
enter the state name in
USA
so these are the two
inputs we are asking from the user that
is to pass the
amount for the item and the state in the
USA
all right now we'll start with our first
if statement I'll write if state
equal to equal to let's say my first
state name is Texas
I'll give a colon
make sure the syntax you are writing is
correct
now I am going to use
another if statement so this becomes a
nested if statement now
I'll write if
total Which is my
item amount so I'm checking if total
amount
is less than or equal to
then I am going to print
shipping cost
in
Texas
is
let's say
30 dollars
all right
now I'll pass my next condition using
ellip statement
since I am using multiple conditions so
hence I'm going to use
the alif statement this time I'll write
F total
is greater than 150 and
if my total amount is less than or equal
to 250 dollars
then I'll say
print
I made a spelling mistake this should be
shipping
I'll say print
shipping cost
in
Texas is
let's say twenty dollars
so usually if you're
amount of the item is high then the
shipping cost is low
so here you can see the total amount for
the package or the item is less than 150
dollars then your shipping cost is
thirty dollars but if it is between 150
and 250 dollars your shipping cost is
less which is 20 dollars
then I'll say else
print
shipping cost
in
excess
is
five dollars
so what basically this means is
if your total is less than or equal to
150 dollars then the shipping cost would
be
thirty dollars
if your total amount lies between 150 to
250 dollars your shipping cost is twenty
dollars
and if the cost of the item or the
package is more than
250 dollars
the cost is five dollars
so this is for Texas state
now moving ahead
I'll write alif
this time
will check the condition for State let's
say Florida
I'll use a colon here and say if
my total is less than equal to 150
dollars
then we'll print
shipping
cost in
Florida
is
let's say 45 dollars
I'll use the ellipse statement again
I'll say LF
total
if it is more than 150 dollars and
if it is
less than or equal to 250 dollars
I'll write
print
shipping
cost
in
Florida is
let's say 35 dollars
next
I'll
write my else statement I'll say
print
shipping
cost
in
Florida is
let's say ten dollars
if the cost of the item is more than 250
dollars now one thing to note here is
the shipping cost is different for the
different states in the U.S
all right
now we'll move on to our
next date let me
give a space here
I'll say LF
State equal to equal to let's say we'll
take
Virginia now
I'll say if total
is
less than or equal to 150 dollars
will print
shipping
cost
in
Virginia
is
let's say 23 dollars
all right
let's scroll down
next I'll write my ellip statement I'll
say alif
total
is
greater than 150 dollars and
total is less than equal to 250 dollars
then
will
print
I just copy this message
paste it here
and we'll see recipient cost in Virginia
is
15 dollars
next
we'll write our
else statement else
print
the message again I'll say shipping cost
in Virginia is
five dollars
in case the cost for the items is more
than 250 dollars
now moving to our final state
I'll write another alif statement I'll
say alif State equal to
equal to let's say New Jersey
if
total
is less than equal to 150 dollars
then we'll print
just paste the message here I'll say
shipping cost in
New Jersey
is
let's say forty dollars
now I'll say alif
total
if it is greater than 150 dollars and if
total is less than equal to 250 dollars
will print
just put this within double quotes
and
I'll say shipping cost in
New Jersey is
let's say
ten dollars
I'll say else
print
my shipping cost
is
free
in case
the
total amount for the items is
more than 250 dollars
all right
finally we'll have our
else statement where I'm going to print
invalid
state name in case the user enters any
other state apart from New Jersey
Virginia Florida and Texas
all right
so
we have our small project ready let me
just run through it
so first we are declaring two variables
total and state and we are taking this
as user input so the user is going to
input the
amount for the item or the amount for
the package and then
the user will input the state
so we have the four states defined here
and we are checking the shipping cost
for these four states based on
the amount for the items
all right
now let me go ahead and run it
so here you can see we have our first
user input enter the amount for the item
let's see I have my amount as
125 dollars
and
the next input is enter the state name
in USA I'll say
let's say Florida
if I run this it gives me the shipping
cost in Florida is 45 dollars let's go
to the top and see what we have
now a total was
125 dollars Which is less than 150
dollars and hence it has printed
shipping cost in Florida is 45 dollars
let's run this again
this time I'll say
let's see my
item cost
255 dollars
in the state let's say New Jersey
let's run it
you see here it gives us the message
shipping cost is free now the reason
being if you see this part of the code
for state New Jersey
if the
total
amount for the items is
more than 250 dollars
the shipping cost is free
now let's try for another state
this time we'll see for Virginia
let's say my
amount is
190 dollars
and my state is Virginia
if I run it it gives me the shipping
cost in Virginia is 15 let's check our
code
so here I have entered my
item amount to be 190 dollars so it lies
between 150 and 250 dollars and hence it
has printed the message that shipping
cost in Virginia is fifteen dollars
now let me enter another
state name that we have not defined
in our code let's say I have
my item amount as
290 dollars
and the state name
I'll give us let's say Colorado
if I run it it gives us the message as
invalid state which is present in the
last part of our code so since we
haven't defined any shipping cost for
Colorado it has given us the message
that the state I am trying to search for
is invalid
you can check for
another state or any other country name
anything that is not part of our
project
let's see I'll enter my amount as
hundred dollars
and this time I'll enter my state name
as
let's say Ohio
and we'll run it it again gives us
invalid state
let's try out one last time I have my
package amount as 350 dollars and let's
see my state is
Alaska
again it says invalid state name because
we haven't defined any
condition for Alaska state so this was a
very simple project that we did using
rip statement we saw how to write
nestative and we saw how to use the alif
and the
else statement if you are looking to be
one of them then yes you are at the
right place introducing you with Celtic
post graduate program in Ai and machine
learning let's take a quick walk through
with this amazing program some key
features of Caltech postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning include pgp
and AIML completion certificate from
Caltech ctme master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts Caltech ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEUs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
so what is a while loop in Python
a while loop specifies a condition or a
block of code that is to be executed
until the condition evaluates to false
or The Loop is explicitly ended with a
break statement
moving on to the next slide
so here you can see the syntax of a
while loop so a while loop is defined
using the while keyword and then you
have the expression followed by a colon
after that you have the statements
inside the block the statements are
executed until the condition evaluates
to false
now on the right side you can see the
flowchart to show all the steps
to execute a while loop so you can see
here we have the test expression if the
test expression evaluates to true then
we execute the statements that are
present inside the while block
but if the condition is false we will
exit out of the while loop now before I
move on I have a question for you
so here is a python quiz question
I want you to tell me the output of the
below code so this is regarding a list I
have declared a list called Alpha that
has d f and c as its elements then I am
saying Alpha plus equal to ke which is
again a string since it is within the
single quotes then I'm printing the list
now you need to tell me what is the
right answer you have four options here
a b c and d the first option is D comma
F comma C comma Ka combined then we have
Ka in the beginning of the list followed
by DFC
the third option or the C option is d f
c k a k being individual elements and
the last option the D option is k e d f
c
please go ahead and solve this question
and put your answers in the comment
section of the video we'll be more than
happy to know from you
all right
now let's go ahead and start with our
demo
so here I am on my jupyter notebook let
me rename my file I'll say
while loop in Python demo
okay
so
let me start by writing a simple while
loop I'll declare a variable called I
equal to 0
then I'll start with my while loop
I'll write my while keyword
and this will run till my eye is less
than 10 let's say
I'll give a colon
and if I hit enter it will come to the
next line you can see the indentation
here which has been maintained I'll say
I equal to I plus 1 so I am implementing
my I value
then I'll say print I
and I'll use my end parameter
and I'll say end Within
single quotes I'll say hash and give a
space
then let me say print again
so here my while loop will run until my
I value is less than 10. so we are
continuously incrementing the I value
and printing the I value let me run it
there you go you can see the result here
we have printed the I values starting
from
1 till 10
and after that
we have come out of the loop
and you can see the
hash symbol being used here because we
used our end parameter as has
so by default it is a new line character
but we have explicitly defined our
end parameter as has followed by a space
cool
now let's move on to our next example in
this video on while loop
I'll Define a variable called count
and I'll assign a value 0
I'll say while my count is
less than equal to 5 I'll give a colon
come to the next line and I'll print
the
condition
is true
and then I'll say
count
equal to
plus 1
and then I'll say print
end of loop
let's run and see a result
you can see here we have printed our
message the condition is true five times
because
our expression is being evaluated five
times here
in the sixth time our count is no more
less than equal to 5 so we end the loop
and here you can see the message end of
loop
cool
now moving ahead
you can also use
the break statement in a while loop let
me show you how to do it I'll say while
true
so I am
declaring my
while loop to be true
and I'll say
please
type your
name
and I'm going to
take my name as input from the user so I
am specifying the input
function
I'm going to check if my name is equal
to equal to let's say Gilly
then
it should give a colon here
I'll break out of the loop
and then we'll
print
thank you
you
typed
the
correct name
all right
so what I am doing here is
I'm going to run this Loop till the user
enters the correct name so I have
declared my name is Gilly if you enter
Any Other Name apart from Gilly this
while loop will continue to run and
execute
let's run it okay
so here it says please enter your name
I'll let's say say John
if I run it
is again asking me please enter your
name let's say this time I'll say Amy
you can see here it is again asking for
the name so I'll enter my name let's say
Hopkins
again are entered username doesn't match
the name that we have provided in the
code let's say this time I'll say Gilly
if I hit enter you can see we have our
message thank you you typed the correct
name
okay
now moving on to the next example we
will see how to find the least common
multiple of 4 and 7. so I'll give a
comment as
LCM of
4 and 7.
now you would know
it is 28 but we are going to find out
with the help of a python while loop so
first I'll declare a variable x equal to
I'll say while
my expression is true
I'm going to increment my x value to 1
I'll say X Plus equal to 1 this means x
equal to X Plus 1
I'm going to use
an if statement and say if not
and here we'll pass the condition
X
percentage 4 or modulo 4
or
X percentage 7
then I'll say break
finally we'll print our message saying X
comma
and I'll say is
divisible
by 4 and
7.
say both 4 and 7. okay so what I am
doing here is
I am taking my expression while true
I am incrementing the value of x
each time and checking if
this is true or not
now at the first instance when my number
X is divisible by both 4 and 7 I am
coming out of the loop and we are going
to print this now let's see
what's the answer there you go you can
see here 28 is divisible by both
4 and 7 and hence the LCM of 4 and 7 is
28 so this is the least
number which is divisible by 4 and 7.
all right
now you can also use the continue
statement
how you use the break statement to
come out of the loop you can also use
the continue statement to continue
running the loop
so I'll say I equal to 0 while I is less
than 10.
so this is my expression my Loop is
going to run until I is less than 10 I
am going to increment the value of I
I'll say I plus equal to 1
if
let's say I set my condition if I equal
to equal to let's say 6.
then I'll say
continue my execution and skip the
current step where
I value becomes 6. then I'll say print I
let's run it and see the result okay you
can see here we have printed one two
three four five and here you can see we
have skipped the execution where I value
became 6 and continued with the next
iteration 7 8 9 and 10. so this is how
you can use the continue statement and
the break statement in a while loop
all right
now moving ahead you can also use the
else statement in a while loop now let
me show you how to do it
I'll say I equal to 1
then I'll write while I is less than
let's say 5.
I'll say print I
then I am going to increment the value
to I plus equal to 1.
now here you can use the else statement
and say print
I is
not
less than
5.
let's run it you can see here
we
ran our Loop until I value was less than
5 so we printed 1 2 3 and 4 when I value
became 5 we printed I value is not less
than 5.
cool
now moving ahead
so you can
use inbuilt functions inside a while
loop let me show you how to use the pop
function and remove the elements in a
list using a while loop
so I'll declare a list of numbers let's
say 1 comma 2 comma 3 4 and we have five
so these are the five elements that are
present inside list e
I'll say while a so I'm iterating over
all the elements
in my list
I'm going to say print a DOT I'll use
the pop function
so
what pop does is it is going to remove
the elements
from the end of a list
then I'll say else
print
there
are
no elements
left
in the list
all right
let's run it and see the result you can
see here we are removing
the elements one by one from the end of
the list so first we popped out five
then four three two and one and after
that we had no more elements left in the
list so we printed there are no elements
left in the list
okay
now the next program we will take
numbers as input from the user and
calculate the average as long as the
user enters a positive number
so I'll give a comment average of
positive numbers
cool
okay
so I'll start my program I'll declare a
variable called num which has a value 0
I'll declare a variable called count
which also has a value 0
then I have sum
which has a value of 0
I'll write while
my
number is greater than equal to 0 so
this condition
is for accepting only positive numbers
I'll say
num equal to
I am going to take the positive numbers
from the user so I'll
pass an input function I'll say enter
any
positive
number
then I'm going to say if
my number is greater than 0
I'll say
count equal to
count plus 1
let's make this
greater than equal to zero
then I'll say sum
equal to sum Plus
my number
so here I am keeping track of the
numbers that we have
entered and here we are calculating this
sum that is the cumulative sum
then I'll say
AVG
which is to find the average
I'll say sum divided by my variable that
is count
then I am going to print
total
I'll say total
sum of
numbers
give a colon
followed by your space
give a comma I'll say sum
then
I'll say
average
give a colon followed by your space
and I'll pass in the variable evg
all right
so here I have my
program ready where we are using a while
loop and
if statement
to tick numbers as input from the user
and calculate the average as long as the
user enters a positive number
so let me run it okay it says enter a
positive number I'll say let's say 5.
again it's asking for a positive number
I'll say
seven
let's say 10
and this time I am going to enter a
negative number so I'll say minus
6.
if I run it you can see here
the total sum of numbers 5 plus 7 plus
10 is 22 and the average is 22 divided
by 3 which is 7.33
all right
let me give a space here for more
readability
we are going to try it again
I'll say 40
50.
and let's say 100
this time I'll enter a negative number
let's say minus 90.
okay so you can see here
I have entered four positive numbers 40
50 30 and 100
so the sum of numbers is 220 and the
average is 40 plus 50 plus 30 plus 100
which is 220 divided by 4 which is 55.
cool
now moving on to the last demo in this
while loop with Python tutorial
so here we are going to guess a number
so the user is going to
give a number between a certain range
and based on a random input generated
from the program we are going to guess
the random number
all right
so for that I am going to start by
importing my library called random
I am going to say n equal to random Dot
Rand int which is a function to Generate
random integers I want to generate
between 1 and 100
let's go ahead and print that number and
then
I'll use a variable called guess
which is going to be
a user input
so I'll say input which is my function
and I'll keep the message enter and
integer
between
to let's say 100
okay
then I'll start my while loop saying
while
n
not equal to
my
variable that is
guess
I'll say if
my
guest number is less than n
I'll print the
message as
your
guess
is let's say low
then again I'll say guess equal to
I'll take the
user input
I just copy this message
and we'll print it here
okay
now
I'll say
alif
if my guess is
more than my random integer
will print I just copy this
we are going to print
your guesses let's say hi
then we are again going to
ask the user to
guess a number between
1 to 100
and after that I'll say
else
will print
you
guessed it correctly
then we'll
break out of the loop
and finally I'll just print it
okay so what we are doing in this game
is
before that let me just give a
comment as guessing game in Python
first of all we are generating a random
integer using the library called random
so the integer will lie between 1 and
I am going to print that integer
after that I am taking a user input so I
am asking the user to enter an integer
between 1 to 100 and I'm checking if my
random integer is not equal to my
user input that is guess
and if that guess is less than my random
integer I am going to print your guess
is low
then I'm again asking the user to input
an integer between 1 to 100
then I am seeing if the guest value is
more than the generated random integer
will print your guess is high
then after that I'm again asking the
user to input an integer
and in case the random integer
matches with the guest number will print
you guessed it correctly
all right let's try this out
okay so here you can see
so my program generated a random integer
48 that lies between 1 and 100. so our
Loop will only stop executing when we
enter our number as 48
otherwise it will keep on running and
asking you to enter an integer let's say
I enter
50.
you see here
your guest value that is 50 is more than
the random integer 48 so we have the
message your guess is high
let's say I'll say 30.
this time my guess is low you can see it
here
let's see I'll
take my number as
300.
you see here
this time I guess is high which is more
than 48
but if I say
my user input to be 48 and I if I hit
enter
there you go we have our message printed
you guessed it correctly
all right
so that brings us to the end of
so what is a for Loop in Python
a for Loop in Python is used to iterate
over the items or elements present in a
sequence
the items present in a sequence can be
in the form of a list Tuple dictionary
or even a string
a for Loop in Python uses the range
function to iterate over a specific
number of times
now let's have a look at the syntax of
for Loop
so here on the left you can see the
syntax of the for Loop so we have the
for
keyword followed by the iterator
variable then we have the in keyword
followed by the sequence it can be a
list you can use the range function it
can be a dictionary a tuple anything
and after that you have your colon
followed by the statements that you want
to execute in the for Loop
and Below you have the rest of the code
and here on the right you can see this
is the flowchart of a for Loop so you
have for each item in sequence then we
check the condition if you have reached
the last item
if that is true you exit out of the loop
but if it is false you keep on running
or executing the statements that are
present inside the for Loop this will
continue until and unless you have
reached the last item in your sequence
okay
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook where we'll
see for Loop in detail
and we'll explore a lot of code examples
okay so here I am on my jupyter notebook
let's start by writing a simple for Loop
suppose I have a variable
Cs and it has a value which is a string
let's say simply load
okay
now
the way to write a for Loop is I'll say
for
I which is my iterator variable it can
be any valid variable name in Python
in
my variable that is s
so here s becomes my sequence
I'll say print
I
so what this for Loop is going to do is
it will iterate over all the characters
that are present in my string and print
them one by one
let me run it by hitting shift enter
you see here using this for Loop we have
iterated over
all the letters that were present in my
string that is simply learn and we have
printed them one by one
okay
now the print function in Python
provides a parameter called end so by
default
the value of the parameter is
backslash n that is the new line
character now you can end a print
statement with any character or string
using this parameter which is end let me
show you what I
meant so I'll again
have my same string simply learn
I'll say for i n
my variable or my sequence s
I'll say print
I
comma then I'll use my end parameter
equal to and
my end parameter will have a value of
asterisks
now let me run this you can see here
which is sort of a pattern that we have
printed so between each letter in my
string simply learn we have an asterisk
okay
moving ahead
let's see how to
use for Loop
in a list
all right
I'll declare a list called programming
and this list will contain
a few programming languages let's say we
have Java
and then
the next item you have in the list is
python
next we have Ruby and then
we'll have HTML
okay
so
I'm going to print
all the individual items that are
present in my list using the for Loop so
I'll use the same syntax I'll write for
this time I'll use my it to variable
name as iter which means iterator
for iterator or iter in my sequence
which is programming
I'll say print
iter
let's run it you see here we have
printed all the items in my list one by
one Java python Ruby and HTML
all right
now let's see
an example how you can find the average
of a list of numbers using for Loop so
I'll give a
comment saying find the
average of a
list of numbers
okay
so here
first of all we'll declare a
list of numbers with variable list
underscore num equal to
have a few numbers let's say 20 25 10.
50 and 40.
let's make it 45
now to find the average of a list of
numbers
first I'll declare a variable called sum
that will have
a value of 0 so we have initialized the
sum variable to 0
and I'll start my for Loop for I in
my sequence that is list underscore num
which is
this variable
give a colon I'll write sum equal to
sum plus I
so here
just give a space to make it more
readable
so I'm adding all the numbers in my list
and we are storing the result in the
variable sum
then we'll say
print
sum
equal to
I'll pass in my variable that is sum
then I'll say
print
average
equal to
now our average will be
my variable sum divided by
the length
of my
list that has all the numbers
let's run this you see here
so our total sum of all the numbers
present inside the list is 150 and the
average of all these numbers is 30 so
150 divided by 5 is 30.
all right
now let's see how you can use a for Loop
using a tuple
so let's declare a variable called num
this is going to a tuple of numbers
and we have 30 45 60 50 and let's say 70
as the numbers inside the Tuple
I'll say sum equal to 0
then we'll have our for Loop for I in
my sequence that is num
I'll say
sum equal to sum plus I so here we are
just adding the values that are present
inside the Tuple
I'll say print sum
so here you can see we have
printed
all the values present inside the Tuple
one below the other now if I shift my
print statement to here
you can see here this is my
sum of all the numbers that are present
inside the Tuple so make sure you have
the current
indentation
now let's see how you can use the range
function in Python
okay
so you can use the range function to
iterate over a range of values or
numbers
using a for Loop
the way to do is I'll say for I in
my function range
I'll give my first index at 1 and my
second index at
or my end index at 10 so this will go
from 1 till 9 and exclude the 10th index
I'll say print I
you see here
for I equal to range 1 to 10 we have
printed all the numbers starting from 1
till 9. so the last index that is 10 is
exclusive in the range function
now in the range function you can also
give a third parameter that stands for
step so that you can skip a few steps
and print the next value let me show you
what I mean
say I write for I in range
0 which is my starting index
10 which is my end index and I'll have a
step size of 2
give a colon I'll say
print
display
values
with a
step
size of
2.
give a comma here and my variable that
is I let's print it
there you go
so we have printed
the values with the
gap of 2 so it starts from 0 then we are
jumping two steps and then we are
printing two then again two steps we
have four six and eight so we are
skipping one value
and printing the next value
in my sequence
ranging from 0 to 10.
all right
now
let's write a program to print a table
of a given number
so I'll give a comment as
program
to
print
table of a given number
all right
so I'll pass my
variable n
which is going to be a user input so I'm
using the int function and inside the in
function I'll use the input function to
take the user input
I'll give my message as enter the number
I'll say for I in
range
from 1 till
11.
I'll say
multiply which is mul here
n Asterix I so basically what I am doing
here is
I'll take a user input of the number
let's say we want to print the table of
five
so from
1 till 10 will have the product of the
numbers
let me print it I'll say print
and
comma
within double quotes I'll give my
asterisks
comma I
comma
within double quotes I'll say equal to
and then we'll have our
variable mul
let's run this
enter the number I'll give 5 and hit
enter there you go
so here we have the multiplication table
of
my number five so you see
5 into 1 which is 5 5 into 2 is 10.
then we have 5 into 7 35 5 into 9 is 45
then our last index which ends at 10 so
we have 5 into 10 that is 50. all right
so this is how you can create a simple
multiplication table using for Loop in
Python
now we can also use the range function
with a sequence of items
the Len function can be combined with
the range function to iterate through a
sequence using indexing
I will show you an example here let's
say we have a list called list two and
here we have
a list of programming languages let's
say
C plus plus you can either use a single
quote or a double quote to represent the
text values in a list
the next programming language I have is
Java
then let's say I have Python and we have
r
okay
so I can write for I in
range
here I can use the length function and
I'll say
list two
give a colon
then we'll print
hello
and I'll say list 2 of I
so what it does is my iterator will
iterate over the list of programming
languages I have here
and it will keep on iterating
till
the length of the list and then I am
printing my messages hello
and it will take each item from the list
using the index number
if I run it you can see here it says
hello C plus plus hello Java hello
Python and hello r
cool
now let's see how you can use
nested for Loops in Python
I'll send a state for Loop
as my comment let's see I have a list
of company names
my first company I have in my list is
Google
let's say apple
PWC
and then we have
Uber
so here I'll write for I in
companies
I'll say print
we will
display
each
letter
of
I'll say plus I
now I'll use my second for loopsync for
letter in I
will print the letter
let's run it and see our result
there you go
so here we have used
two for Loops so that becomes a nested
for Loop we have my outer for Loop and
then we have our inner for Loop so in
the outer for Loop we are just printing
the name of the company so here we see
we will display each letter of
plus I which stands for
my company name Google so you can see
below we have
displayed each letter of Google using
the inner for Loop similarly we have for
Apple you can see a p p l e we have PWC
and then we have Uber
so this is how you can use
multiple for Loops in Python
now let's see how you can use a for loop
with else clause
so I'll give a comment for loop with
else clause
sell rate for in range
0 comma 10 comma I'll give a step size
of three
I'll say print I
and after this
python gives you the flexibility to use
an else clause
after the for Loop so I'll write else
print
the loop has
completed
execution
so this is my message that we are going
to print after we have printed all the
elements
that are present inside this range
function
let's run it you can see here we have
printed
the value starting from 0 with a step
size of 3 so we have 0 3 6 until 9 and
then
after that we have our else block
printed which has the message the loop
has completed execution
good
now let me show you
two more
important feature that you can use while
writing a for Loop one is called the
break statement the other one is called
the continue statement
so in Python you can break the for Loop
and end it before it has actually run
all the elements in the I treble using
the break statement
so let me show you a simple example if I
write for
just give a space here
I in
range
let's say from 1 to 10
I'll use an if condition saying if I
equal to equal to 6.
then break and come out of the loop
next we'll print I
so here what we are doing essentially is
we are iterating over
all the values from 1 to 10 and whenever
the I value becomes 6 we come out of the
loop and print
all the values we have iterated so far
let me run it and we'll see the result
there you go so here our I value started
from 1
we printed one two three four five and
then
our I value reached 6 then we use the
break statement to come out of the loop
all right
now
you can also skip the execution of
further statements in the for Loop
during the titration using the continue
statement in Python
so when a continuous statement is
executed the for Loop continues with the
execution of the next element in the I
table
it does not complete all the statements
in the for Loop body
so again we'll
give a comment
say continue
okay so I'll write for I in range again
from 1 to 10
give a colon I'll say if
my I value
is equal to equal to 6 then I'll say
continue
then we'll print I
let me run it and we'll see the result
okay so if you notice this
output so we have printed values from 1
to 5 and when my I value became 6. we
skipped printing 6 and we moved on to
the next element in the eye table which
was 7 then we printed 8 and 9.
so this is how you can use the braid and
continuous statements in Python
all right
now we'll see a program to display the
total goals a player has scored
so here we are going to iterate over a
dictionary
so I'll give a comment program to
display
the total goals uh
player has scored
all right
first of all
I'll declare a variable saying clear
name
and let's see we have the player name as
Carmelo
all right
I'll declare a
dictionary called goals
and within curly braces I'll have
my first
clear name addition
let's say addition has code
14 goals then we have let's say
Burnet
so Burnet is my key here and then we'll
have
value in terms of goals let's say three
and then we have our third player let's
say Carmelo
and Carmelo has scored let's say seven
goals
now I am going to write my for Loop so
I'll write for
my I triple name here is player in my
sequence name is goals so I'll say
goals
I'm going to check if
my player
is equal to equal to player name
I'll say print
the goals scored by the player
so I'll
pass my dictionary name and within
square brackets
I'll say clear
let's use the break statement
and then I'll say
else
will print
my message would be no player with
that name
found
let's run and see the result
all right so here what we did was
initially I declared a variable called
player name that had the value Carmelo
and since Carmelo was present inside my
dictionary
named goals you can see here we have
Carmelo who had scored seven goals
so I I treated Uber
my sequence cools and I checked if my
iterator
that is player is equal to equal to the
player name which is Carmelo since this
Carmelo is present inside my dictionary
name so we printed the goals that were
scored by Carmelo that is 7. now let's
say I change this player name to
we have let's say Messi
now since Messi is not present inside my
dictionary goals if I run this it will
print no player with that name found the
reason being messy is not present inside
my dictionary called Ghouls
cool
now
we'll see two more
examples
this time
we are going to print the cube of
numbers using for Loop
all right
so first of all I'll declare a list
which will have a list of numbers let's
say 2 5
7 4 8 and let's say 6.
then
I'll pass in a empty list so I'll
declare Within
empty square brackets
I'll say for I in
my sequence name that is num
I'm going to use my empty list Cube and
Then followed by the append function
and inside the append function we'll
have our
cubes of the number so I'll write I
I'll use the double asterisk operator
and then I'll say 3.
after that we are going to print
my list name that is Cube
let's run it
there you go
so you can see here
first we have
the list of the numbers here and then we
have printed the
cubes of these numbers in a pattern
let's say
bring this print statement here and I'll
run it again now this is much more
readable you have 2 cube is eight five
cube is 125 7 cube is 3 43
then 4 cube is 64 8 cube is 512 6 cube
is 216.
all right
now coming to
the last example in our demo section of
this
for Loops in Python video
will write
a program to print a pattern I'll say
pattern printing
all right
so we are going to print
a right angle triangle
for that I am going to take
my first variable called n which is
going to be
a user input to enter the number of rows
so using the input function I am passing
the message enter the
number of
rows
I'll say for I in
range 0 till my user input n
give a colon
I'll use my inner for Loop
this is
going to be the number of columns so
I'll say for J in
range
comma
I plus 1
give a colon
and
I'll print
my star pattern so I'm using asterisks
and I'll use my end parameter
I'll have my double quotations
and then
we'll say
print
the pattern
so here what I am doing is I'm taking
the number of rows from the user
and I'm iterating
from 0 till n which is my user input and
then
we are
assigning another for Loop for the
number of rows so that ranges from 0
till I plus 1
then I am printing my star
let's run it and see the output
let's say I'll enter the number of rows
as 6.
if I hit enter you can see here we have
our right angle triangle printed here so
initially
my
I value is 0
so here my J value becomes from 0 till 1
so we have just one star printed
in the next iteration my I value becomes
1.
so from
0 to 1 plus 1 that is 2 we have 2 Stars
printed the next iteration my I value
becomes 2 so 2 plus 1 is 3 again so we
have three columns here so three stars
printed so on and so forth so
okay so I'm on my jupyter notebook first
of all let's rename our notebook to
looping techniques
okay
I'll just increase the
size all right
okay so let's see how you can arrange
the values in a list using for loops
with python sorted function
so I'll create a variable called num
and
I'll assign a list let's say it has
values to 5 10
I'm taking just random values
let's say 36
50 and 49.
so this is my list now I want to arrange
the
items in this list
in either ascending or descending order
so for that I can use a for Loop I'll
say for I which is my iterator variable
in
and after this I am going to use the
python sorted function
and inside the function I'll pass in my
variable which is num
then I'll give a colon and say print I
so let's
hit shift enter to run it okay
you can see here
so python by default
has sorted the elements in the list in
ascending order so we have 2 4 5 10 10
36 49 50 and 50.
now let's learn how you can sort the
values in a list using a for Loop in
descending order
so
I'll just
copy my above cell of code we'll paste
it here it will help
save us some time
so I'll say for I
in sorted
I have given my variable num
after this
I'm going to pass in another parameter
called reverse
equal to I'll say true
the reverse equal to True will make sure
python will sort the list in descending
order
if I run it you can see the difference
we have
sorted the elements in the list num in
descending order now so we have 50 50 49
36 10 5 4 and 2.
okay so this is one of the techniques
that you can use
to sort the elements in a list using a
for Loop
now similarly you can also sort string
elements alphabetically in the list and
ascending or descending order
so for that I'll create a variable
called players let me just scroll down
then I'll create a list
which will have the names of football
players let's say we have Messi
then let's say we have
Ronaldo
then we have
Salah
and then we have let's say Harry
okay
I'm going to say for I in
my function sorted
I'll say players
I'll give a comma and again use reverse
equal to true
so
this is going to sort the
items in my list players in descending
order of
the alphabets
then I'll give a colon and say
print I
let me run it you can see here
the names of the different football
players have been sorted in descending
order of alphabets so we have S
appearing first then R M and H so Salah
Ronaldo Messi and Harry
all right now let's move ahead
now we are going to create a dictionary
of key value Pairs and sort it
so I'll create a dictionary called d
which will have a few key value pairs so
my first key is f and the value is let's
say 1. then my second key let's say is B
and the value is 4
give a comma
my next key is a and the value is let's
say three
after that my next key is e
and the value is let's say nine
and finally we have our last key which
is C and the value is 2.
now to sort this dictionary I'll say for
I in
sorted
I'm going to use the items method I'll
say sorted D dot items
and then we'll print I
let me run it and show you the result
you can see it here our dictionary has
been sorted in
ascending order of the dictionary keys
so we have a b then C there is no D here
after that we have e and then f
cool
now you can also sort the
keys and values separately let me just
copy this and I'll show you
I'll paste it here and instead of d dot
items I'll just say d dot keys
if I run it you can see here we have
sorted only the keys in my dictionary
now to sort the values instead of items
you can just write values
and here you can see we have
sorted the values in the dictionary D in
ascending order again so we have one two
three four and nine
all right
now we will understand how to use the
reverse function in Loops to reverse the
items in a list
so I'll again
create my
list called pliers which will have
messy
let's say again the next player is
Ronaldo
and then we have
Salah and then we have Harry
okay
now to
reverse the elements in this list called
players I'll say for
I in
then I'll use the Reversed function and
pass in my list called players
give a colon and then say print I
let's run it here you can see
we have reversed the
elements in my list called players so we
have Harry first then Salah Ronaldo and
Messi in the end
cool
now moving ahead
we'll see how to use the filter function
in Loop and filter specific elements in
a list based on some conditions now to
give the condition we'll be using an
anonymous function in Python that is
often called as the Lambda function
to do this I'm going to create a list
called Animals
I'll give my square brackets and inside
the square brackets
I'm going to
pass in the elements in the form of a
dictionary
so to pass in a dictionary we need to
have key value pairs
so my first key is name
let's see
my animal is
dogs
I'll give a comma
then my next key is the each let's say
dog's age is 11.
so this is my first
list element which has been passed in
the form of a dictionary
I'll create another curly bracket and
will have the same keys this time let's
say
my animal is lion
let's make it dog instead of dogs
okay
give a comma and then say
each
let's see the age of the line is 30.
I'll give a comma
we'll go to the next line
and this time
we are going to have another animal
I'll see
elephant
give a comma
let's see the edges
step three
I'll give a comma
and then we'll have our final
element in the list
let's say the name of the
animal is leopard
give a comma
then we'll have the edge of the leopard
let's say
the ages 18.
so we have our list ready now
using a for Loop
will filter
the elements in the list giving a
specific condition let me show you
so I'll write for animals in
I'm going to use the filter function
and inside the filter function I'll
give
an anonymous function called Lambda
I'll say Lambda I colon
I of
age
if it is divisible by 2
so I'll say each
divided by 2 equaled equal to 0
give a comma
then we will
print that animal
give a colon
I'll say print animals
so what I'm doing here is
I'm using the filter function and
passing my condition that is if the age
of the animal is divisible by 2 then
print the animal
or just print the list rest
we don't need
all right
now let me run it
it says there is an
invalid syntax let me
debug it
okay there is a spelling mistake here in
Lambda this should be
mbda okay now I will run it there you go
so here in the list that we had created
only the age of lion and leopard were
divisible by two so 30 and 18 were
divisible by 2
so python printed us only those two
elements in the list the rest it node 11
and 63 are not divided by 2 so we did
not get dog and elephant cool
so this is another interesting looping
technique where you can use filter as
well as an anonymous Lambda function
all right
now in the next example we'll see how to
remove items in a list using a while
loop so so far we have been using only
four Loops now we are going to see a few
examples
using while loop okay
I'm going to create a variable called
country so this variable will hold a
list of elements of the different
country names I'll say India
let's see my second country is
Canada
and let's see my third country I have is
Brazil
my
fourth country I have is Japan
and then we have let's say Israel
okay
now
I'll use a while loop so I'll say while
my list that is country
then
to remove the elements in the list I am
going to use the pop function so I'll
say
print country
dot I'll say pop and I'll pass
-1 as the parameter so that
it removes the elements
from the
end of the list if I
run it you can see here we have Israel
Japan Brazil Canada and India now you
can just print country you can see here
since we have removed all the elements
from
my list country there is no element left
here so it gives us an empty list
cool
now let me show you how you can use
while Loops in just one line
so for that I'll create a variable
called num
and I'll assign a value of 10.
I'll say while
num is
greater than 0
I'll say
num
equal to num minus 1
I'll give a
semicolon this time and then I'll say
print num let's run it you can see it
here we have printed nine eight seven
six up to 0.
so in the first iteration my num value
was 10
so 10 greater than 0 was true so we
decrease the value of num by 1 so num
became 9 and we printed 9 in the second
iteration num which was 9 was greater
than 0 then we decreased or reduced num
by one again so it became 8 then we
printed it
and the loop continued till we reached
zero cool
now had this condition been num
equal to num plus 1 or num plus equal to
1 the loop would have run for infinite
number of times
all right
now I'll show you an example how to run
an infinite Loop
so I'll say while
true
I'll create a variable called num
now this num would be a user input a
user integer input actually
I'll pass in the message as enter and
integer
give a colon followed by a space
and then we'll see
print
the
product
of
I'll give a comma say num
I'll give another comma
I'll say
is
now we'll pass in our
multiplication I want to
multiply any user given number by 5. so
I'll say 5 multiplied by
num
okay let's run it and see here enter
integer if I say let's say 3 so 3
multiplied by 5 is 15 the product of 3
here I can change the message as
multiplied
by 5
you can say is
okay now let's run it
okay
so let's say I enter my integer as 3 I
have the message the product of 3
multiplied by 5 is 15.
let's enter another value 10
the product is 50. let's say I have 20
the product is 100
let's see I am taking
35 multiplied by 5 is 175 so this Loop
will continue until and unless you don't
interrupt it
so I'm going to interrupt my
kernel
to stop executing this Loop
okay now we are going to explore the
enumerate function in Python but before
that let me tell you what enumerate
function is
so the enumerate method or the function
in Python allows us to number list
indices of the items as they are coming
out of the array python will
automatically put this indices into a
tuple let me show you how it works
so I'll directly start with my for Loop
I'll say for I in
I'll use the enumerate keyword
and within
brackets I'll pass in my
elements in the form of list I'll say
the let's say then we have
Brown
the next word I have is for
let's see then we have jumped this is
basically a sentence broken down into
different words and those words we have
put
as elements in the list
the next word I have is the
give a comma I'll say
Lizzy
then we have
dog
give a comma
and finally we will have our full stop
or the period
okay then I'll give a colon and I'll say
print
I
now let me run it you can see here using
the enumerate function we have
given
the indices to the different items in my
list so it starts from 0 and goes till 8
so there are total nine elements in my
list
okay
now you can see here the result has been
printed in the form of a tuple or Tuple
I'll just copy the above code and paste
it here
now I'm going to replace IE with
key
and value
and
print also I'll see key comma value
let me show you the result you can see
here this time
it is no more a tuple
and here we have the indices and then we
have the
items so basically these indices have
now become the keys and
the items are the values
okay
now you can
print
the different elements in the form of a
sentence let me show you how to do it
I'll just paste it here
and
instead of key I'll say value
and I'll use
the end parameter in the print statement
I'll say end equal to
give us peace
let's run it you can see here
okay this should be brown fox and not
far let's run it again
so we have the sentence the brown fox
jumped over the lazy dog okay
so similarly you can iterate through the
letters in a word or a string and print
the letters along with the indices
I'll declare a variable called company
and
this will have a value let's say simply
learn
I'll say for I comma J in
I'll use the
enumerate function
within brackets I'll say company
give a colon
then I'll say print
I comma J
let's see the result there you go so
here we have
indices assigned to the different
letters
in my word simply learn
okay
now moving ahead
so by default the index position starts
at 0 as I told you
now you can also mention the starting
index position using the start parameter
so what I'll do is
I'll copy my
above code
I'll paste it here now we are going to
make some changes I'll say for
I in
enumerate company and then I'm going to
give my start parameter let's say I want
to start the index position at 10.
now if I print it
okay let's see print I
there you go here you can see
my first letter starts at index 10 then
we have 11.
M at 12 P at 13 and finally we have
the last letter which is n in simply
learn is at the 20th index
cool okay so now let's explore the zip
function in Python and how you can use
it to Loop it through two arrays at once
so the zip function returns a zip object
which is an iterator of tuples where the
first item in each past iterator is
paired together and then the second item
in each past iterator is paired together
and so on and so forth
so if the past iterators have different
lengths they iterated with the least
items decides the length of the new
iterator
let me
show you
the first example that will help you
understand how the zip function works so
have a list called first
and I have a
names of few
football players we have Lionel
then we have Cristiano
give a comma and let's say we have
Muhammad
I'll declare another list called last
it will have
values like Messi
then we have
Ronaldo basically the
surnames
of Lionel Cristiano and Muhammad then we
have Salah
I'll write my for Loop I'll say for I in
my zip function or the method I'll pass
in first comma last which are my
List names I'll say print
I
let me run it you can see here using the
zip function we have
iterated through both the less so we
have Lionel Messi Cristiano Ronaldo and
then Mohamed Salah
all right
now you can combine the elements of
three lists as well
so I'll just paste the code here and
we'll create another list called num
and this is going to be a list of
numbers
let's say 7 and 8 okay
now here I'll say for I
IN Zip first last and num print I
if I run it you see the result here it
has zipped only the
first three items in the list first last
and num so we have
three items printed
okay
now coming to the final section of this
demo on looping techniques in Python
we'll explore about
zip underscore longest
so Python's iterator tool or iter tool
is a module that provides various
functions that work on iterators to
produce complex iterators so iterators
in Python is an object that can iterate
through sequence data types such as list
Tuple string and so on
so the zip underscore longest iterator
falls under terminating iterators it
prints the values of the iterables
alternatively in sequence if one of the
iterables is printed fully the remaining
values are filled with the values
assigned in the field value parameter
so to use this function called zip
underscore longest we need to
import zip longest from the it tools
module so I'll say from
either tools import
zip underscore longest
okay
then I'll
create my
first list
I'll say
let me go to the top and copy the
elements because we are going to use the
same elements again
I'll paste it here
okay
and let's say I'll give a comma and we
are going to
and I'm again going to use the
three elements okay
now I'll create another list called last
and we're going to copy the items
from the top
paste it here
and now I'll say for let me just scroll
down
I in
zip underscore
longest
within brackets I'll say first comma
last
we are going to print I
let me run it and show you the result
this should be zip underscore longest
okay you can see the result here
for the first
three items it has printed Lionel Messi
Cristiano Ronaldo and Mohamed Salah
which you can see here but for the last
three items in the first list it has
given us because there were no values
now to overcome this problem you can use
a parameter called fill value
let me just copy this
and I'll paste it here
and the only change that I am going to
do here is
I'm going to say
give a comma
I'll use the parameter called fill value
equal to I'll say n a
if I run it you can see here
for the last three now we have whatever
we have defined within field value
parameter you can change this to let's
say
not defined
there you go
all right
so these were some of the interesting
examples that we implemented using
looping techniques in Python
so we are going to look at what is the
function in Python then we'll see the
different types of python functions
then you will understand the various
advantages of using python functions and
finally we'll head out to our jupyter
notebook to understand python functions
in detail with Hands-On demonstrations
okay
so what is the function in Python
so a function is a bunch of statements
that are defined to perform specific
operations a function in Python helps to
divide your program into smaller and
modular chunks thus allowing you to make
extensive programs more organized and
manageable it also avoids repetition and
makes the code reusable
so let's understand the types of python
functions first we have built-in
functions so these are the functions
that are built into python
so by default the inbuilt functions are
available in Python then we have user
defined functions so functions defined
by users to carry out certain tasks are
called user defined functions they don't
have a fixed name
so here on this slide you can see the
different built-in python functions that
are available so you have power length
next Max absolute we have print range
slice sorted Round And there are many
more so these we will explore in our
demo session
so wait for a while
now let's understand about the user
defined functions so these functions are
defined by users to perform specific
tasks
and these are the steps that you need
to create a user defined function so
first you need to create the function
and then call the function
now moving to the next slide so here you
can see the syntax of writing a user
defined function so we use the def
keyword to define the function followed
by the function name and within brackets
you have the parameters or the arguments
of the function then you have the
function block and if you want to return
a value from the function you can use
the return function followed by the
expression
so here is an example where we are just
printing hello python using a user
defined function and in this case my
function name is called my underscore
function now if I call my underscore
function it will return me hello python
cool
okay now let's understand the advantages
of using
python functions
so with the help of functions you can
avoid rewriting the same logic or code
again and again in a program
so in Python you can call functions
anywhere multiple times in a single
program
you can also track an extensive Python
program easily when it is divided into
multiple functions
and the most crucial feature or the
advantages of python functions is that
of its reusability
cool now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll explore the inbuilt
and user defined functions in detail
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook
first I'll go ahead and rename my
notebook as functions in
python
and click on rename okay
first of all let me just increase the
size
okay
I'll give my comment as
built-in functions
okay
so we'll start by looking at the
absolute function in Python so absolute
or ABS function Returns the absolute
value of a number
so I'll say let's say e equal to
I'll use the absolute
function which is represented as ABS in
Python suppose I write abs of let's say
10.75
and if I print a it gives me 10.75 which
is fair enough
let me just copy this code I'll paste it
here
I'll say b equal to APS
this time I am going to use the
negative symbol or the negative sign
I'll say minus 10.75 and will print V
let me run it you can see here python is
automatically removed the negative sign
and it has just given us 10.75 so this
is how the absolute function works so
ABS Returns the absolute value of a
number which is always positive
now let's see another inbuilt function
very popular which is called the length
function or Len I just give a comment
saying Len
above also let me just give a comment as
APS
okay so later we can have a track of
whatever functions we have learned in
the demo
so the length function Returns the
length of an object it could be an eye
table such as a list it could be a tuple
or even a dictionary let me show you how
it works I'll say list one equal to
I'll create a list within square
brackets let's say
I have
a few letters
let's say
i n then I have d
I again
and E so I have
all the letters in my word India now if
I say x equal to
Len of list one
then I'll print X it gives me 5 because
the length of all the characters in my
list is five You Can Count here I and d
i a
so there are only five elements and
hence it is written as five
now we'll explore another function which
is called as all
so the all function returns true if any
item in an i treble object is true
so I'll say
my underscore list equal to let's say I
have 0 1 and 0.
I'll say x equal to then I'll use the
all function
and inside the function I'll pass in my
list which is my underscore list and
will print X
hold on for a second and can you please
guess what this
X will be
it gives us false the reason being
we have
two false values 0 and 0 here and there
is only one true value which is one
suppose I had one one and one
if I run this it would have given us
true because all the elements in my list
or the I triple are true
if any one of the elements is false it
will give us false
okay
now moving to our next function which is
called sum so python sum function is
used to get the sum of numbers of an
iterable
let's say I have
s equal to
I'm using the function sum and inside
the sum function I am going to declare a
list of numbers let's say we have 20 35
and let's say 70
let me create another
list called S1
I'll say sum
and now
let's say we'll pass in a tuple now so I
am using another bracket we have let's
say 7 5 and 9. now if I write print
s and let's say I want to print S1
you can see here my sum function has
returned the sum of all the numbers in
the I triple the first one was a list
and next we have a tuple so 20 plus 35
plus 70 is 125 and then 7 plus 5 plus 9
is 21. so this is how the sum function
works
now moving ahead we have the Max
function next
as well as the mean function
so as the name suggests the max function
will return the maximum number of an
iterable
so I'll create a variable called M1 and
I'll use the max function
let's say we have a few values 7 10
3 12 61 and
now let's go ahead and print M1
now if I run it
it returns me the maximum number that is
present inside my list of numbers or the
Tuple that I have passed in
here you have the maximum number as 61.
now let's use the max function over a
dictionary so I'll create another
variable called M2 and I'll say Max and
inside the max function I'm going to
pass in my values in the form of a
dictionary so I'm using curly brackets
or braces I'll say let's say 7 90 you
have three let's say 150
67 and 44.
now let me go ahead and print M2
if I run it you can see it here it has
given us 50 which is the highest element
in my
dictionary
okay
now similarly you can use the Min
function let me just copy this
and I'll paste it here
I'll say M3 instead of Max function we
are going to use the Min function so the
mean function will return the minimum
number in an i treble
let's see I'll pass in
M3 as a
list this time and if I say print M3 it
gives me 3 which is the lowest number of
the lowest value in my list
and similarly you can
have the lowest value printed from a
dictionary I just change the variable to
M4 and instead of Max we'll use the mean
function
and here also I'll use the
variable as M4 if I run it you can see
here we have printed the minimum value
in my dictionary which is 3.
okay now moving ahead we'll explore
another function called
iter
so python either function returns an
iterator for the given object so the
iter function creates an object which
can be iterated one element at a time
and the next function Returns the next
item in an iterator let's use both iter
and next function in our next example
so I'll create a list called my list
and as equal to
followed by using the iter function and
inside the item function I'm going to
pass in a list which will have letters
of India
I have n
d
I and then I have a
now I'll create another variable called
X
and then I'll pass in the next function
and inside the next function I'll pass
in my list and
we'll go ahead and print X
so it will print the first element in my
itable that is I here now if I copy this
and I'll
paste it here if I run it again
you can see it here the iter function
Returns the
second I treble which is n in my list i
n d i a
I'll paste it again if I run it we have
the
third item in the list which is d
ok
now coming to using the
power function in Python so python pow
the Power function Returns the power of
the given numbers let's say x raised to
the power 3.
so I'll
declare a variable X1 and say pow
let's say I want the value of 3 raised
to the power 3
and let's say I have another variable
called X2
I'll use the pow function and this time
I want to know what is 2 raised to power
4.
we'll go ahead and print X1 and X2
and as you guessed it 3 raised to the
power 3 or 3 cube is 27 and 2 raised to
the power 4 is 16.
cool
now coming to using the range function
so the python range function returns a
sequence of numbers starting from 0 and
increments by 1 so this is by default
and stops before the given number
so let me show you
if I say x equal to I'll use the range
function and inside the range function
I'll have my value as 6. then I'll say
for n
now here n is my iterator variable I'll
say for n in x
print n
let's run it and we'll see the result
you can see here the range function as
returned us the
number starting from 0 and it has
gradually incremented the iterator by
one so we have from 0 till 5.
now I'll show you another example
I want to change
the default starting value that is 0 so
I'll save x equal to range I'm going to
start from 40
till 50
with a step size of 2 so you can pass it
as the third argument so it will Skip
One value and print the next value so
then I'll say for n
in X I'll give a colon
let's print n and we'll see the result
you can see here it starts with 40 and
has a step size of 2 so we have 40
42 44 46 and 48 cool
now let's move ahead and we'll explore
the round function in Python so the
round function rounds off a number to
the given number of digits
let's say I have x equal to I'll use the
round function
and then I'll have a decimal value let's
say
8.624
and I want to round it to two decimal
places
let's print X
if I run it you can see here my python
has returned a rounded up value to two
decimal places so we have
8.62 and the rest it has just skipped
now moving ahead we'll explore the
sorted function in Python so the sorted
function returns a sorted list of the
specified either object you can specify
ascending or descending order
so I'll create a list called a
and we have
the elements let's say again India so I
have I n
d
I
and I have a again
if I say x equal to
sorted a and
if I print X
you can see it here python has sorted
the elements in the list in
ascending order of the letters so we
have a appearing first then D again I
and I and then finally we have n now
suppose you wanted to print the letters
in descending order you can use another
argument here I'll give a comma and say
reverse
equal to true
so this
line will ensure
my list is sorted in descending order
you can see it here it has just reversed
the above result so we have n appearing
first and I I D and E
you can do the same for a list of
numbers let's say we have 12 50
let's say 27 80 and 5.
I'll say x equal to
sorted a and will print X
if I run it you see it here we have
sorted the numbers in the list in
ascending order now if you want to
sort it in descending order just add
reverse equal to true
there you go here my list has now been
sorted in descending order of elements
now we are going to look at the final
built-in python function which is slice
so the slice function returns a portion
of an iterable as an object of the slice
class based on the specified range
suppose I have
a list called a
okay let's not Define a list we'll
Define our Tuple
so this has the letters
in the word simply load
so I have SIM
p
l
I
again l
I have e
comma I have a
then we have R and finally I have n
so these are the letters which have been
represented as a tuple
simply learn then I'll use the slice
function
and
I'll give my ranges 5 and will print
a of x
let's run it you see it here
the slice function has sliced the first
five elements in my Tuple so we have s i
m p and l
cool
so we have explored
all the important
built-in python functions now let's head
over to using
user defined functions or learning user
defined functions in Python I'll give a
comment first user defined functions
cool
so as we had learned in our slides
to define a user defined function we
will use the def keyword
and
a function name this should be a valid
python name so I'm using func one
followed by parenthesis and then we'll
have a colon
and now we'll Define the body of the
function I'll say
print
hello world this is the same example
that we had seen in our
slide
now I am going to call the function
using the function name which is
f u n c 1 if I run it you can see it
here I have my message printed hello
world
so this is a very simple user defined
function and it does not
carry any arguments or parameters
now let me show you another
user defined function I'll say def
hello
again we are not giving any parameter to
this function or arguments to this
function
I'll say name equal to Str this time we
are going to take the input from the
user so I'm using the input function
I'll say
enter your
country name
give a
colon and a space
and then we'll say
print
I'll print the message hello
followed by a space
give a plus sign
and we are going to convert our name to
string
so this is my function let me run it now
I'll call hello
it is asking me for
entering
country name I'll say Japan
if I hit enter it says hello then
my country name which is Japan so hello
Japan let me run it again this time I'll
say USA
I'll hit enter you can see here my
message is hello USA
cool
now moving ahead to our next example
where we'll see
using functions with different
parameters
so we'll start with a very simple
example
I'll say
Def
I want to convert
feet to centimeter
I'll see my function name as FD
underscore 2 underscore CM so I'll pass
in a
value for feet and that feed will be
converted to centimeters
and this time inside parenthesis I'm
going to pass in
my parameter as ft
I'll use the formula for centimeter I'll
say
my variable centimeter equal to
feet
multiplied by
30.48
so 1 feet is actually
30.48 centimeters so centimeter becomes
feet into 30.48 then we are going to use
the return keyword and I am going to
return the output which is centimeter
let's run it
now to call the function I'll use my
function name which is Ft underscore 2
underscore CM this is my function name
and then I am going to pass in a
value for feed let's say I want to
convert 6 feet into centimeters if I run
it there you go you can see it here six
feet is actually
182.88 centimeters let's see
5.8
if I run it it is
176.784 centimeters
so here you saw how to pass in arguments
to a user defined function
again you can pass in multiple arguments
let's say
I'm going to find the sum of two values
for that I'll create a function called
EF
my function name is ADD I'm going to add
two values X and Y
so I am passing in two parameters X
comma y
I'll create a variable called sum that
will store the value of x plus y
and then let's print some
okay let me just scroll down
I'll hit shift enter to run it okay we
have created my function
that is ADD now let's add 40 and
50.
you have to pass in two arguments
because we have declared X and Y in the
function so it needs at least two
arguments if I run it you have the sum
of 40 and 50 which is 90.
let's say I have
minus 20 and
30. if I run it you have the result
minus 20 plus 30 is 10.
all right
now similarly you can also multiply two
numbers let me just
copy this
I'll
paste it here
and instead of ADD
I'll give my user defined function name
as
multiply
I'll say
product equal to X
asterisks Y and I'll print
product let's run it and call my
function using the function name
multiply let's say 4
multiplied by 6.
so the result is 24. cool
now moving ahead
we'll explore another example let's say
I want to print the absolute value of a
number
so I am creating a function called def
my function name is absolute and I'll
pass in
one parameter which is X
I'm going to use
eiffel's statement I'll say if x is
greater than or equal to 0
we'll give a colon
then I'll say return X
else
give a colon
I'll say return
minus X
and run it
Wi-Fi print
absolute
of let's say
56 the result is as expected since 56 is
greater than 0 we have just returned 56
let me just copy this
I'll paste it here let's say absolute of
minus 56 is again 56 because we are
returning minus X so minus of minus 56
becomes plus 56 now if you wanted to
return minus 56 you need to
make some modifications I'll put another
minus and keep this within brackets let
me run the function again
and now if I print absolute of minus 56
you have the result as minus 56 okay
now let's see another example how to
find the factorial of a number using
a user defined function so we'll Define
our function as def I'll use the
function name as factorial
I am going to pass in uh
parameter called X I'll say if x is
equal to equal to 0
then we'll just return X or return 1.
I'll say else
give a colon return
I'll say X
asterisks or multiplied by I'll use the
function name factorial
I'll say x minus 1.
now let's run it
I'll call my function
factorial
let's say I want to find the factorial
of 5 the result is 120 let's say the
factorial of 10 the result is
36 lakhs 28 800.
cool
now let's see how you can pass in
default arguments to your function or
default parameters
okay
suppose I have
a function defined called welcome
here I am going to pass my argument
as name and
in the argument itself I'll pass in the
value or default value let's say Paul
give a colon and I'll print
hello
this would be within
quotes
and the name
cool let me just run it
now I am going to call the function
welcome
this time I am not giving any value to
my function if I run it it has
automatically taken the default argument
which was Paul so my message becomes
hello Paul
now
let's say I'll pass in a value
welcome
and within quotes I'll say DC
now the message becomes hello racy so if
you pass in
a value to your
function welcome explicitly it will take
that value instead of the default
argument
cool
now you can also have multiple arguments
in your
function as we saw above
for the addition and multiplication
functions
I'll create a function called
message
and we'll have
the arguments as name one name to and
name three
give a colon
I'll say print
a message that is
hello
give us peace give a comma we have nim1
give a comma and then I'll say
comma please
tell
give another comma
I'll have my name too
give a comma
followed by the message that
I have name three
this should be a comma instead of a
period
then I'll say is waiting
make sure this is within quotations
again
just give a exclamation mark
okay
so I have my message let's run it
now I'll call my function
message
we need the arguments now so I'll pass
in three names let's say my first name
is Gilly
my second name is Rachel
and my third name is let's say Shaw
I'll run it and you can see here we have
my message printed hello followed by
name one which is Kelly so hello Gilly
please tell name 2 which is ritual so
please tell Rachel that name three which
is sure that Shaw is waiting cool
now we'll understand about
scope of variables in a function
now your scope could be a global scope
or a local scope
let's define a function called func
three
inside the function I am going to create
a variable called Z which has a value of
7. now I'll just print
Z and I'll call in my function
if I run it you have the value printed
of Z that is 7 now if I want to access
my variable that is z outside the
function if I run this it throws me an
error because this variable Z was
defined locally that is inside the
function and you cannot access Z outside
the function
now to overcome this issue let me just
copy this
we are going to declare Z as a global
variable
so I'll have Z outside the function I'll
see
Z equal to 7 and then I have
my function defined I'll just change the
name of the function to
function 4 and then we'll
print Z and I'll call the function
function 4 if I run it
you can see it here I have the value of
Z printed that is 7 now if I want to
access Z outside the function then also
it's fine because we have defined Z
outside the function that is z is now a
global variable so its scope is
throughout the function
now another thing to note here is you
can't change the value from inside a
local scope
so if I say Z equal to 7
and then I'll Define my function f u and
C let's say 5.
I'll give a colon and I'll see let's see
I want to alter the value of Z to let's
say Z plus seven
I'll print Z
and let me now call
func5
if I run this it throws me an error as I
said it says local variable Z referenced
before assignment so you can't change
its value from inside a local scope for
that you're going to explicitly Define
the variable Z AS Global let me show you
how to do it I've just copied this code
and paste it here
I'll say Z equal to 7
I'll Define my function let's say f u
and C 6.
here I'm going to see
global
C
so I have explicitly defined my Z as a
global variable now if I
call the function 6. you can see here we
have altered the value of Z from 7 to Z
plus 1 that is 7 plus 1 which is 8. okay
now asterisks arcs in function
definitions in Python are used to pass a
variable number of arguments to a
function suppose you don't know the
exact number of arguments you need so
you can use
the argument within asterisk symbol let
me show you how to do it
I'll say Def
welcome
and here I am going to pass in asterisks
followed by the
name of my argument which is names
I'll say print
I'll print my message as hello
comma
then I am going to say
names
the first name
which is with
index value of 0
comma followed by your space
then I have
neem
one
and give a
comma followed by your space and then
we'll have names
two
there should be names
okay
let me run this now I'll call my
function welcome
now you can see here I have passed in my
argument that is names three times so
let's
call
three names Let's see we have Steve then
we have
Bill and then we have let's say yes
if I run this
there you go we have a message printed
hello Steve Bill yes
okay now coming to the final section of
our demo here we are going to find out
the area of a circle and a sphere so we
are going to Define two functions one
for Circle and another for spear
so first of all let me Define the value
of pi which is 3.14
I'll start
with def I'll
give my
function name as circle area
and inside that I'll pass in my argument
that is radius
I'll give a colon and we are going to
return the area of a circle
which is pi
R square so I'll have
radius
again an asterisk symbol and then reduce
so this becomes Pi into radius into
radius which is pi R square
okay now let's define another function
called def I'll say
spear
area
I'll have my
argument as radius
give a colon and say
return
4 Pi R square which is the area of a
sphere so I'll have 4 multiplied by pi
multiplied by
radius multiplied by radius so this
becomes 4 Pi R square
now we are going to Define
the mean function so I'll say define
mean
where we'll just have
a print statement so I'll say print
Circle
area
with
radius
15.
I'll give a
comma
and say
circle area
which is my function name
and will pass in the value of the radius
which is 15
I'll just copy this message
and we'll print it here I'll see
spear area
with radius 15 is
I'll just change this to spear
and let's say we'll have radius for 10
instead of 15
okay
finally I am going to call my main
function so I'll just say
Main
now let's run it
okay there is one error here
this is an indentation problem now I
will run it again there you go so the
circle area with radius 15 is
3.14 which is the pi value multiplied by
radius into radius that is 15 into 15 so
the value is
706.5 and similarly the sphere area with
radius 10 is 4 into 3.14 into 10 into 10
that is
1256.
all right
so what is the Lambda function
a Lambda function is one of the simplest
ways to define a function in Python a
Lambda function is an anonymous function
defined without a name and does not have
the def keyword
it can accept any number of arguments
but can only have one expression so the
function is always defined using the
Lambda keyword which you can see it here
so here we have the Syntax for Lambda
function we use the Lambda keyword
followed by the arguments and then we
have a colon after that we have the
expression that we want to evaluate
cool
now moving ahead let's look at an
example of using Lambda function in
Python
now if you were to add two numbers in
Python using a function you would
ideally use the DF keyword followed by
the function name and then pass in the
arguments you can see the arguments here
A and B
then
use the return statement to get the
value of the addition so we have written
a plus b
and finally you will call the add
function and pass the argument values to
get the result
now this operation can be done using the
Lambda function as shown here so we have
defined a variable called add which is
equal to and then we have used the
Lambda function followed by the two
parameters or arguments so here A and B
are the arguments and then I have my
Expression A plus b see all this you can
do it in one line
and then to call the function you use
print
followed by the variable which is ADD
and then you have the arguments three
command so the addition of three plus
eight would be 11. now you can see that
instead of using the DF keyword we have
used the
Lambda keyword and there is no
parenthesis required anything after the
Lambda keyword is treated as a parameter
or argument
so
we use a colon to separate parameters
and the expression in our case the
expression is a plus b
now moving ahead we'll look at
the pros and cons of
Lambda functions so Lambda functions are
suitable for simple logical operations
so when we want one expression in return
we can use the Lambda function now
Lambda function is used as a parameter
to different functions such as map
filter reduce we will see all this in
our demo session
now coming to the cons of using a Lambda
function so Lambda functions can only
evaluate one expression as I told you
earlier
you cannot write a dog string to explain
all the inputs operations and outputs as
you would do in a normal user defined
function that uses the DF keyword and
finally Lambda functions are generally
not preferred when you have to declare a
function with multiple lines of code
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook where we will learn about
Lambda functions and how to use it in
different ways
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me
just go ahead and we'll
rename the notebook as
Lambda
functions in Python
okay I'll just click on rename
cool
first of all I'll write a
General user defined function using the
def keyword let's say I want to add two
numbers
so this example we have already seen in
our slide
so the way to do is I'll use the DF
keyword followed by the function name
and then I'm giving my arguments or the
parameters after that
let's say I want to store
the addition of e plus b in a variable
called result so I'll say result equal
to e plus p
and then
I want to return my output that is
result so I'll see return result
so this is how you will normally create
a function in Python
if I run it and then
I'm going to call my function using the
function name that is ADD and then I'll
pass in
my parameters A and B let's say my e is
3 and B is 4.
if I run this
I will get the result 7 which is fair
enough
now if I want to
do the same operation using
a Lambda function I would do something
like this let's say I'll create a
variable called add and then I'm going
to use the
Lambda function
followed by the arguments a comma p
then I'll give a colon and say A Plus p
after that I'll just say add
and then pass in my parameters
3 comma 4 if I run it you have the same
result that is 7.
now let's see another example using
Lambda functions to add a number this
time I am going to pass in only one
argument
so I'll say add equal to
Lambda
my argument is X I'll say x colon X Plus
let's say I want to add x width 100.
I'll say
print
and let's say I want to add 50 with 100
if I run it I have the result 150.
all right
now in Python there is no need to assign
a Lambda to a variable you can directly
call it let me show you how to do it
I'll say
Lambda
a comma B which are my arguments
again
this time I am going to use
a multiplication
operator
since I want to do a product of A and B
and after that
using another parenthesis you can
directly pass in the
arguments so there is
no need to explicitly assign a Lambda to
a variable
so if I want to find the product of
let's say 15 comma 30
if I run it I have the result 40
let's change the arguments let's say I
want to find the product of 5 comma 7
the answer is 35.
so this is known as an immediately
invoked function expression or iife
which is often pronounced as if he
you can also use keyword arguments using
Lambda functions let me show you what I
mean
I'll create
my Lambda function and assign it to a
variable called Product I'll say
Lambda
let's say my arguments are x y and z
after that I'll give a colon and say X
multiplied by y multiplied by Z
next I'll say print
my variable that is product
and here I am going to use keyword
arguments so I'll say let's say
Z equal to 5.
x equal to 10 and y equal to 4.
you can see here
this need not be in an order as you have
defined the arguments
if I run this I have the result the
product of 5 multiplied by 10 multiplied
by 4 is 200.
now you can also
use default arguments
suppose I say add equal to I'll use the
Lambda function
and say x comma
why I am assigning a default
value of let's say 15 and Z let's say
I'll assign a default value of 24. then
I'll give my colon followed by the
expression that is X Plus y plus Z
now I'll say print
add
now here I'm going to only pass in my
value for x since I've already given a
default value for
argument y and z
so my function only needs
one argument that is X so let's say I
want X to be
20. if I run this you see the result
here so 20 plus 15 plus 24 is 59.
now you can also use the asterisks
args parameter or args
so this allows you to Define as many
arguments as you want
so I'll say addition
equal to
Lambda
then I'll say Asterix ergs so this will
allow us to pass in as many arguments as
you want and I want to find the sum of
arcs so I'm using the inbuilt sum
function in Python now I'll say print
my variable name that is addition
and let's say I want to find the sum for
four values or four arguments let's say
40 and let's say 50.
if I run it so the value is 112 So 20
plus 2 plus 40 plus 50 is 112.
cool
now Lambda functions are also used with
higher order functions which take one or
more functions as arguments
or return one or more functions let me
show you
so I'll Define a variable
called higher underscore ORD underscore
fun which stands for function and ORD
stands for order
so I'll declare my Lambda function
suppose the parameters are X
and then I have a
function
and Then followed by a colon I have
expression as X Plus
function of x
now I'll see
higher underscore ORD underscore
f u n
and I'll pass in my two
arguments let's say my X is 20 and for
this
function
I'll have
a Lambda function defined I'll say
Lambda X colon
X multiplied by X
now
let me just run this and I'll show you
the result okay so what it did was
it added
my value of x that is
20 with
function of X or f u n of X what is f u
n of x f u n of X is
X multiplied by X so 20 multiplied by 20
is 400 so this becomes 400 plus X
which is 400 plus 20 hence the result is
420.
so this is known as a higher order
function
now let me show you another example
let's say I want to display order even
by
taking the value of x
I'll say Lambda X colon
here I am going to pass in my expression
if x
mod
give a space here
I'll say and
odd
or
even
now I'll give my
argument value let's say 30
the result is even because 30 is
divisible by 2
I just change this to let's say 15.
if I run it the answer is odd because 15
is not divisible by 2.
let's say I have 150 the answer is even
now moving ahead
so let's write a Lambda function that
checks if a string is a substring of the
given string
so I'll create a variable called sub
underscore string
now I'll assign this variable with the
Lambda function I'll say Lambda
my
argument let's say string
I'll give the colon and pass in my
expression string in
let's see my string
has this message welcome to
python
functions tutorial
okay
so we are going to check
if a string let's say in two welcome
python Java anything whether it's
present inside the string which is
welcome to python functions tutorial
now let me go to the next line
I'm
going to print
sub underscore string and let's say I
want to check for my string
let's say Java
if I run it it gives me false because
the word Java is not present inside my
string welcome to python functions
tutorial
suppose I write
python
now one thing to note here is the p is
small and here the p is in capital
letter
if I run it it again gives me false
because
python is case sensitive now if I make
this as capital P it will result in
true
let's say I want to see
instead of tutorial let's say I have
training
if I run it it tells me false because
this word training is not there in the
string welcome to python functions
tutorial I'll change this to tutorial
you see here I have my result as true
all right
now let's see how to use Lambda
functions using filter function so we
are going to filter a list of numbers
using a specific condition
so I'll create a list called num
let's say it has values 40
10 40
then we have 56 27 let's say 33 59 and
70.
so this is my list now I am going to use
my Lambda function
along with the filter function
so I'll pass in my variable as greater
I'll say list
then
I'm going to
pass in the filter function and inside
the filter function I'll use the Lambda
function
and I'll have my
argument as num and my expression let's
say I want to filter only those values
which are greater than 30.
so I'll say num greater than 30 this is
my expression
or the condition that we want to check
I'll give a comma and
I'll have my next argument as num
and let's go ahead and print the
variable greater
if I run this there you go you can see
here we have all the values from the
list or the numbers from the list that
are greater than 30. so we have 40 56 33
and 70. so 10 27 and 15 are less than 30
and hence those three values were not
printed
now let's say you want to filter a list
of numbers that are divisible by 4.
so I'll create another list called list
one
and
let's say I'll have the
same values in the list so I'll just
copy it and I'll paste it here
and I'll create my variable let's say
divide
I'll say divide equal to
list one
I'll use the filter function followed by
the Lambda function
I'll say X
colon
then I'll have my expression X
mod 4 should be equal to equal to 0
I'll give a comma and pass in my
next argument as my list one
now
I'm going to
say print
divide
okay
okay I'll remove the bracket here there
is no need of a bracket here cool
and we'll delete here as well
now let's run it
okay there is one error here this should
be list one
let's run it again
okay there is some error let's debug it
okay so this should be the function list
cool
there you go so here you can see we have
two numbers
40 and 56 that are divisible by 4. the
remaining numbers are not divisible by 4
and hence when not printed
all right
now let's go ahead and explore how you
can use the map function along with the
Lambda function
so the map function accepts two
arguments a function and a list it takes
that function and applies it to every
element of the list and Returns the
modified list
so we'll create a list called
list two
I'll say equal to
and again we are going to have the same
values in the list as above
so I'll just
copy those values or the numbers
I'll paste it here
okay
now
let's say
I want to find
the value of a number multiplied by 2 so
I'll say
let's say the variable name is double
the num or double the number
I'm going to use the list function
followed by the map function this time
and then we'll have our
Lambda function
I'll pass in my argument as X
colon
followed by the expression so X
multiplied by 2
I'll give a comma and then we'll have
the list that is list two
there is a spelling mistake here this
should be list two all right
now
I'm going to say print
double underscore the
underscore num
make sure there is no space
in the variable name
now if I run it
you can see here we have multiplied
every number in the list by 2 so
10 multiplied by 2 is 20
40 multiplied by 2 is 80 similarly 30
multiplied by 2 is 66 15 multiplies by 2
is 30 and again we have 70 multiplied by
2 is 140.
so this is how you can use
map function with
Lambda functions
now suppose you want to find the power
of a number let's say I want to find the
power of a number raised to 3.
so I'll create a list called list three
let's say I have values 2 comma 5 comma
10 comma 6 comma 4 and then let's see we
have 12.
I'll see
Cube
so I want to find
the value of a number raised to the
power 3
so for that I am going to use the map
function followed by the
Lambda function
I'll pass in my argument X
and then
here I am going to use the inbuilt power
function in Python so pow
my
argument X and this x I want to raise it
to the power of 3
and then I'll have my
next argument which is
list underscore 3
or list three
okay
now
let's
print the list so I'll say list of cube
I'll run it you can see here so 2 raised
to the power 3 or 2 cube is 8 5 cube is
125 10 cube is thousand six cube is 216
4 cube is 64 and 12 cube is
now coming to the final section of the
demo where we'll see how to use
the reduce function in Python along with
the Lambda function and then we'll use
the Lambda function within a user
defined function
so first let's look at how to use reduce
in Python so reduce applies a ruling
calculation to all items in a list you
can use it to calculate the total sum or
to multiply all the numbers together so
reduce function is a part of func tools
module so to use the
reduce function you need to import the
func tools module first so I'll say from
Funk tools
import
my function that is reduce
and then I'll say
let's say I have my list 4 this time
I'll create a list
I'm going to take the same values as
above
and I'll pass in within a list
and now
I want to find the sum of all the
numbers that are present inside this
list called list four
so I'll do that using my reduce function
followed by the Lambda function
so I'll say x comma
and I'll give my expression as
y colon X
plus y
give a comma and pass in my last
argument which is my list itself which
is list four
all right and then I'll say print
sum
let's run it there you go so 2 plus 5
plus 10 plus 6 plus 4 plus 12 is 39. so
this is how you can use the
reduce function in Python suppose you
wanted to find the product of all the
numbers present inside the list so you
can just
use the
asterisks instead of the addition
operator now if I run this you have the
product of all the numbers that were
present inside the list that is list
four we have 28 800.
now
let me show you the final demo that is
using a Lambda function in a user
defined function so first of all I'll
create a
user defined function to calculate the
value of a quadratic equation
so
for some of you who don't know the
formula of quadratic equation it is a x
square plus BX plus C so we are going to
use that formula in our function
and find the value using Lambda function
so I'll create a user defined function
called quadratic
and it will have
three arguments a comma B comma C
I'll see return
and here in the return expression I am
going to pass in my Lambda function I'll
say Lambda X Which is my
argument I'll say x colon
then I'll have my equation which is a
x square so I am saying a multiplied by
X
raised to the power 2 so I am using
double
Asterix
Plus
B
multiplied by X so this becomes ax
square plus BX
Plus
I have my constant that is C
now
just go to the next line
I'm going to create a variable let's say
f
I'll have my
user defined function name quadratic
I'll pass in the values for a b and c
let's say a is 2 B is 3. and C is let's
say 5
and I'll call a of 1. the value of x is
the value of a is 2
the value of B is 3 and the value of c
is 5. now let's run it and see the
result so
ax square plus BX plus C for
equal to 2 b equal to 3 and c equal to
5 the result is 10.
now let's change it to let's say I want
the value of x as 2 if I run it you have
the
equation evaluated and the result is 19.
all right
so what is the class in Python a class
is a virtual entity or a blueprint for
creating objects
a class in Python provides a means of
bundling data and functionality together
you can think of a class
as a school so here School becomes your
class a school has attributes about the
students classrooms Labs playgrounds Etc
hence the school can be called a class
and classrooms Labs desks playground
assembly are the attributes or objects
of a class
a class comes into existence when it is
instantiated or initiated
we can create as many objects as
possible in a class now in Python a
class is created using the keyword
called class followed by the class name
the first string inside the class is
called doc string and has a brief
description of the class below you can
see the syntax of creating a class in
Python we have the class keyword
followed by the class name this should
be a valid python name and then you have
a colon
below that you have the statements that
should be present inside the class now
let's look at an example of a class in
Python so
here you can see we have created a class
called student and we have two variables
the student ID and the name of the
student
and after that we have created a
function using the def keyword so this
is a user defined function and the name
of the function is called display
and inside the display function we are
giving a parameter called self so here
the self parameter refers to the current
class object and accesses the class
variables we can use anything instead of
self but
it must be the first parameter of any
function which belongs to the class
now moving ahead
so let's look at what is an object in
Python
so an object is also called an instance
of a class and the process of creating
this object is called instantiation
now you need to create an object of the
class if you want to use the class
attributes in another class or method
now the procedure to create an object is
similar to a function call So Below you
can see we have created a object called
Stu and we have called the class student
using parenthesis so this is how you
create a class and after that we are
displaying
the message to be printed by calling the
class name followed by the function
which is present inside the class
so this example will create a new object
instance named Stu
we can access the attributes of the
objects using the object name prefix
now moving ahead let's understand the
initialization or init method in a
python class
the init method is similar to
Constructor since C plus plus and Java
all classes in Python have an init
function it is always executed when the
class is being initiated you can use the
unit function to assign values to object
Properties or other operations that are
necessary to do when the object has been
created
so the unit function is called
automatically every time the class is
being used to create a new object so
here you can see we have used
the init method we have defined using
the def keyword then we have parameter
self name and each so we are calling
the class using this object called S1
and then we have passed in the values
for name and age that is delay and his
age is 27 years and after that we are
printing the age and the name as well
all right now let's get started with our
demo on classes and objects in Python on
the Jupiter notebook
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me
first go ahead and rename my notebook to
classes and objects in Python
alright I'll click on rename
first of all
let me show you how to create a simple
class
so I am creating a new class
using the class keyword so this is
the keyword class and
followed by the keyword I have my class
name called new class
one thing to note here is the class name
should always be a valid python name
I'll give a colon and in the next line
I'll just say
x equal to 50 so this x is a variable
which is present inside my class called
new class now if I run it
I have my new class created now if you
want to display the
value of x you can just say new class
dot X now if I run this you can see here
I have my value printed which is 50.
now
we'll see another simple example to
create a class and to call that class
using
an object
so I'll say class
then I'll say
new class let's say one
give a colon
and I'll create a variable called x
equal to 100 so my X is a variable which
is present inside new class 1 and holds
a value 100
now I'll give a comment
create object
so to create object I'll
Define a variable called R let's say R
stands for result and then I'll say new
class 1 so I'm calling my class and then
I'll say print
R which is my new object dot X
let's run it you see here I have my
value printed of X which is 100 so this
is how you can
create or initiate a class using an
object
now let's see how you can use the self
parameter in a class
so I'll go ahead and create a class
called
student
give a colon
then I'll have some variables
or the
attributes of a student let's say the
student ID is 10 and the name is
Anderson
now
inside the class I'm going to
create a user defined function called
display
so I have used my DF keyword followed by
the
function name that is display and inside
the display function I'll use self as my
parameter
and then I'm going to say
print
self dot ID I'll give a comma and I'm
going to print
my name so I have written self.name
so I'll run this and then
we're going to create an object called s
and we'll call our class
that is student and I'll say s dot
display
now let's run it and see the result you
can see it here we have called the
class using this object called s so it's
displaying
the ID that is 10 and the name that is
Anderson
cool
now we are going to see an example where
we'll pass a doc string so in the slide
we discussed that the first
string inside the class is called a dog
string and has a brief description of
the class
so let me show you an example how to
pass in a dark string I'll create a
class again let's say called student
give a colon and then we'll have our
message which is essentially a doc
string I'll say this is a student class
then I'll create a variable called each
let's say the students age is 14. and
then I'll create a user defined function
called welcome
and have myself
parameter after that I'll say print
my message let's say hi comma
welcome to
section
let's say B
and then
I'll come out of the class and we are
going to
print
class name that student Isa student dot
each
and then I'll say print I'll just scroll
down
student Dot
then I'm going to use the
function name that is welcome
and after that to print the doc string
message I'm going to say
my class name that is student
dot I'm going to use underscore
underscore doc underscore underscore
now we have created a class called
student that has a variable called each
so we are going to display the age of
the student and then
we are going to display the doc string
so here we are not going to print the
message which is present inside the
function called welcome
let's run it you can see it here
we
have the message printed so first we are
printing the age of the student and then
we have the doc string message that is
this is a student class
all right
now let's move ahead we are going to see
how to use the init function
in a class
so I'll say my comment init function
all right I'll scroll down
I'll create another
class called student
this time we are going to use the init
function so I am writing DF space
underscore underscore init underscore
underscore then we'll have our cell
parameter let's say the next parameter
is name and then we have the date of
birth of the
student
I'll say self dot name equal to
name
then I'll say self Dot
dob or D to birth equal to
my parameter that is DOB
and then
I'll say
my object let's say S1
I'm going to call my class student
and it will have
values of name and date of birth let's
say the name of the student is Harry
and
the date of birth let's say it is
October 1992.
all right
and finally we are going to print
s1.name and then I'll say print
S1 Dot
date of birth
let's run it
you can see it here we have the name and
the date of birth of the student printed
cool now you can also modify the objects
that you have created suppose I want to
change the name from Harry to Virat
because my object was S1 dot name
Harry I want to change this to Virat let
me show you how to do it
this is very simple I'll just give a
comment that is modify objects
the way to do is you just
see the object name that is S1 followed
by the parameter that is name equal to
let's say Virat
now if I print
S1 dot name
I'll have Virat instead of
Harry
okay
now if you want to delete the object
properties let's say I want to delete
one of the properties let's say I want
to delete name property of the student
to do that
I can use the Del keyword followed by
the object name that is S1 and say S1
dot name
now if I print
S1 dot name it will throw an error
saying student object has no attribute
name because we are first deleting it
and then we are trying to print it and
hence
python cannot recognize this attribute
name
now you can also delete objects that is
all the objects using the Del keyboard
so this means we can delete both the
objects that we created above which is
name and date of birth
so the way to do is I'll just say DL S1
so it will delete all the objects
that is S1 in this case
I'll run this and then let's say I want
to print
S1 Dot date of birth
you see it here
python says name S1 is not defined
because we deleted it
cool
now coming to the final section of the
demo we're going to create a simple
class with init method again
so this time my class name is let's say
animal
give a colon and then I'll write my
init method using the
DF keyword
I'll say self comma
name that is the name of the animal as
the parameter I'll say self dot name
equal to name
and then
I'm going to create another function
called TEF
which is essentially a welcome or a
great message
and that has a parameter that is self
I'm going to print the grid message or
the greeting I'll say hi
my name is
give a comma and then say self dot name
now I am going to create
my object E1 to
initiate my class
so I'll say animal which is the class
name let's say the name of the animal is
puppy
then I am going to say E1 Dot
greet
I'll use parenthesis let's run it there
you go you see here we have a message
printed hi my name is then using the
self dot name
argument of the parameter we are passing
in the value that is puppy all right so
that was a demo session on python
classes and objects so we saw how to
create a simple class in Python and then
we saw how to create objects to
call it class
and then
we
so how to use the self parameter after
that we saw how to
print a message that is present in the
dark string of a class
and then we
checked a few examples on using the init
method in a class then we learned how to
modify objects and delete objects in a
class and finally we saw another example
on init method
all right
if you are looking to be one of them
then yes you are at the right place
introducing you with Celtic postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning let's
take a quick walk through with this
amazing program some key features of
Caltech postgraduate program in the AI
and machine learning include pgp and
AIML completion certificate from Caltech
ctme master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts caltex ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEOs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
we're going to talk about the concept of
inheritance the types of narratives
which are applicable so the different
kind of militants which we're gonna talk
about are single level inheritance
multi-level hierarchical and multiple
inheritance and we're going to support
each concept with an example
before we begin this session I just want
to highlight that inheritance Is Not A
New Concept in any of the programming
languages just like in Python this
concept is applicable across multiple
programming languages like Java C plus
plus Etc
now what is inheritance inheritance
provides the reusability of a code
it allows you to inherit what you have
written in a particular class or a piece
of code and you don't need to rewrite it
you can inherit it so that is the main
purpose of inheritance it is creating a
new class that utilizes the properties
and behavior of an existing class so we
will support this with an example so if
you take a look at the syntax the sample
syntax over here you have a base class
and you have certain attributes
functions associated with the base class
and then you have a derived class in
which you extend basically you inherit
the base class and you inherit the
properties of the base class
now the new class formed is called the
derived class or the child class you can
call it anything derived child or
subclass and the existing class whose
properties are inherited is known as The
Base Class parent or super class these
are synonymous so any where you hear
that okay you know you're working on a
child class or derived class you can
easily figure out that you're talking
about a derived class and whenever there
is a reference to a parent or a super
class it means we are talking about the
base class right now
with this concept with this idea let's
move ahead and look at the different
types of inheritance which are possible
in Python
now here we are trying to display
pictographically diagrammatically the
different kinds of inheritance and this
will make understanding more clear
now let's talk about first single level
inheritance you have a class A and you
have a class B so basically only till
class B only single level child is
inheriting the attributes the properties
of classes so that is what we call as
single level inheritance multi-level is
you have multiple level of inheritance
in for example Class B here in edits
Class A Properties and Class C in edits
Class B properties so ultimately you can
see that the the properties gets
trickled down till class C right so that
is the example of a multi-level
right
next is hierarchical in which two
classes are narrating from a single
class class B is also inheriting from
class A and Class C is also narrating
from class A so both class B and Class C
are kind of siblings to the parent Class
A right
multiple inheritance it means that a
child class in is inheriting properties
from two parent classes so in this
example the class C is inherited the
properties of Class A also and Class B
also so we will be looking at these
examples
when we will be running in Python
now let's
take this example with a real world
object right let's first try to give you
a view of how we are going how what we
want to explain in The Inheritance with
Real World objects right now here we are
taking an example of a black and white
TV and a color TV now single level
inheritance in this type of inheritance
there is only one single derived class
from a single Base Class as I mentioned
earlier so for example you can assume
there is a class called black and white
TV and what are the attributes of a
simple black and white TB it has a
regulator it has a sound adjustment now
there is a child class called color TV
which inherits the basic attributes of
course a color TV also has a regulator a
sound adjustment but additional play on
top of it it also provides new features
like color picture and cable connection
so now what do you understand by this is
that the child inherits the basic
properties from the parent class but it
also adds on the new additional features
so the color TV does not need to rewrite
or the functionality of a regulator and
the sound adjustment it has inherited
multi-level very similar to single level
but now we are adding more features so
like in the previous example color TV
inherited the features of black from
black and white TV Now we move a step
ahead now there is another
classification another advancement of
Wi-Fi LED TV so that has also inherited
the features from color TV right so it's
a multi-level inheritance
so just to reiterate the black and white
TV hat Channel regulator Edition Tina
the color TV added additional features
of color picture quality and cable
connection and the Wi-Fi enabled TV
added the new smart features to the TV
which it inherited from the color TV
multiple inheritance now in multiple
inheritance the derived class is
inherited from more than one base class
right so now for example over here you
have a class called Android which is an
Android operating system based class and
one is the Wi-Fi LED class which has the
Wi-Fi features of like sound picture
Wi-Fi enablement and if you combine all
these features and bring it into another
child class that class is the Smart TV
class which has the features of Android
and the features of Wi-Fi LED TV and
then you call it as a smart TV it has
all the Android applications it has the
Wi-Fi features and Etc so this is the
example of multiple inheritance getting
the best of all the parents
foreign
if more than one class is narrated from
the base class right so now if we just
tweak our prior example and you know
just rephrase it what we are saying is
now from the black and white TV you can
also make a color TV you can also make a
smart TV or you can also make a Wi-Fi
LED TV right so there is no restriction
as such so basically the color TV is
also inheriting the features of a black
and white TV smart TV is also inheriting
the features of a black and white TV and
the Wi-Fi LED TV also is inheriting the
features from black and white TV so it's
a very typical example of a arq in
inheritance
so now let's quickly look at the
examples
okay so let's start off
with a very simple single level
inheritance
let's make a class
and create a function
called speak
and print something
okay
now let's make another class
so what we did was we created a class
called Homo sapiens and in the and now
we are creating a class called man which
inherits
uh the attributes of homo sapiens and we
say
create a function which is specific to
man so almost base sapiens has a
function which called speak and man has
a function called Talk
and let's print it
now let's create an object of man now
what does this signify the man class is
also inheriting whatever is there in
Homo sapiens so man can even talk and he
can even speak right
so what we are going to do is
first we are going to execute the
function
Peak
so the
The Base Class function got called speak
and it is printing Homo sapiens speaking
and also we can call the child function
okay so so if you see this is the basic
difference which we want to highlight
that just you have created the object
only for the child class not the parent
so now making by making the object of
the child class
you can invoke the parent class function
as well as the child because the child
has inherited the parent features
now let's take an example of
multi-level
so we will
continue from our previous example we
will create a class homo sapiens
Define in
functions speak
and
print
now we will make another class
man
now we are saying
man can walk
so we are saying man walking
now this is the third level this is the
multi-level
the child
and
we are saying that a man child can eat
so ultimately The Man Child can speak
can walk can eat all three operations
can be performed
so we are going to make a object of man
child
and now
python will allow us invoke walk
function
Peak function
and eat function
perfect so this is our typical example
of multi-level hierarchy
now
moving to our next type of inheritance
which is the multiple inheritance where
the child is deriving
attributes properties from
two parents
so we will now create a class called
calculation one
in our example
and let's make a function sum
and it will return
calculation X Plus y
second
calculation 2
and
let's create operation subtraction
and it will return x minus y
okay
now
we will create the derived class which
is inheriting both calculation 1 and
calculation 2.
and
let's create
its own function called multiplication
okay so derived class now has a sum
function subtraction function and
multiplication okay
so let's create an object for derived
and now let's invoke the relevant
functions so some
subtraction
it should say minus 40
and
multiplication
thousand
so if you see it's it's a different from
multi-level it's multiple it means that
the child class has inherited from two
parents it's relevant functions right
and that's how we are able to call them
in the grade class
now let's take another type hierarchical
inheritance
okay so in hierarchical in inheritance
let's go back to our example of
first we have the black and white TV and
we will create a function called
antenna
print channels are telecasted through
then we will create
color TV
and
we will Define its own function called
cable connection plus it has inherited
the function called antenna from black
and white TV
here it is okay
now we are going to create another class
called as
Wi-Fi LED TV which is also in editing
from black and white
now in this we are defining bluetooth
tethering function
okay
and let's make another Smart TV
okay and then we are gonna
you can watch
Android applications on Ott platform
right so this is the class of smart TV
okay so what we have done eventually
over here is we have created a black and
white TV color TV also inherits from
black and white TV Wi-Fi LED also in
edits from black and white TV smart TV
also inherits from black and white TV
okay now
let's try to create the
relevant objects
we will first create an object of color
TV
then we will create
Wi-Fi LED TV
and then we will create
Smart TV
okay
now we will have the relevant functions
available to invoke
so both all the child all the children
objects now will have an antenna
function A1
A2
and A3
all three are having the antenna
function so we can just try to print it
okay
and then
we can invoke the relevant
child functions A1
cable connection
bluetooth tethering
and Android applications
foreign
key you have color Wi-Fi LED and smart
TV all inheriting the black and white TV
features and its own
its own feature
[Music]
okay
now along with this concept let me just
also introduce
some relevant Concepts which are
applicable along with the inheritance
concept which will be helpful
I also want to show you the example of
init function init function
is a Constructor in Python language and
it is called by default whenever you
instantiate an object
so let me give you an example over here
so here you have a class person and you
have we are just defining the init
function the Constructor
okay and we are just
defining certain attributes
instantiating certain attributes in the
person first name and the last name
and another function which I am calling
is the
print name
I'll print the name it's a
straightforward function
okay so what I'm doing is I am creating
a child class now
called as student which is inherited uh
the features attributes of the person
based class
and
I'm also making a Constructor for
student
and from student I am invoking the
Constructor of the person class right
so now if you see I'm going to make an
object of student
and initialize it with
the self the first name and the last
name
and in eventually
the
parent class init function is being
called first name and the last name and
this function diff print name it will
print James Anderson right as I have
already initiated the
parameters
okay so if you see now what have I done
I have the attribute values in the
parent class are getting printed by
invoking The Constructor of the child
class
so what happened when you invoke student
by default this init function got
invoked the parameters of James and
Anderson got passed then from person you
invoke The Constructor in it and here
now the first name and last name got
initialized and then it got printed
so this is the basic feature of a init
function
now like the way I have called person
dot init over here I I can also make a
call to Super there is a keyword called
super keyword
so let's just take an example of super
keyword
okay let me have my child class like the
previous one parent class the person
class
and
I'll have to just make a change in my
student class
in the init function instead of parent
dot in it I will call
super.net
this is the keyword
super function
which will always invoke the parent
class
gives you the handle to the parent class
and then you can invoke the relevant
method
and the invocation methodology will be
the same and you can
check the output it's going to be the
same but it's that the syntax is
different there is another keyword which
is available for you to invoke the
parent so you don't need to know the
class
of the parent you can just make a call
to the super
now let's also take a look at another
utility utility function called is
subclass right
so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a function
calculation one
calculation two okay so we have created
two classes calculation one calculation
two independent classes no one
inheriting each other now we are going
to create a derived class
now this is the example what we have
done earlier very similar to multiple
inheritance so we are just actually
recreating a
multiple inheritance example
okay so you have a derived class which
has multiple inheritance from
calculation one and calculation two
summation multiplication and divide
relevant functions are there now we will
check
which class is a sub class of which one
right so let's create an object of
derived
now what we want to print is that
whether derived
is a subclass of calculation to
and it should return true
and let's see
another is calculation one a sub class
of calculation two it should return
false right because these two are
independent classes so if subclass is
another function which is available in
Python which helps you
decide you know you can check whether
which is a derived class and which is
not a direct class
next let's take an example of another
function called is instance okay
we will take the same
set of functions
create an object of derived
and check
whether the object D is of which
is it is it of a instance of class
derived or not it's true so instead of
derived if I make it as calculation 2
for example now if I say c equal to
calculation 1
and say c
is instance of derived it should say
false but if I say calculation 1 it
should say true
and if I say calculation 2 should say
false because calculation class is an
independent class D is a derived class
from calculation 1 and calculation 2 so
basically D is in is instance of both
calculation 1 calculation two so it will
always return true
we are going to talk about what is a
python iterator what are iterables right
what are the iterable objects how an
iterator works and then we will also
discuss about how to throw a stop
iteration exception basically when you
reach the end of a list then you can
throw a stop iteration exception and we
will see that with an example
now what is a python iterator
pythonitrator is an object that can
Traverse through iterable objects in
Python like lists tuples dictionaries
sets and returns data one element at a
time so basically you can Traverse
through these lists one at a time and
then you can use it as per your custom
requirement but iterator as an object is
available to you is a tool available to
you in order to Traverse through each
and every element
now they are implemented within for
Loops comprehensions generators in
Python implicitly they are not visible
up front but they are hidden in plain
sight so basically when you're using
Loops when you're using generators
comprehensions implicitly python is
actually converting them in the back end
in an iterator object and giving you the
results
now what are iterables on which you can
iterate list tuples dictionaries sets as
I mentioned are all iterables or
iterable objects other than these you
can't perform any iteration if you have
not created an object of list Tuple or
dictionary or certain of course your
writerable will not be of any use
and these objects internally possess an
item method iter method which is used to
get an iterator A handle to an iterator
and then you can start looping it or you
can start accessing the elements of the
iterator
now how iterator Works python iterator
implements internally
these two methods which you are seeing
on the screen underscore underscore item
underscore underscore brackets and
underscore underscore next underscore
underscore brackets now these two
methods are implicitly implemented by
python for any internal implicit
iterator object but if you have to write
your own custom iterator then you need
to override these methods and I'll show
you in my examples in jupyter Notebook
the iterator object is initialized using
the idea method so basically whenever
you have to create an iterator object
you need to initialize it with ITA and
then use next method in order to
Traverse through it
now stop iteration exception so as I
mentioned when we reach the end of an
iterable right like suppose you have a
list or a set which has a length of four
when you have ended the fourth element
and you're trying to access something
Beyond fourth element which is fifth
then of course you can implicitly raise
a stop iteration exception or python
will throw it so we will see that with
an example but you will get a stop
iteration exception
you know so to prevent in order to
handle it or manage it in your code we
use top itation statement to raise an
error you can raise your custom error so
you can catch this exception and then
raise your custom error in the
underscore underscore next method
so now let's uh support everything with
our examples let's start with a very
basic example of an iterator now let me
create a list with just four numbers and
as I said I'm gonna initialize my
iterator with item method so now I have
created a list and now I am initializing
it with item okay
Now using next I'm gonna print my first
element four okay so it means the iter
internally has given me handle to the
first element
and now as many times I move print next
I am moving to the next element
so now I'm also going to show you a
different syntax this is a syntax but
the output will be same it's a different
syntax to invoke underscore next so its
output is going to be same but the
syntax is only the difference over here
so you're going to get access to the
next element
and then
my fourth element which is 33. now I
have traversed through all my four
elements now what will happen if I again
do next
I have ended I am at the end of my list
so I'll get an exception of stop
iteration right and this is thrown by
python
now let's take another interesting
example if I want to perform iteration
on strings
so I have created a variable and I have
initialized it with geeks and now I have
created an iterator on top of this uh
string variable and I'm going to
Traverse it till the time I and reach
the end of my string so let me
hydrate it and I'm gonna iterate till
the time I get the stop iteration
exception
so also I'm actually explaining here how
to cleanly handle the exception
except
and then break if I get the exception
I'll break out of this program
and here you get the result all the
letters of my string Geeks has been
printed individually
and I think it's a very important
example interesting example that how a
string has been converted now point to
be noted over here is that python has
internally invoked underscore underscore
iter and underscore underscore next
methods which it has implicitly
implemented for string iterator so you
don't need to do anything
now let's take another example to how to
Traverse through a list using for
Loop
so I'm gonna leave for object in list
and just print the list this is
without an iterator I'm just printing my
list so I'm just trying to show the
difference that if you use an iterator
or you do not but how you can access the
elements in the list
now let's take an example of how I can
write my own custom iterator
okay so I'm creating a class where I am
overriding the init method basically
initializing in his initialization of my
class where I'm gonna initialize a
variable Max with 0
and then I am overriding this is the
most important point over here I am
overriding iter method
and then
I am writing another overriding the
underscore underscore next method where
I am adding 6 to my number and then
incrementing my Loop so that
I can move further so in this underscore
next method I am just moving beyond
adding 6 and till the time I reach the
max variable so when I'll invoke my
class
I am passing 9 so it means that I should
not
go beyond
uh 10 basically I should start my
iteration from 6 and will not go beyond
ten nine plus one so I should get
numbers which are between 6 to 10 as per
my expectation
now before we diagnose the output most
important point is that how you have
converted your class to an iterator over
here you in order to invoke make a class
in iterator it is mandatory you override
I take AR and next methods which you
have done over here
okay
so now let's print
okay so six so my number started with 0
initialized with 0 and I added 6 to 8 so
my first result is 6 and now if I keep
printing I will get one value
incremented
seven
eight
thank you
nine
and
10 right so this is the expected output
right
now another example on the same lines
I'm gonna print the first 20 numbers
using my iterator so I am
gonna override the iter method and
underscore underscore next method my
numbers now in this underscore
underscore next method I'm just
incrementing my number y 1 not by 6 and
I'm gonna stop at the limit 20.
so like I showed in my previous example
I'm gonna initialize first my class
and then
initialize my iterator and just then
gonna run a for loop on one
and here is the response output I have
printed the first 20 numbers because I
have created this limit so I am
initializing with one and going till the
max 20 number
but the point is it's not the output
which is more important over here the
most important concept over here is that
you have created your own iterator
we will talk about what is a generator
in Python we will talk about the
advantages of using generators
the utility of the next function which
allows us to operate with generators and
print the values within the generator so
we will see these all these concepts
with an example
now what is a generator in Python
python generators lets you create your
own iterative functions that return the
traversal object with a sequence of
values
so basically when with iterators you can
only work on list tuples or sets but
with generators you can convert your
functions into iterator functions itself
and we will see that when we will be
working on a jupyter notebook
now another important feature in a
generative function is that a yield
statement is used rather than a return
statement so basically
the return statement terminates a
function entirely if you use it within
the function and you know basically
return from the statement while the
yield statement pauses the function
there it is and holding all its states
all its variables the values in the
variables and then continue thereafter
on the successive calls so basically in
a generative function you use yield
functions and I will talk about the
utility of this yield
a statement within the generator
function how it helps in generating
pipeline but just to hold a thought over
here and understand the concept the
yield statement basically holds the
processing of the function at that point
and if you make an invocation of that
generator function again it starts from
there itself where you left it
as compared to return statement return
is a general exit if you make an
invocation of the return statement from
a function it will restart again from
the beginning if you invoke it the next
time and that's the basic difference
so what are the advantages of using
generators it's very easy to implement
the code syntactically it's very simple
within the few line of codes you are
able to achieve the you know functions
and able to implement the logic
you can generate infinite sequence you
don't need to provide the range values
the starting and ending you can generate
an infinite value and I'll show you that
with an example
and uh generators are very memory
efficient they are the most memory
efficient ways of processing huge data
sets
they process the data incrementally and
do not allocate memory to all the
results at the same time they do that
incrementally
they really come in handy when
implementing data science pipelines for
huge data sets in a resource constraint
environment where you have uh you know
constraint on the RAM and the other
resources of the hardware
now another biggest Advantage is
pipelining with generators generator
pipelines are a great way to break apart
complex processing into smaller pieces
when processing list of items so
basically you can break your complex
code into smaller pieces and then
invoke them as a generator
recursively and we will see that how but
basically you are making the complex
code look simple and making it invoke in
a pipeline fashion
now the another most important function
in order to deal and operate with the
generator is the next function the next
function is used to retrieve elements
from a generator object and then print
it so that's how you basically interact
with your generate function you cannot
do that until unless you don't use next
function
so now let's quickly jump to our
examples which we are going to support
for each of these Concepts now let's
start by basically creating our first
generator function
I'm gonna create a variable and
initialize it with one
and I'm gonna do a print
this is just for my
login and showing on the console that
where we have reached and then
I am going to say yield n
okay
so now here we are not exiting the a
function we are just saying that just uh
you know this is the point if you invoke
the function again the function will
start from this point on
foreign
and again if this is the second
checkpoint in the code
and similarly
this is the we are going to have a last
checkpoint in the code
now in order to
create my generator now this is the
my generator initialization my J
now if I use the next function and
invoke my generator
now my
generator has been executed till this
point right n equal to 1.
now if I make a second invocation
now it has moved ahead and printed the
second so it is behaving like a loop it
is now behaving like a loop it is
behaving like an iterator but I have not
created any list I have not created any
Tuple but I am basically traversing
through the variables through the
sequence of the variables within my
generator
and if I again
print it
this is my last this is printed last so
all the checkpoints within my generator
have been executed
now the same example which I have over
here
let me call it in a loop
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
remove these invocations and just
replace it
with a loop call right so this generator
functions remain as is now instead of
writing my next
function
three times I am gonna just invoke my
generator in the for Loop and this will
get invoked the number of times I have
yield in my generator
and my output should be
the you know the these logs which I have
created and of course the variables
yeah so see now what has happened is now
the output is all these three print
commands have been executed plus the
variable values of n as being imprinted
at each checkpoint one two and three
so when I initialize my item variable
during the for Loop this item consists
of the variable values which are there
in my generator
now I'm gonna show you
example of if I use a return statement
in my generator
so I am going to create another
generator
and provide a value
now in 2 during this in middle of this
generator I'm just invoking return
and then I am
printing my second checkpoint
and then the
last checkpoint
now
I'm going to initialize my generator
now if I invoke my first element of the
generator I'll get it there's no problem
because I printed the first item I got
the value of my yield and then I
returned but now if I invoke my second
element in the generator but before
invoking second I have already given the
return statement my generator will exit
and I'll get the stop iteration error
now this is a python generated
exception which is denoting that you
have you cannot move beyond the first
item because you have returned from the
generator over here so that's the
difference if you just remove this
comment this out
and then run it
you will get your second item so it's
not X the code exits if you write return
over here
so I hope you are able to understand the
difference
now let's take another example now here
we are going to create a list and how
uh implicit list like the way Legacy way
we have been creating in Python
differentiates like the way we are
creating a generator
so what I'm doing is I'm creating a list
with random numbers
and then another list in which I am just
Square rooting the numbers in that list
and similarly I'm also creating a
generator which I am expecting the same
output in the new list as the generator
but I'm gonna show you different ways of
traversing the generator as compared to
a list
now if you see this list underscore if I
just make a print call to this list
it's gone straightforwardly uh square
root
uh the numbers and give me the output 4
9 64 and 100
but if I print the generator
I will not get the expected output what
I'm expecting I will just get the
generator object which is not what I
desire so basically you can't just print
the generator like the list you have to
either use the next or you have to
use the for Loop which I had shown
earlier and print each and every item
within the generator
now this is the output which I was
expecting I was expecting the line by
line output of each and every element in
my generator 4 9 64 and 100.
okay
now this for Loop is taking care that it
is not exceeding the number of items the
length of the items in the generator so
this is automatically taken care by this
syntax
but if you don't take care of it then
you will get an exception let me show
you another example if I create a list
and now I'm creating a generator
which is square
of square of all my elements
so now one by one
instead of the loop I'm one by one
printing the output
second output
third element output
fourth element output
okay I have four now if I try to again
print
I'm exceeding the length of
the
uh list I'm gonna get an exception stop
iteration exception because I am
exceeding the length right either I use
before or if I'm using individual print
and next function then I have to take
care that okay how many elements are
there in the list and I cannot exceed
beyond that else the python will raise
an exception
okay
now I'll show another example of
highlighting the difference between next
and the for Loop printing I'm gonna
create a
uh generator for 2 to the power n
so I'm initializing n with 0 and then
just
raising it
2 to the power n
now here I am initializing my generator
and printing it
and I am getting the expected output as
2 raised to the power 0 1 okay
now another way of doing this job is
I Loop over this
and I get the same output so if you see
it's only
I do not have only one element
so either you use for Loop or you print
using next the output is going to be
same
now another important concept which I
talked about if you want to print
infinite in finite numbers so
or you want to do some infinite
calculations I'm going to use print and
all even numbers
so I'm gonna write in generator which is
going to print infinite number of even
numbers
so I have created a generator
and now I'm gonna invoke this and mind
you I have to kill this job because it's
going to keep running
it's going to keep running keep running
because it's constantly generating the
numbers even numbers so I would have to
stop this
but if you see
otherwise this is not possible in any
for Loop the basic for Loop you have to
give a range start and end of the length
but using a generator you can do
infinite
looping
right because here I had to kill this
job I have to do a keyboard interrupt
now I'm going to show you an example of
how you can use generators for creating
a pipeline
so I'm going to take example of
Fibonacci series
create an example of Fibonacci two
variables initialized with zero and one
and now I'm gonna write the logic of
Fibonacci adding the two numbers
to itself
subsequently
and I'm gonna add yield now this is my
generator this is my one generator and
I'm gonna create second generator of
Square
so I'm gonna show you in Excel what
logic I'm going to apply and what will
be my expected output
so I am now squaring the numbers which
I'll get out as an output of Fibonacci
okay
now I'm gonna
I'm creating a pipeline
like this
first I'm gonna generate Fibonacci
series for the first 10 numbers
then I'm gonna find the square of each
of the Fibonacci numbers and add it
so if you see this representation in
Excel I'm going to generate these are
the two variables which I've already
initialized X and Y and from here on
these 10 are my first 10 Fibonacci
numbers
I'm going to find
calculate the square of these numbers 1
4 9 25 and till 55 the square of 3025
and then add these numbers and I should
get the output of 4895 so if you see one
function generator second generator and
the third calculation now this hole has
been done in one single line of code you
have generated created two generators
and just invoked them in a single line
pipeline so entire looping and you know
you don't have to write the looping
operators the for Loop and you don't
have to worry about writing all that
complex logic it is all encapsulated
within this
now let me run and I'm going to expect
this output 4895
and here is my output right so in the
hindsight what python has done is it has
generated these Fibonacci numbers found
the square of these numbers and then
added it in single line
and now this is the convenience
Simplicity which I was talking about
earlier
now let's take another example of
Fibonacci
I'm going to create a generator again
initializing A and B with 0 1
and this time I'm taking an example of
printing the Fibonacci in two different
ways
okay I'm gonna print the first
five Fibonacci series number
the first way I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
print the next function five times
because I'm generating five so let me
run this
these are the first five Fibonacci
number zero one one two and three and I
am also going to use a loop
in order to print
so now in the loop I am invoking the
five Fibonacci numbers
and run it
so either you can
make individual five individual calls or
you can use the for Loop but the output
is the same and you're using a generator
now let's learn about what is scope in
Python
so scope in Python is the area of the
region of a program where you can access
variables functions and objects declared
the scope defines the accessibility of
the Python object so the objects cannot
be accessed from anywhere in the program
variables are not visible to the entire
code so their visibility can be
restricted
now scope verifies which variable to be
accessed
a variable declared inside a function
belongs to the local scope of that
function and can only be used inside
that function
now whenever you use a name such as a
variable name or a function name python
will search through different scope
levels or name spaces to determine
whether the name exists or not
so python resolves names using the legb
rule the legb stands for local enclosed
Global and built in scope
now talking about local scope the
variables which are defined in the
function are called local scope of the
variable so these variables are defined
in the functions body
we're talking about enclosing scope now
this scope only exists for nested
functions if the local scope is an inner
or nested function then the enclosing
scope is the scope of the outer or
inclusion function
coming to Global scope
the variable which can be accessed from
anywhere in the program is known as the
global scope such variables can be read
inside or outside the function
now the global scope is often
implemented when we want to use the same
variable name in the rest of the program
coming to the
final rule which is B that is built in
scope so if a variable is not defined in
local enclosed or Global scope then
python looks for it in the built-in
scope now this scope contains names such
as keywords functions exceptions and
other attributes that are built into
python
now if you define the same variable name
inside and outside of a function python
will treat them as separate variables so
two separate variables one available in
the global scope that is outside the
function and the other available in the
local slope that is inside the function
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll try
Scopes in Python with Hands-On
demonstrations
all right so I'm on my jupyter notebook
let's start with our examples first we
look at
local scope in Python
for that I am going to create a function
called
f u n
and inside the function I'll create a
variable called
s which holds let's say an object called
simply loan
and then
I am going to
print
the variable that is s now in this case
I have defined my variable
inside the function so this becomes
accessible only
inside the function now if I call the
function using the function name that is
fun
and if we run it you can see we have the
message printed that is simply loan now
we'll see another example
so suppose
we'll try to access it outside the
function it will throw an error so I'll
just give a comment try
to access
it
outside the function
all right so again I'll create
a function called let's say
fun one
we'll give a colon and here I'll say
let's say S1 equal to
simply loan
and now
I'll give a comment here print S1
then I'll call my function f u N1
and
I'll try to
print
the variable S1
outside the function so here S1 has a
local scope since it is defined inside
the function but I'm trying to access
the variable outside the function let's
run it you can see the error here name
S1 not defined
now
if I give a
comment and run this
you see there is no message and let me
just remove this comment and print it
you can see we have the
S1 variable message printed that is
simply loan so this is how the
local scope of a function works
now let's see an example of enclosed
scope which is
function inside another function
so I'll create a function
let's say if you and C
and
I'll use the variable this time S2 equal
to
simply loan
and then
inside the func function I'll Define
another function let's say
i n f u n c which basically stands for
inside function
and then here I'll say print s
S2
and
we'll call the inner function that is in
Fu and C
and then I'll call the outer function
let's run it
and see the result
you can see here we have the message
printed
simply learn I'll just
edit this message let's see
welcome to Simply loan
now if I run this you can see we have
updated the message here
now for the enclosed scope you need to
Define an outer function including the
inner function like we did here and you
can also comment out the local variable
of the inner function and refer to the
variable using the non-local keyword let
me show you an example around this
suppose I have a
Global variable called MSG
I'll say this is a
global
scope
message
after that
I'll create a function so I'll Define a
function called
outer
and I'll use the same variable name that
is MSG
and my message would be this is an
outer variable
after that
I am going to Define another function
called
inner
and
this will have
the same variable that is MSG and my
message would be
inner
message
variable
now as I mentioned before I need to
comment out the local variable of the
inner function so I'll just
comment this out
and then
I'm going to say
non-local which is the keyword
so I am referring to the variable using
the non-local keyword I'll say non-local
my variable name that is MSG
and now
I'll
print MSG
will come out of the function and we'll
call it
inner
after that we'll call the
outer function and then I am going to
print I'll just scroll this down and
we'll say MSG
so here what we are doing is so this is
an example of an enclosed scope so where
we have
defined the outer function including the
inner function and we have commented out
the local variable of the inner function
and we are referring to the variable
using the non-local keyword now let's
run it you see here I have my
2 print statements working here the
first one is this is an outer variable
you can see here and then I have print
MSG so this is a global scope message
cool
now
we'll see an example of how the global
scope works though we have already seen
an example above so this was an example
of a global
scope
now we'll see a few more examples around
Global scope again
suppose I have a variable called S3
equal to I'll see
simply loan
and then I'll declare a function
f u n c 1
I give a colon and then say
print
S3
now I'll call the function f u n c one
and will print it
S3
if I run it you can see here I have
simply learned printed twice so I have
used the same variable name S3 inside
the function so
this simply learn is for the local scope
S3 that is this one and outside the
function we have printed S3 again so
simply learn twice
all right
now let me show you another example
about using the
Global scope
create a variable msg1
let's say my messages
welcome to
simply learn
python
programming
I'll Define the function f u and C 2
I'll give a colon
and I'll use the same variable that I
used
or declared above that is mst1
I'll say this is the
inner MSG one variable
then I'm going to print msg1
after that I'll call my function Fu and
C2
and I'll print
MSG one
if I run this
you can see I have the two messages
printed first is this is the inner msg1
variable and the second print statement
will print the
Global variable
message that is welcome to Simply Learn
Python programming cool
now you can also
use the global keyword inside the
function to convert a local scope into
Global scope
now I'll just give a comment using
Global keyword
so I'll Define my function f u n c let's
say three
I'll give a colon
and using the global keyword
I'll say s
and I'll say s equal to
simply loan
now let me
call Fu and C3
and we'll print as outside the function
now one thing to remember here
my variable has been declared inside the
function but since before declaring the
variable I have assigned the global
keyword to S so this now becomes a
Global scope variable so you can access
it outside the function as well now if I
run it you can see it here I have my
message printed
simply learn if I say hello you can see
it hello printed
cool
now
we'll see another example of using the
global scope let's say I have a variable
called E1
which is
India
and then
I'll create a function called my country
and I'll use
the
Global keyword and say A1
and after that
I am going to
see E1 equal to
I'll change the country to let's say
France
now let me
call the function my country and will
print
A1
and you can
notice the difference in the result
so here initially I had defined India as
a global variable and after that I am
assigning the
same variable name with a global keyword
and hence it will take the updated value
for E1 and you can see here the result
is friends
now finally let's look at
built-in scope in Python
this is the final example in the demo
session about Scopes and arguments in
Python
cool
so
this example is a bit different from the
previous few examples that we saw on
local scope enclosed scope and Global
scope so here I am going to
import
PI from the math
module so I'll say from math
import
pi
so this example includes Global scope
enclosed scope as well as local scope
and of course we have the built-in scope
as well
now what I'll do is first I'll
give a comment and
create a variable called
pi
equal to
I'll say
Global pi
variable
I said this is a global
Pi variable
and then
what I'll do is I'll say
DF let's do one thing first of all we'll
remove
the comment
and now I'll create a
outer function
think of a colon and say
the variable pi
I'll say
outer
variable
pi
and then
I'll create
a nested function
with the name inner
and
I'll say pi equal to
inner
by
variable
now
I'm going to say print
pi
and after that I'll call the
inner function
and
next
I'll also call the
outer function
now if I
run this
you can see the result
inner
Pi variable being printed which is this
print statement
now
what I'll do is
I'm going to comment out the
Global scope variable
and I'll also comment out
the first
outer function variable that I defined
I'll comment this out
and I'll also comment the inner
function y variable
now if I run this
you see the result here
it prints the value of pi that was
imported directly from the math module
or the math Library so here Pi is not
defined in either local
enclosed or
Global scope so the built-in scope is
looked up that is the pi value imported
from the math module so this is an
example of built-in scope in Python that
uses inbuilt
functions modules and objects that are
available in Python
if you are looking to be one of them
then yes you are at the right place
introducing you with caltic post
graduate program in Ai and machine
learning let's take a quick walk through
with this amazing program some key
features of Caltech postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning include pgp
and AIML completion certificate from
caltex ctme master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts Caltech ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEUs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
we are going to start with discussion of
need of exception handling what is
exception handling the types of Errors
you can handle in exception handling and
how exception handling works and in the
end certain points to be remembered and
also we will support our slides with a
python Jupiter notebook examples
now what is the need for exception
handling any programming language or any
program you write there is definitely a
need in order to have a clean execution
of the program even if the program
throws errors so you need exception
handling for cleanly logging the
exceptions or throwing meaningful errors
to the users
so when does exception occurs right
whenever the program gets terminated
right the program terminates whenever an
error occurs right so it could happen
that an error could be a fatal error and
the program gets terminated in between
or there could be a certain termination
which can corrupt the program right so
you need to handle exceptions or they
may be they might be a data loss because
of those exceptions and you need to take
care that that doesn't occur or the data
loss does not happen or even if data
loss happens then you pass on a
meaningful message or you capture a
meaningful message in the logs at the
right point
now what is exception handling an
exception is a runtime error that
terminates the execution of a program
so basically whenever an exception
occurs the program gets terminated you
are thrown out of the running program
exception handling means you generate a
message in correspondence to the
occurrence of the error and take the
right step to handle it so now an
exception has occurred but you need to
handle it now by handling we mean that
you need to throw a meaningful message
as I said earlier and then you might
need to navigate the program into the
right direction or take some certain
corrective actions in order to handle
the error so all that comes under the
exception handling criteria
now in general there are three types of
Errors compile time errors logical
errors and runtime errors now compile
time errors are the errors which any
programming compiler or python compiler
will show you while you are compiling
your program so it could be because of
the syntax spacing
indentation or you would you you are
using wrong keywords all those will get
captured at the compile time logical
errors you know you have not used the
correct syntax around logical operators
like and or or your if else conditions
are incorrect and you are expecting an
output but it is not coming as per your
expectations so those are logical errors
and the most difficult ones to capture
and track and handle are the runtime
errors so imagine your program is
compiled and as per your expectation uh
you are expecting an output you have you
know written a logic but at the runtime
it does not gets executed it does not
run as per your expectation and the
program gets terminated unexpectedly so
the the runtime errors are the most
critical and important in order to
handle them and if you talk about
runtime errors handling in production
scenarios then it becomes very critical
that you have handled the exceptions
correctly and captured the logs
correctly so that the support team can
point out uh where the error has exactly
happened
now how exception handling works
there are certain syntaxes in Python
which you need to follow
now you generally put the uh exception
handling code the code for which you you
want to handle the exception under a try
block so you run that piece of code
under a try block and then you put an
accept keyword where you basically throw
an error message
and then if there is no exception right
then also you can handle the code okay
if there is no exception in my code then
how the code will behave yeah right so
it could be possible that there is a
runtime error but if there is no then
you might want to do some logical uh
calculations or you want to put
something over there you can put in the
else block and then finally now finally
is a code block which will always get
executed irrespective of you had an
exception in your code or not so
basically generally uh if you go by the
Legacy programming if you have opened a
database connection uh or if you have
opened a file and you it is essential to
close those connections uh from your
program then those close connection code
are written generally in the finally
block irrespective of the except
exception coming you need to close those
connections otherwise you will run out
of your connection pools
now it's a pretty straightforward
flowchart of an exception and handling
you start with a try block and then if
an exception occurs in your code then it
will go to the accept block otherwise it
will go in the else section and then
finally you have the finally block where
the code will finally get executed and
stop
so as I said you put that piece of code
in the finally block which is mandatory
and generally the block the code which
is essential to release the resources
which the program has consumed uh the
CPU resources the memory resources
Hardware Resources with the program is
using you have to release that in the
finale block accept block you have to
use for capturing the error and through
a meaningful message or
do any other logical operation and else
block if you want to continue your
program as is
now what are the points to remember
these are very important points which
you should consider you can write a try
block without any except block so it's
not essential that you put a accept
block always
or you can write several except blocks
for a single try you might be expecting
a null pointer exception or a divide by
zero exception or incorrect variable
naming exception so you can start off
with one try but you can have different
except blocks to capture these different
kind of exceptions and throw a relevant
meaningful error per accept block also
you can write multiple accept blocks to
handle multiple exceptions it's almost
the same thing and you can write
exception as an object you can also uh
print or capture an exception as an
object or you can write multiple
exceptions within a tuple you can
capture the multiple exceptions added to
a tuple and throw it away okay so now
let's take a look at uh certain examples
which we want to run in order for better
understanding of exception handling
now throughout my exercise I am gonna
focus on divide by zero error which we
are easily able to simulate so I'm gonna
mostly show you how we can capture a
divide by zero error
okay so I have declared a variable a and
I have declared a variable b z uh as10
BS 0. now I am trying to divide a by B
now I'm trying to divide a number with 0
so ideally yes this is not a correct
mathematical operation divide by number
zero uh is not allowed
so I should get a zero division error
now
this is an unhandled exception my
program has not handled it properly so
that's why you're getting this error on
the uh trace of the Python Trace but
if I handle it properly
then I can very cleanly
throw this error and capture this error
so
I'm gonna take input in B enter A and B
and
I'm just gonna print a generic accept
block
so 10
and I have got an exception and I have
printed it now there is no stack Trace
there is no Trace but at least I am able
to cleanly throw an error a meaningful
error
now
again I'm definitely going to handle the
exception
I'm gonna create the same exception but
gonna handle it differently
now it is a try block
now I am
writing an accept block to capture
the specific exception zero division
error exception
in the earlier code block I had just
written except so any exception would
have come to this block but in this
except block only zero division error
will be captured
so as you can see uh I cleanly
uh handle the exception of course I gave
the name except zero division error and
then my code got executed
later on
now in another example
what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna show you that if my code runs
cleanly then it's not necessary my
except block will get executed
definitely because if there is no error
then the accept block will remain
redundant
all right
now here you see what I have done is
I've taken genuine two numbers
divided them printed a new line and then
completed so as there was no exception
the exception block did not got executed
foreign
to be highlighted over here is that it
is not essential that you know exception
block will get executed always it will
only come into picture when there is a
relevant exception getting generated
now let's take an example of how
Vivo can print an exception object
so I'm gonna take my previous code
and here
I am
capturing the exception but also
printing the exception object
so what has happened is I have printed
the exception of a message a custom
message plus I have printed the
exception object
okay
now I'm gonna take the same example
but I'm not gonna generate an exception
foreign
block did not got executed and I was
able to Simply print
simply learn
now
let's take another example
where I am
capturing my exception in in a variable
so do not divide number by zero
in this x I have captured my exception
division by zero
so in the exception the python generated
exception name is this and I have
printed over here so division by zero is
the python generated exception which I
have appended in my print command
now I'm going to take another example
where I'm saying is that I will print
exception as a plus I'm gonna also
capture another exception so it's like
one try and two exceptions
so one exception is do not divide number
by zero and second exception is name Z
is not defined right
so I'm so as I said earlier you can have
one try but to accept blocks which is
permissible
now one thing is that you know you this
exception print a by Z
came uh went through both the except
blocks except this exception and this
exception though this exception is not
divided by zero error so therefore
therefore in this a variable nothing
came in but in the B variable the name
error was definitely captured because
it's a name undefined name Z is not
defined error and that's why you can see
that do not divide number by zero up
after that we do not have any relevant
meaningful message
okay
now let's take another example where
we are going to have
two except blocks and out of these two
only one will get executed
okay so there is no type error exception
so that accept block did not got
executed but only zero division error is
there so only that got printed
now you can explicitly also raise an
exception it's not like you just have to
wait for a runtime exception you can
also raise your X raise an exception
from your code and execute it so if you
see this what we have done is just
created a variable with a negative value
and just checking that if the value is
less than zero then raise an exception
so that's what we have done
similarly you can also throw raise an
assertion error
it's it is called assert
and you can run
this message you can throw this message
compatible with Linux only
we will understand what is file handling
we will go through certain file handling
operations
then we will understand how to open a
file in Python using various modes which
are pretty important
and then we will discuss the file
handling process the different types of
files which we can create and advantages
of using files
now what is file handling
a file contains a collection of data and
information it is just like a data
storage
so the data can be updated and shared
through files with multiple stakeholders
now file handling in Python performs
functions such as creating reading
updating and deleting so you can perform
the basic crud operations using the file
handling functions and operators
now in Python file operation takes place
in the following order
in order to work on a file you have to
first open a file that is the first and
foremost step and then you can perform
an e-read or write operation and then
you have to close the file
so these three primary steps are
involved in order to do any operation on
a file
now in Python we can work with files
using the open function and it takes two
parameters the file name and the mode
so here you can see the syntax if you do
not give the mode parameter then it
takes the default values which we're
gonna see in our next slide
but at least you need to give the name
of the file with the extension now what
are the various modes in which you can
perform operations on a file let's go
through them one by one
you can open a file first of all in the
read mode which is the default mode
and it opens a file for reading
but if the file does not exist it throws
an error
right second is append a it opens a file
for appending creates the file if it
does not exist so in this mode if the
file does not exist exists it gets
created similarly in the right operation
it opens a file for writing and creates
the file if it does not exist so A and W
will create the file X it creates
specified file returns an error if the
file exists so you cannot create an
already existing file you need to give a
different name then the next mode is the
T mode the text mode which is the
default value so so by default when you
open a file in Python you are basically
opening it in default read text mode
and the next mode is the binary mode if
you specify B it means that you're
trying to open an image or any binary
mode related file which cannot be opened
in a text mode so we will see certain
examples of these modes in our Jupiter
notebook when we will run certain
examples on our sample file now what is
the file handling process right so in in
a plain vanilla process first of course
you will create a file and then you will
open a file update and close the file so
the first thing which you can do but in
the from the function standpoint like we
saw in our previous slide even if you
have to create a file you have to call
the function open then you have to read
it you write in it and then you close it
first thing which you have to then do in
order to
uh interact with the file is always make
a call to the open function
and then you pass the file name and the
mode as a parameter
now as we discussed there are two modes
there are two types of files in Python
text file and binary file so in text
file the data is stored in characters
and string and in binary file this data
is stored in the form of bytes but the
bytes file which you store you can store
in a different extension and it can be
read by other utilities or tools or
softwares which are meant for reading
the binary files but you can interact or
you can
performs certain functions using the
python operators and the open functions
which are available text file is a
simple uh concept you open the file you
can write append update the data and you
can open the file in your operating
system and see your changes so we are
going to perform our examples on a text
file where we will show you how you can
view your changes by opening a file real
time
now there are some preliminary
advantages basic advantages of using
files you this data is stored and is
permanent basically it resides in the
file and then it is up to you how do you
save the data in the file in the
operating system or you purchase the
data in some uh secure area and that is
up to you
and the stored data can be shared
definitely you can mail the data you can
share it in your hard drive you can
share your network drive Etc and you can
update the data in the file so you can
append you can override you can remove
you can delete the file all those
operations all those possibilities are
there
so now let's
create our jupyter notebook
with certain examples
so what I have done here is I have
already created certain sample files
where I have some predefined context
there
so I have a
simply learn.text file in which I have
written today Thursday in one line
tomorrow is Friday and I am waiting for
weekend
now I'm gonna read this file
so I'll import the package in order to
read the file
I'll create the file object now in this
I have given the path where my file is
residing today.txt the same content is
there
and I'm going to be opening it in the
read mode so it's the default mode but
I'm calling it out explicitly for a
better understanding
now this is the read command file dot
read
this operator this will read the entire
file so if you see in my file all the
contents are printed
now
if I want to read
the first seven characters
okay
of my file
so what will this do it will read the
first seven characters of the first line
of my file so in the First Command my
file.read printed all the contents
but here I have passed a parameter to
the read function to print only the
first character seven characters
so that's what it has done
now
I will
ask
my function
to read
line by line
so now what is the difference between
this and this the difference is that the
file dot read read the entire file in
one go but here
it is allowing me to read only one line
at a time
okay
so this function of read line will only
go and read the
line
now
if I have to read all lines one by one
write down
here I have printed one line now I want
to print all lines one by one then there
is a different
function
which is file dot read lines
and it will print an array
and of course you can see there's a
slash n operator because it's a
different line so it will print my three
different lines in an array today's
Thursday tomorrow is Friday and I am
waiting for weekend
now like I gave this example of file dot
read seven characters in the similar
fashion
I can also
provide how many characters to read
from the line
okay
foreign
so from the first line it has given me
the first three characters and here in
the file dot read it was starting to
reading starting to read the entire file
but I only limited to the several
characters
now let's take a look
at the
right function
write method
so now in my today.txt file I now pass
the mode w
and I'll
override it
with my new content which is the Sunday
and Monday
and see file Dot close
and run it
now I can go and check it's been
overrated
now
I'm gonna create a new file
let me
create a new file and
add contents to that
I'll create simply 2.txt and run
and a new file has got created with the
content sunshine
so here I have passed the mode as X
now
I want to delete a file
I will just simply pass
OS dot remove there is no open function
to be called and just give the name of
the file
and my today.txt file is gone
even I can put a check before removing a
file whether the file exists or not
if it exists then remove
else print that the file does not exist
there is no file
now if I want to print line by line I'll
show you one another example if I want
to print line by line
then the example is import
ant
and file dot in the loop and
you print the output
so basically you can if you want to
print the lines in a loop then you need
to put the for command for Loop and put
the red lines call
we will discuss what is sorting in
Python what is the importance of sorting
we will discuss different sorting
algorithms like bubble sort insertion
sort merge sort and quick sort with
examples
what is sorting
sorting refers to arranging available
data in a particular format so typically
when you have data in a non-sorted order
generally there is a requirement in any
algorithm where you would require the
data to be organized either in ascending
or descending order so if you take an
example which is there available on the
presentation here you have a list L1
where you have random numbers which are
unsorted and then you have a sorted
array which is in descending order means
highest number First and the lowest
later so generally any algorithm which
you implement for sorting provides you a
organized
sorted list either in descending or
ascending order
now why is sorting important
now you must have seen practically in
your day-to-day life whenever you are
navigating through a website or through
an application you generally tend to or
you want to see data in a sorted order
either alphabetically or numerically it
makes search faster and easier right
it's it becomes easy to search an item
when if it it is sorted alphabetically
sorting is also used to represent data
in more readable format so it allows you
to read the data which is sorted easily
it helps locate various patterns in the
data so for example if you have an
alphabetically sorted data then you can
easily compare if there is a difference
in pattern in the data which is lying in
an Excel sheet or which is shared with
you in any other data format
also and
another important point is duplicate
values you can easily find out if there
is an occurrence of a duplicate value
when the data is provided to you in a
sorted fashion so all the basic
utilities Standalone utilities
applications like Microsoft Excel or
other utilities provide you basic
functionality of sorting of data
alphabetically or numerically
now python has a built-in sorting method
which is called as sorted and it gives
you a data in ascending order whatever
input you provide the list it will give
you data in ascending order
and python uses a Time series sorting
algorithm in build
to
perform this sorting
so let's take a look of the inbuilt
Sorting algorithm which we have gonna
show you on my jupyter notebook
so it's gonna be very straightforward
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a list
and just
invoke the list dot sort method and
print it
and just with one line of function call
our list is sorted in
ascending order 12 15 27 33 62.
now
with this inbuilt function if you want
to
change the Sorting order right you want
to reverse it in descending order you
just have to pass a parameter saying
reverse equal to 2 true and print d
list so if You observe now you have your
output in the descending order
so this is an inbuilt function the
sorted method but we are here to discuss
custom sorting algorithm and we will
start with bubble sort
now what is bubble sort in bubble sort
algorithm the first element is compared
with the adjacent element and if the
adjacent element is smaller than the
first element the elements are swapped
basically bubble sort is a sorting
algorithm that compares two adjacent
elements and swaps them until they are
not in the intended order
so just like the movement of air bubbles
in the water that rise up to the surface
each element of the array move to the
end in each iteration therefore it is
called a bubble sort
it is the simplest sorting algorithm
that works by repeatedly swapping the
adjacent elements if they are in wrong
order
so we have to remember the point that
they the elements in the array are
swapped till the time the intended order
is reached and the
each element has reached to the last
iteration
so we will see this with an example
now here you have a sample list which
has unsorted data 9864.
now according to the bubble sort
algorithm what it will do is first it
will start from the zeroth element and
compare it with its next adjacent
element 8. now in this scenario
it is smaller than 9 so therefore we
will swap it so 8 and 9 will get swapped
and now you have eight nine six four
now again 9 will be
compared with its adjacent 6 and now 6
is smaller than 9 it will be swapped
coming down 9 now compared with 4
is smaller than 9 it will be swapped so
till this point what has happened is 9
has been compared and
with each of its adjacent element and in
this iteration now 9 is at its correct
place it's at its last place now we
don't need to go to this iteration again
we will only go till the
second last iteration so now we will
start from the beginning we will compare
eight with six
okay and 6 is smaller than 8 we will
swap so now your output is six eight
four nine
again it is compared with four four is
smaller than 8 it is swapped now we will
not go further because now we know 9 is
at its correct position
it is at its correct position now only
we need to do one iteration of
comparison between six and four now four
is less than 6 we swap and this is the
final output of four six eight nine nine
so all the iterations depend on the size
of the list but the
in bubble sort the whole goal is that
you keep it iterating till the time each
and every element is compared with its
adjacent element now let's write a piece
of code in Jupiter in order to compare
our
algo what we have discussed
okay so what I'll do is I'll just create
a list of elements
now this is the list which I showed in
my example and I want to sort it
so I'll create a function
bubble sort
and I'll capture the length of the array
now
I need two Loops one Loop which will run
n number of times the length of the
array
so I'll create a loop
okay
and then there will be a second
iteration which will run
from the first element of the array to
the
last element okay
less one less than the last element till
the time
I have
placed my sorted last element in the
array so I'll show you that
now in my example I'll print
my
ji iterator and the adjacent element to
it
okay now
what we have to do is we just have to
write now the the condition that if
the element
to which my inner loop is pointing is
greater than the next element then we
will swap
now in Python it's there is a very easy
way to write the swap code
you
are swapping the two adjacent elements
with each other so you just have to
write this line
and now this piece of code will place at
J position the adjacent element of J
plus 1 and at the adjacent element it
will put the previous element
now just to
show you I'll print the array at
unsorted and sorted level so I'll print
the array over here and here so that you
can easily understand how the array has
been
sorted
okay so now you have a one Loop which is
running for the number of times the
length of the array and then the inner
loop which is running from every time
from the first element to the one less
element
length okay
now let me run this
okay
okay so now what we have done is
now I'll explain my example okay
so what we have done is we have 9864
okay now the length of this array is one
two three four so the element the length
will be n will be four
my outer loop will run from 0 to 4 from
4 times 1 2 3 4 and now my inner loop J
Will
run six times and I'll show you how so
now first J at 0 and its adjacent
element is at one so what we are doing
is we are comparing nine with eight
and eight is smaller than 9 9 is greater
than 8 we are swapping it so now this is
my unsorted array and this is my sorted
array so 9 and 8 are swapped you have
eight nine six four
now I move ahead
J is incremented to 1 and the adjacent
element is incremented to two so now I
am comparing nine with six as six is
smaller than 9 I swap it so now my next
set or array is 8694
now I go to J2 and adjacent 3 so 9 and 4
I compare nine and four four is smaller
than 9 I swap it now till this iteration
now 9 has reached its correct position
now I'll go back again and start
my iteration from j0 back again and go
only till this element 4 so again I am
comparing 8 with 6 6 is smaller I swap
then now I'm comparing 8 with 4 4 is
smaller I swap now 8 has reached its
correct position
again now I am going back to zero and I
will only go to the point of 4 I compare
6 and 4 4 is smaller and I get my sorted
list of four six eight nine now if You
observe the number of iterations which
have happened are one two three four
five six it's because 9 has traversed
three times
it has traversed two times and 6s
Travers one time three plus two plus one
six iterations so that's how you get
those iterations
so this was an example of bubble sort
now let's take example of insertion sort
now what is insertion sort let's talk
about that
insertion sort places a given element at
the right position in a sorted list
so in the beginning We compare the first
two elements and sort them by comparing
them
now let me show you
how what I mean by insertion sort
now in insertion sort whatever list you
have the first element is always
considered to be sorted and the rest of
the other elements are assumed to be
unsorted so you start your comparison of
first element with the
with its adjacent element right now just
to simplify things
insertion sort is like it's like playing
cards like you Shuffle the cards and
sort your cards playing cards uh in your
hand it's just like that okay so the
array is virtually split into sorted and
unsorted parts values from the unsorted
parts are picked and placed at the
correct position in the sorted part
so now in our example our sorted part is
8 and unsorted is 4 6 and 9. now in the
second iteration we will compare four
with eight now four is smaller than 8 we
will put it before 8 and now we have
sorted list of 4 and 8 and unsorted list
of 6 and 9.
now in the next iteration we will
compare six with eight
okay and if 6 is smaller than 8 we will
insert it before 8 but and also we will
compare six with four but now 6 is
greater than 4 we will not swap it
now my list is four six eight nine
and four six eight is sorted and 9 is
unsorted now again I'll compare 9 with 8
and it's already greater than 8 I don't
need to swap it and I'll not go any
further and I'll stop it over here so
that's how my sorted list will get
created so my final list is four six
eight nine and I'll we'll see that
within example
so now let's create our insertion sort
logic
so in my example I want to create an
array eight four six nine fifteen twelve
and I want to create a function called
insertion sort
okay
now it's pretty simple you want to
Traverse
through the entire length of the array
but you want to start from element one
not from 0 because 8 is your sorted
element you are already considering it
your sorted element
now
take a variable in which you capture the
outer array and now I'm putting a while
loop with two conditions one is
definitely the one which I explained
that you compare the unsorted element
with this sorted element so the previous
element and you go till the point on the
sorted side till the last element you
don't need to go beyond zero right you
need to only Traverse through the first
element which is the zeroth index
and if you
then you of course
put the
swapping code
you swap
the unsorted
element with the sorted side and
you need to go
so from the right hand side you are
going towards the left hand side of the
array right from right towards left so
that's why you need to decrease the
number okay so what are we doing over
here what we are doing is we are
comparing 4 2 with 8 now if 8 is greater
than 4 you swap
and you only go to the point you have
index 0 okay like now if 4 and 8 will
get swapped now six will come 6 will
compare itself with eight
it is smaller it will swap 6 will
compare itself with four
and it will stop over there so let me
show you I'll put a print command
so that
it is easy to understand
so let me print the array
over here and see
okay so what I've done is I have to
print my array
okay
so this is my original array eight four
six nine fifteen twelve eleven now in
first time I compare 4 with 8 and swap
it
then I compare six with eight it's
smaller I swap it but six and also
compare six with four I don't swap it
then
I compare
9 with 8 it is not small I don't swap it
and I stop it over there
then I compare 12 with 9 it is not small
I stopped it over there then I compare
11 with 12 it is small I swap it right
and then of course 15 I compare with 12
I stop it because it's already bigger so
it is like you divide you always follow
the approach of sorted and unsorted like
I presented and you keep comparing with
the so unsorted a side element with the
sorted side element and keep moving
towards the left hand side
so now let's discuss another sorting
algorithm called merge sort
now merge sort is a divide and conquer
algorithm
so basically in merge sort you first
divide the list into equal parts and
then sort the parts and unite them as a
sorted list so basically you split the
list into halves and then keep
huffing them reducing each half till the
time there is a single element in each
half and then you start merging them
back in a sorted fashion so we will
discuss this with an example over here
now it's for an example we have our list
over here with unsorted numbers 8 4 6
and 9. now as it is even number of items
in this list so they will get
distributed into two equal halves in the
left half you have eight in four and in
the right half you have six and nine
now again recursively you will split
each half the left half and the right
half again till the time you have single
elements so now you see eight and four
now again gets split into individual
element of 8 4 and 6 and 9 into 6 and 9.
now you start merging the individual
elements in a sorted fashion so first
you will compare 8 and 4 now 4 is less
than 8 so you swap and put 4 first and
eight at the second position
similarly when you compare 6 and 9 9 is
greater than 6 then the order of this
particular set remains as is 6 and 9 are
taken into the new array now you have
two merged halves which are in sorted
order four and eight and six and nine
now while merging you compare the left
most elements of each array so first you
will compare four and six
so four and six now six is greater than
4 you place four and six at their
correct positions
now you compare now eight with nine now
eight is the left most item in the array
and nine is the leftmost item in its own
array and both are in the sorted fashion
so that's why you put 8 and 9 at their
relevant position and this is your
sorted output
so definitely we will take a look at the
example with our implementation in
jupyter Notebook
okay so now let me take my list example
which had shown in the presentation
I want to perform a merge sort on this
list okay
okay so I'll create a function
merge sort
and I'll start off with checking
that the list length of my list is
greater than one if it is a single
element then I don't need any sorting
now
I'll find the midpoint of my list
and take
the left part of the array
list and the right part of the list
so the convention which I am using is
actually automatically taking means that
the list starts from 0 till the midpoint
and the list here will start from
midpoint to the length of my list it's
the same convention so you can keep 0 or
not it's up to you
and the length of my list I have the
double slash 2 means that
if the list is of
odd number then it will divide by two
and round it up to the nearest integer
so you will not get the decimal output
so we will get a integer rounded mid
value
now after I have done this I will
recursively call the left array
and the right array
in my into this merge sort so using this
I'll be able to get the split value of
8469 and I'll you this with this
recursions I will reach to the point
where I'll get individual elements of 8
4 6 and 9.
now
I have two iterate through the left
array and the right array so I'll create
two variables which will help me iterate
through left and right
array
and I am also initializing a variable
which I'll keep as a counter
for populating a new array which will
comprise of my merged
okay
so now
this is the logic I will loop from left
element
from 0
to index to the length of the left array
and zeroth index to the length of the
right array and I'll compare
if the left is less than equal to
the right it means I already have my
value in the sorted order I'll just add
it to my merged array and put it at the
kth position
and
increment my left array
further
else
else I have to pick up the right array
element so if the left array is smaller
and greater then right array then I put
it the left one in the merged list or if
the right one is smaller than the left
one then I merged put it in the merge
list and increment my
right list
now while after this conditions are done
I increment my
merged list incrementer okay I move
ahead
now there could be a possibility that
there might be some elements which might
remain
uncompared in the left list like for
example if this would have been an odd
number of uh elements then here would
have been three and two then one element
will remain uncompared so then I need to
iterate through the remaining left array
and just put them in my merge list
I and K by one
and same could be the possibility of the
right array that there might be some
Elements which might remain uncompared
or you know unsorted in the right array
so I'll put them back in my
merge list
so my list is my
list which I am
updating constantly
so now let me put some
prints when I'll run this
code I want to put some print out so
that I can explain
where my
list is now this is my merge sort and
I'm gonna run this
okay so now what I have done we had a
list of eight four nine six so in the
first recursion display the list got
split into eight and four and nine and
six
okay
now
okay sorry let me just make it similar
eight four and six nine
then in the second recursion I have
eight as a single element 4 as a signal
element and in the third recursion I
have six as in single element and nine
as a single element
now after that
my this logic gets executed where I
compare left and right elements and
emerge them okay so now I compare four
with eight and four is less than eight I
swap it move four to the left my common
array and then eight then ins in this
case six and nine they're already in the
sorted fashion I just move it into my
common list my list and again now four
eight and six and nine are compared
the leftmost element is 4 compared with
six it's shorter smaller it is put it in
the common list eight and nine eight and
nine are smaller it is put it in the
common list and you have the sorted
array
so this is the idea behind a merge sort
where you have divided the list to the
nth element to the zeroth element and
then you start merging it back by
comparing the leftmost elements now
let's take an example of another sorting
algorithm called quick sort
quick sort like merge sort is also a
divide and conquer algorithm but in a
different way
in quick sort first you choose a pivot
element in the array then store elements
less than the pivot in the left sub
array and greater than the pivot in the
right sub array and then keep doing this
activity recursively for each subsequent
left and right array which you have done
after that
we will call quick sort on the left sub
array and similarly we will call quick
sort on the right sub array so it's a
recursive algorithm based on the choice
of the pivot element which you have
taken on the array generally the pivot
element is generally taken as the right
most element of the array
now let me try to explain quick sort
with an example over here and then we
will look into the python code
now I have an array with six elements
where my last element is my pivot
so now what I have to do is I have to
create a left array where all the
elements smaller than 34 should get
aligned and then I have to create a
right array which should be having
elements greater than 34
so in order to achieve that that is the
whole algorithm which you have to write
now I have taken two pointers the orange
colors and
the one on the left hand side and one on
the right hand side this is I and this
is J
now what is the job of eye pointer the
job of eye pointer is to find the
elements which are less than 34 and the
J pointer is to find the elements which
are greater than 34 okay so I will keep
on shifting towards the right until
unless it finds an element greater than
34 and in case of J element it will
shift towards the left until unless it
finds an element
less than 34. okay so we will see that
now I
will start its Journey from the zeroth
element always and J will start its
Journey from the one element less than
the pivot always okay
now in this example I is already
pointing to a
element which is greater than 34
but J is pointing to an element which is
greater than 34 but it should move
towards the element which is less than
34 so now I will remain static and J
will move one element further which is
17 and it will check whether J is
less than 34 or not
if not then it will stop over here
correct and I
is less than a pivot or not if not then
it will also stop over here okay so J
will check if it is greater than 34 or
not and I will check if it is greater
than 34 or not
now in this scenario 40 and 17 now are
meeting the condition that whether 40 is
greater than 34 and 17 is less than 34
we will make a swap of these elements so
17 will interchange with 40 and 40 will
interchangeable 17 and then now I and J
will continue their journey ahead
what will happen now I moves to 21 J is
at 40.
okay now 21 is less than 34 I will
continue further it will come to 8.
okay
8 is also less than 34 I has now moved
to 40 right now 40 is not less than 34 I
will stop over here
now J what happened with j j is greater
than 34 it will move further now J has
reached 8 and I has reached 40. now at
this point when J has crossed I then now
it is the point when you need to swap
the pivots you need to change the pivot
so at this point when J has crossed When
J is greater than I you need to swap the
pivots so in this case what will happen
is 40 will get swapped with 34 and 34
will come in place of 40 and 40 will go
to the end now with this whole exercise
what has happened now 34 has found its
correct position in this entire array
and if you monitor the all the elements
on the left hand side of 34 are smaller
234 and all the elements on the right
hand side are greater than 34.
and this is what we wanted to achieve
now the same logic will get applied to
left array and right array
in left array now 8 will be assumed as
the pivot and in the right array 40 will
be taken as the pivot
now and applying the same logic now 8 is
taken as the pivot 17 and 21 I and J are
pointing now as there are only two
elements 21 is greater than 8 17 is also
greater than 8 so then automatically 21
will move ahead J will move ahead and I
will move ahead and then 21 and 17 will
swap each other so the final will become
8 17 21 here we only have one element of
okay 51 and 40 will swap amongst
themselves as pivot and they will align
themselves
so I know it's a little confusing and uh
complicated algorithm but I'll try to
explain this with my
example
now what I have to do is I have to
create my data
and I am
creating a quick sort
algorithm
now in order to start the quick sort I
need to send the zeroth index and the
length of the array minus 1
and of course if the
length of left is great less than right
means there is some data then only I'll
continue
now secondly what I have to do is I have
to find the index of the pivot element
and pass it recursively to the quick
sort
so now we will create another function
which is called Partition which
will encapsulate the entire logic
so I'll create my left pointer I which I
was explaining the right pointer J which
is one less than the right most element
which is my Pivot
and I'll capture my
pivot which is the rightmost element in
our example 34
and then
I'll run a while loop
for the duration when I while I is less
than J right when I J becomes greater
than less than I means when they cross
the path then we will swap the pivot
now first
I will iterate move my
left iterator I
to the right hand side right when it is
less than the right and I'll check my
element on the ith index is less than
the pivot because this is my left sub
array
and
then I'll increment
similarly
I will move my ji Trader
from right to left compare that the
element at the J pointer is greater than
the pivot so because I have to create my
right sub array
okay
now I am checking
if my I index is less than J
correct
then I'll
swap the elements
and let me print the array over here
now outside the while loop
I'll check my
arith array I index is greater than the
pivot
yes
then I'll I am now changing my Pivot
basically pivot value I am swapping the
pivot value and I'll print it here for
you
and I'll return
d i this is the index of the pivot
let me
indented correctly
and print it
okay let's see what has happened
now this is my original array where the
pivot
is starting from 34
now
as I told my I did not move the head
because I is checking if my element of I
is less than pivot 40 is greater 40 so I
has not moved but J moved J moved from
started from 51 till 71 till 17 and it
stopped over here
and at this point 17 and 40 got swapped
17 com came over here and 40 came over
here now Hereafter I started moving
forward I 21 is less than 34 okay 8 is
less than 34 okay 40 is less than 34 no
so I stopped over here
my J was at 40 it moved further 8 8 is
greater than 34 no so I and J have
crossed each other now this is the point
where we have to make a swap between 40
and 34.
okay so 40 will move to the end and 34
will come in middle so now 34 has
reached its desired and actual position
and all elements left of 34 are smaller
than it and right of 34 are greater than
it
now
I am working on my left sub array where
8 is my Pivot
now I will start
from here
j i
so 17 it is greater than 8 it will not
move ahead 21 it is greater than a 8 it
moved ahead J and it reached 17. now 17
and 21 now J has crossed I they will
swap each other okay
and now my array position is 8 21 17 34
51 40. now my Pivot changes to 17 17
will be compared to 21 and this is the
swap happening over here
now coming to the right sub array my
Pivot is 40 only single element is there
40 and 51 the swap will happen over here
so as you understand
quick sort
you will better understand when you run
it with multiple examples if you are
looking to be one of them then yes you
are at the right place introducing you
with Celtic postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning let's take a quick
walk through with this amazing program
some key features of Caltech
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning include pgp and AIML completion
certificate from Caltech ctme master
class is delivered by distinguished
Caltech faculty and IBM experts caltex
ctm is circle membership earn up to 22
CEUs from Caltech ctme and more few
skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
now we will start a project that is
track phone number location using python
so for that
first we'll create a folder for our
project you could also create a virtual
environment but
um I'm not going to do that you guys can
create if you want to just keep your
project aside from all other projects
and don't want your modules to get
conflicted with any other module
so I will name a test track
and inside this I will open the command
prompt
and I will use the ID that is Visual
Studio code for that I am writing the
command code space period and press
enter in the command prompt
so it will open my ID
Visual Studio code
and here I will create a new file and
name it as
new DOT py
and before starting with the project the
first thing we should do is install and
import libraries that we need for our
project
so we'll start with installing and
importing the libraries
so we will import
the first library that would be phone
numbers
I will show you you can just simply
write pypi that would be the PIP
installation command for
the particular Library you can just
search pypi and the name of the library
you want to install in any browser
you will get these kind of web pages and
inside you could see the command to
install that and here you can find
some of the descriptions and their
download files release history and home
pages
so we'll just copy the command move back
to our Command Prompt or you could use
the terminal of your ID
you could use any to install your
modules
so I'm using command prompt and I have
copied my command as you can see it
states that the requirement is already
satisfied that means that on this system
I have this module already installed so
I don't need to install it again
and portfolio we'll just copy it
and move back to our Command Prompt and
paste the command
and click enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as I've already
installed these modules so I don't need
to install them again and there's
another that is open cage so we'll use
it to
point out the location on the map
so for that also you could just copy the
command get back to a command prompt or
your terminal of your ID and press enter
and it will get to modules installed it
states that the requirement is already
satisfied as I've already cleared that I
have already installed these modules
so moving back to our ID
we'll start with importing our libraries
so we'll import the necessary libraries
that is phone numbers that is used to
pass phone numbers geocoder
uh will call the class from the phone
numbers that is geocoder which is used
to determine the location of a phone
number and will use volume which is used
to create Maps it will also assign a
value to a variable key
so we'll start with importing
and first we will Import phone numbers
okay
moving on
now we will import geocoder from phone
numbers class
okay
now we'll also import volume we'll use
it
later on but yeah and we will also
create a file
uh for our phone number
so that we can just import the phone
number from that file and I won't be
showing you the phone number so you guys
won't be like spamming or misusing it I
know you won't miss use but yeah I will
not mention it
so for that
I will
take the file name as test.py and here
we'll just create a variable
and name it as number and inside
just write the phone number
okay
and get back to a file that is new node
py we have imported the libraries now
we'll create second file for phone
number that we have created now we'll
start with creating a variable and we'll
name it as check number and use the
phone numbers library and the pass
function parser phone number
so to do that first we'll create a
variable and name it as check number
and we'll use the pass function of
phone numbers Library
and inside will pass the number that we
have stored
into
the other file but to access that
variable
from the other file we need to import
that file so from test
that is test.pi that is in the same
folder we will import the variable
number
okay
we have imported it
now okay
just written number now it's number
okay
moving on now we'll use the geocoder
class and use the description for number
I will show you guys
what I am going to use
that is we'll use the jio code
geocoder.description phone number
function to determine the location of
the phone number and that to in English
language
so for that we'll create a variable and
name it as number location okay
number underscore
location
and inside this we'll use the geocoder
class
and what function values description
phone number
you could see this is the second
function
so we are using this and inside this
what will pass we'll pass the variable
check number in which we have passed the
phone number
so we will pass this check number
and
we will ask it to provide the result in
English language for that we have used
en
okay
and after that what we need we need the
number location that is stored in the
variable we want to print it
so we'll just simply print it that would
be number
underscore
location
okay that is then
and now
if you just
run this
you will get the output as location that
is India and the most important thing
these libraries will tell you the
countries note the particular States
like it will these libraries try to
depict the particular state but they are
not such particular they will give you
the countries in which these phone
numbers are situated
okay
where these phone numbers are active
so we have done with the location
now we also want to extract the career
not career but the carrier that the
mobile service provider that is if in
India we talk about we have mobile
service providers that is jio ATL
Vodafone idea BSNL and if we go out so
we have nine mobiles and others so we
want those service providers okay yes
that is mobile careers
so for that
now we'll
use the phone numbers libraries again
and for that we will import the career
class
so for that all right from
phone numbers
import
area
okay sorry
now we have imported the career class
now we'll use a function that would be
career dot name for number function that
is in the career module that we have
imported from phone numbers
so for that first we'll create a
variable and name it as
service provider
okay and inside this variable what we'll
use is we'll use the phone number dot
parse first we have done that
in the check number variable also
so you could use the check number
variable or we could just simply pass
the phone number again here so for that
we'll just write phone numbers library
and use the pass function
and that is inside will pass the number
in which we have stored our number
okay
we have passed it
and now
now
we'll use the
career dot name for number function and
for that they will directly print it out
or you could store in a variable that's
your choice
we will directly print it that would be
career
Dot
and you could find the functional name
for wallet number no
that is name fundament that is the first
one and inside will pass the pass number
that we have stored in a variable
service provider or you could use the
check number
so we'll just pass service provider
and
will pass anything that would
we need
the
credit provider name in English
so we have passed en okay so this code
has used career total name for number
function that is used to DET minus
service provider of the phone number
that is in English
we have done that so we'll just save the
file
and run it
so you could see that states Tata docomo
I will run it again for you guys
now it has printed both things that is
the number location that is India and
the service provider that is started
docomo and what this Library does is if
you get your number ported it won't show
the current service provider it shows
when you have just
get your Sim the first time the first
service order it will show you that that
is
okay now moving on we will use the maps
to point out the location
so for that we'll use the open cache
module as we have already installed that
so we'll import geocoder or open cache
jio code from
module
so I will show you what will import that
is from
open cage dot geocoder module
will import openk jio code glass yeah
the first one open gain Geo code
okay
now
what we need is the key of open cage so
I will show you guys
will open the open cage
and you guys have two
login into that I have already login
so this is
the dashboard and we'll go to geocoding
API
and we'll use the Freeman free trial and
one-time plan customers can have only
one active API key at a time okay we'll
use this only
and I will just like I won't show you
guys
so I will just blur it out
so we'll paste the key here
and coming back
so here we'll use the key so for that
we'll create a variable first
and name it as geocoder only
so geocoder and use the open KGO code
and inside will pass the key
but we have stored in a variable key
and now
you want the number location in a string
so we'll store it in a variable
for that we will just write query equal
to string and inside will
store the parse number as a string so
we'll pass the variable in which we have
passed the phone number that is number
location
and now we'll use the
geocoder.geocode function and pass the
query into it
so for that we'll create a function a
variable and name it as the results
and we'll use the geocoder
and use the geocode function and inside
would pass the query that is the
variable in which we have stored the
pass number that is as a string and now
what we want is latitude and longitude
of the location
so for that we'll create a variable and
name it as latitude
and
from the results variable
we will just
okay let it equal to from the results
variable we'll just take the
zeroth index
and
we will
take geometry
and the latitude
and for longitude I will do the same
that is in this code what we are doing
is we are importing the open kgeocode
class from the opencase.geocoder module
which is used to get the latitude and
longitude coordinates of the location of
the phone number
like it then initializes an instance of
the class with the API key that we have
stored in the variable key and then the
code creates a query variable but we
have created that is with the value of
number location and we'll use the
geocoder.geocode method to get the
latitude and longitude coordinates of
the location of the phone number that we
are doing now so these coordinates are
then stored in the variable that is lat
that is we will store latitude in that
and we'll store the longitude in the LNG
variable and finally that latitude and
longitude longitude coordinates we will
print them in the console okay
so
now we will just get the longitude
so for that we'll use
results
and inside we'll use geometry
and the longitude
okay
so now we'll just print the latitude and
longitude
okay we will save this and
run this
so you could see the first thing it has
printed is the current location that is
India then the service provider and then
the latitude and longitude you could
just copy these latitude and longitude
and paste on a map or you could just
search on a uh any browser it will show
you the coordinates on a particular map
where these are and to get the pointer
on a map we will use the folio module
so
I will show you guys how we'll do so
we'll use the volume dot map function
that is the map function from the folio
module and we'll pass the latitude and
longitude coordinates that we have
stored in the variables latitude and
longitude and then the volume dot marker
function will use the marker function
from the folio module class volume
module and it will show the marker on
the map so
to do that I will show you guys I will
do we have imported the volume module
and first we'll create a
variable
and will store the file in an
in an HTML format so you could just open
in any browser and you could see the map
so in this variable we'll use the map
function
so volume
that is equal to volume dot map and
inside
use location and that is equal to
latitude
Uma
longitude and
what we need to set Zoom
so we can set Zoom start
and we'll set it as 9. you could set as
you want
okay
so we have set it as 9 and now we'll use
the
marker function so
put that
we'll just use the marker function
dot marker
and inside will pass the latitude and
longitude
okay
and we will just pop up the number
location for that will set
pop-up
and that would be equal to
the past number
okay and we'll use the add to function
that is
not add to and inside this will pass the
variable map location in which we have
stored the
so we'll pass map location okay we have
passed this and we want to save this map
location in an HTML format
so we'll use map location
dot save
and we'll name the file as
my location
what HTML okay
so I'll save the file in an HTML format
so you guys would just open that and use
it so we have run the
program and you could see it has said
that India Tata docomo and the letter U
and longitude and you could see in the
same folder that we have the my
location.html file
so we'll get back and you could see my
location we'll just
open it and you could see that it has
pointed out into the map that is the
phone number belongs to the India
and we'll get
check it out
now we'll change the phone number and
test this
for a different phone number so put that
I will write
obviously I won't be showing the phone
number
what in the phone
yeah
you have saved it and in the new DOT
pure file we will run it
for this
phone number and see
Nevada
and the latest and it has not provide
the service provider
okay
we'll run it again
look it won't be able to
find out the service provider and the
location for this phone number has been
saved in the dot HTML file so we'll just
open it
and
check okay yeah the pointer is located
near Nevada
so our project is working fine and if
you want
not to store the phone number and like
the other file
you could just do it you would just get
the phone numbers entered in the
console
so for that you just guys have to write
a small line for enter
entering the phone number so first we'll
do is I will show you guys how to do
that just get this
so we have commented the module that is
the test module and now to get the phone
number input
from the user will use the same variable
number in which we have stored the phone
number earlier and we'll use
and put and here we will write
enter
phone number
with
country code
okay
with the country code you guys have to
enter it
and if I run it
so here
I will enter
and I will get this also blurred so it
will take a little
time for editing also you guys can see
India Tara docomo latitude and longitude
and
the file has been updated that is the my
location.html
and if I open this you could see that it
has pointed in India and
first we'll see WhatsApp project and how
it looks like
so
we will save it and run the program
you can see that the Tinker window has
appeared
and this is our project and this is what
we're gonna make in this video so using
twilio I have received the OTP on my
mobile phone and that is 4601
foreign
I can see the show info window that says
that the verification is successful
and we have one more window for you guys
if you want
you can also make it uh we will also
discuss this in this video
so you can see this is the first window
we will create and after we click on the
generate OTP button
it will redirect to the second window
that is verify OTP and there you could
just type in the OTP you get on your
mobile phone and the OTP I code is 6709
and I will just click on the submit
button it will show that the
verification is successful
there's a recent OTP button and there's
a timer as the twilio tokens they are
default available for 10 minutes only so
I have set up a timer for 10 minutes if
you want you can also make the timer
else you could just go with the verify
OTP GUI and the design button it will
just make that video send the OTP again
to a mobile phone so if there is any
difficulty in reaching the RDP to us so
moving on now
we will start with our project
that is first we will create a folder
and name it as OTP verification
and inside
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open the editor I will be
using the visual studio code you could
choose any editor as you like or you
have the hands on any editor
so for that I will write the command
code space period and press enter
so here we will
create the name of the file as program 2
Dot py
and now we should install and import the
modules
for T can term we don't have to install
it like click enter is a python module
that is used to develop GUI that is
graphical user interface there's no need
to install any module as decanter module
is a part of the standard python Library
and here we need to install twilio
so for that
we will open the command prompt and
write the command
okay install
your and press enter
as it states that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the twilio module and used it
in the project so you just have to write
the command and press enter in the
command prompt or in the terminal of
your editor
and the rest would be done for you
so moving on
we will
import the modules
so from click enter
we will import all the classes and files
and from two video
foreign
class
and to generate the OTP we will use the
random module and generate the
OTP with the random function
random
and we would also be using the message
box but here we will see it later on
so now we'll create a class
in the taken term
so in order to initialize the class we
use the unders Quantum score init
function this creates a method that
prints itself when we form an object
from the class
so we will make a class
and name it as OTP wire verifier
OTP underscore verified
and inside you will pass TK
colon
and as I said we will
make the
image
and pass self in it
so we will create a root window and
display it on the screen for that we
will just run window dot main Loop to
pop out The Tick into window
and for that
and the slope we will just
write
to support
tick enter provides many methods and one
of them is the geometry method this
method is used to set the dimensions of
vetting enter window and it's used to
set the positions of the main window on
the user's textbook
so for that we will use the geometry
function
and write the command itself
documentary
and inside the cutting places uh scoring
Circle bases
we'll set the y-axis
as thousand of course x axis with 580
and
mute
to make it shift with
200 dimensions then y-axis
and 80 dimensions in the x-axis
now we will configure the window so we
will use the config function so config
and configure function they both are
same and they can be used on any widget
to change settings that you may have
applied earlier or haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command self
dot configure
and inside we will set the background
color as white only for the tender
window
and use the hexa code for the colors
you could use for example or just write
white
so what might be
have
6 amps you can search for the port the
Excel code
or you could just write the white color
now we will use the resizable function
so this method is used to allow decline
term root window to change its size
according to the user's name as well as
we can prove the resizing of the tender
window so basically if you want to
create a fixed size window this method
can be used in resizable method user can
pass either positive integer or true to
make the window resizable
but if you want to prohibit the resizing
of the window you could just pass false
or zero
so we would just private it
we will write the command
self Dot peace size table
foreign
and now
before executing code python interpreter
reads source file and Define few special
variables to Global variables if the
python interpreter is running the source
file as the main program it sets the
special variable that would be the
underscore underscore
name variable
as value equal to Main
that value
would be equal to underscore underscore
Main
if this file is being imported from
another module so the name variable will
be set to the module's name modules name
is available as value to name variable
that is the global variable
so to execute it
will write the command
if
name equal to Main and that
would be in line but it commas
here first we will
the class
window equal to
vertically underscore
verifier
and now
write a command click on the menu
that is the main thing to get a window
popped up so we'll save the file
and run it
we go to Arrow here
so it is due to the spaces
I don't
have to Make spaces in the geometry
method
and now we'll save it and run it you can
see that the peak enter window has
popped up
now
we will make its GUI and before that
we will see that video so this is the
twilio console you have to login into
that and that would be your account Sid
your token and the phone number from
which you will get the OTP
so I will show you the demo for that
you can just visit that value
website
soot value is an American company that
is based in the San Francisco
which provides programmable
communication tools for making and
receiving phone calls sending and
receiving text messages and Performing
other communication functions using it
web service apis
so this is the website here you can just
go
sign up
have the account already I will just log
in in it you will just write the first
name last name email and password that
should be 16 plus characters and after
that you will accept it and start a free
trial it doesn't need any credit card or
something you can just use it without
any payment mode
and after that it will ask you to get
your phone number assigned or it will
ask first it will ask you like what
purpose are you serving the 12 year
so you could just make it that you want
to run it for your project or any code
purpose and after that you have to
generate the phone number from which you
will get the SMS
so I have my console already
I have logged in
so going to the code part
now we'll use twilio
to get our OTP
mobile phones
so
for that we will write the command
in the class only that is odbi file
we will use the current function for
that we will create a variable
self port client
and that is equal to
and use the client function
and inside
will pass two parameters
that would be from the console
that would be the account Sid we will
copy that
and
we'll paste it in the inverted commas
and the next parameter will pass
the price token that would be unique for
you
paste this
and that could also bend the inverted
commas only
and next
we'll write the command serve.client dot
messages
that is we'll use the variable
above there was a client variable
and we'll create the messages
and here we will write our phone number
that
here two and equal to
and inside
the brackets we will write the contact
number
you want to receive the message
so here I am writing my contact number
and
not
highlighted
as it
as I can get the Spam messages or
samples so I would not highlight it
and
we will
write the contact number that we have
got from that value
and that contact number is material your
phone number we will copy that
and right wrong
underscore
paste that with your phone number
comma and then the body what body we
want to receive as a text message from
this number so the body we want to
receive an OTP
so for that we will use the random
module and generate an OTP
so first we will create a variable
store it in a variable n
for that we should use the random module
to generate the OTP for that we will
just
make a function and name it as OTP only
and inside you will pass self
and this function we will return
double TP and that will generate with
the ranked range function
and pass the range
so this function will choose any number
from this range and return to us
so we will ask this function to generate
a phone number OTP
so we have
made the function
for the OTP and now we'll assign it
to the variable we have declared above
so in this variable we will be pointed
the OTP should be passed as a string
because body would take as number as a
string only
so that will write the command Str
UCT
OTP
in the body you will get the variable
and only
but that will write the commandself.in
now
we will
save it
and run it
yeah
it is an issue here
element
or successfully executed so sometimes
it takes time to talk back to whenever
okay
and now we will start with the GI GUI
and for that
will create a function so that we can
store all the widgets there
and we will name the function as labels
and first thing we will create would be
the canvas Widget the Cano switch it
lets us display various graphics on the
application it can be used to throw
simple shapes to complicated graphs we
can also display various kinds of custom
widgets according to our needs so first
we will
create a variable
and name it as C
and inside
we will make the canvas widget
then now set its background color
and that
I will use the hexa code only if you
could just
see
that's the green color
you could use
the hexa port or you can just write the
name of the column
or if you want you can just search on
the web you would get the hexa boards
and you would get the variations of all
the colors in hexa board and I will set
the width for the canvas and width would
be equal to 400 as you can see that it
is in the comments
we have to put the hex support in the
inverted commas
yeah
so website the width and now we will set
the height
that is
waiting
and now
we will place this canvas for that we
will use the Place function and the
place function allows you explicitly set
the position inside of a window either
in absolute terms or relative to another
window
so for that we'll write the command set
dot C dot place
and the X Dimension will be equal to 219
and Y Dimension will be equal to 120.
and now
we'll just save this
and run the file
so we have to call the
labels function also
let's save it and run it again
you could see that this is the canvas
the gray canvas
and moving on now we will create a frame
and that would also be in the labels
function so frame is a rectangular
region on the screen and that can also
be used as a foundation class to
implement complex widgets it is used to
organize a group of widgets
so we will create a upper frame and
inside that we will place
a small image with OTP verification and
the heading
that would be to verify the OTP
so for that first we will create a
variable and we will name it as upper
underscore frame
and inside we will create a frame
and
office capital
for the same widget
and inside we will pass self
and set the background color
equal to Blue and that will do the W and
I will use the hexa code for that hexa
code is 4 6
yeah this is the color you can see here
and now we'll set its width and before
that we will
get this into the inverted commas and I
will set the width
width would be equal to 1500
and now we'll set its height
should be equal to 130
and now we will place it so where should
we in the peak enter window for that
we'll use the place function
write the command self Dot
or underscore frame
Dot place
yeah
so we will
place it at x equal to zero and y equal
to 0 only
so I'll save the file and run it for you
so you can see the output side by side
yeah you can see that this is the frame
and we have set the color as blue and it
we have placed it as x equal to 0 and y
equal to 0. we have created the canvas
so now moving on
we'll use the labels
and in the labels only first we will
place the image in the frame
for that uh
first I will choose the image as I've
already made the project I have chose
the images
and I have pasted it in the folder
that is picks
and
it is
paste it in our
project folder
so first I would be using the password
one image
and I will set it in the frame only
and in take and turn like some widgets
can display an image such as label and
button and we would be using label to
display this image and for buttons also
I have created the images as you have
seen in the folder
so I will show you how to use these
images and show them as a button so
these widgets take an image argument
that allows them to display an image
so for that we will create a variable
and name it is picture
and the widget is photo image
and inside you have to pass the location
of the file where the image is stored
so we have just placed it in the same
folder so we'll just write the name of
the image and that was
password
one
there was no spaces and that was the PNG
file
yeah
after creating a photo image object you
can use it
you can use it with other widgets that
accept an eatman's argument
the image object is returned by the
photo image function that we have used
and it's that easy to display a picture
in Python however the photo image class
only supports the GIF and PGM PPM
formats which is a concern
jpeg jpg and PNG are the formats that
are most often used
so now
we will
place the image in the frame
for that
first create a label for that and
we will create a variable and limit as k
and create a label widget
antique inter label is a widget that is
used to implement display boxes where
you can place text or images so here we
would be first placing the image and
then the text
so inside the label widget
and we'll pass the argument that was the
variable for the upper frame and then
the image object
that is
picture
and set the background
as the same as of the frame for that we
will write BG
equal to and the hex are good that is
same that is four six eight two B four
and now we will place it
so write the command here only that is
Dot
place
and X
would be equal to 200
um
and y equal to 35.
and
save this and run the file
you can see that the image has been
placed here
so now we will write verify
OTP and we will also create the labels
for that
Professor building
now inside the label function only
we will create another label
for the text and first we will create a
variable and name it as J
and inside we will create a label widget
and
inside the upper frame
write a text
that could be verify OTP
set the font for it
that would be thanks to Roman
you could also set the size as 38 and
make them bold
and now we'll set the background color
for that
foreign
[Music]
color that would be the text color as
white and here we will notice the
hexagon I would write the name of the
color
for that for Credit One for ground color
that is equal to White
and now we replace this label
please add
around to 70.
and Y would be same
and that would be 35 only
now I'll save this and run the file
we have get the label verify ODB but
they both are insideing so we will just
change the coordinates
for this label
and we'll set as
300.
we'll save the file
close the
previous decanter window
save the file and run it
so I just got home so you can see that
it has shown the verify OTP but still
it's not in the center so we will just
again change the x coordinate for that
and that would be 400
and save the file
and run it
could see that
now it is in the center
to place it accordingly like I would be
creating a GUI and if you want
Perfection you can do that by one
and now moving on we will place a simply
learn image
just on the file and show you like where
we
will place a simple line image
place and just write them bottom right
so for that we will create the label
again and first we'll use the photo
image to create the photo object go to
image object and first we'll create the
variable
and name it is simply
underscore logo
and inside we'll use the photo image
and write the name of the file else you
have to write the location of the file
as we have the files in the folder only
and we have the simply learn file with
the name simply learn
space logo
so just use the file name
should check that change this okay
yeah
that's it
so write the name of the file
space
below
and the extension of the file is PNG
and now we'll create a label for the
photo image object
for that we will create another variable
and name it as e
use the label widget
signal pass self and
image equal to
self Dot
simply done
this
logo
and we'll set the coupon color
equal to White so that will use the hexa
code for white color
and now we'll paste this label
at x equal to
870 that would be the bottom right
and why
you could write 13.
it's showing an arrow
and we have used the image name here we
have to use the variable
there is
underscore logo
so now
let's see this
close to previous
click into window
and run the file
that is
Thunder from spelling
for payment file
now we'll run into load and save it
save it and then run it
takes time to open up
foreign
logo has been placed at the bottom right
now moving on okay I will
show you what we will execute next
so we will place an
text widget here in which we can just
enter the OTP and after that we will
make the buttons verify OTP and the
recent ODB first we'll make the text in
which we will write our degree
so for that
we won't make it in the labels function
so that we will create another function
and if it is entry
we will enter the video
and we will
make a variable that would be username
and use the text widget so text widget
is used that a user wants to insert
multi-line text Fields this widget can
be used for a variety of applications
where the multi-line text is required
such as messaging sending information or
displaying information and many other
tasks we can insert media files such as
images and links also in the text widget
and for that
for to enter the OTP we will create the
next widget and
we will write text
inside
our self
and now we'll set the font size in which
you would enter the ODB and it would set
it as calibery
and the size to the font would be 20.
and now
let's set the Border width
for the text
so it should have a border width so we
could see on that canvas
and we will use wrap
so if
the word
put that text it exceeds the width of
the text widget it will just wrap it and
send it to the next line
and
what
set the width
equal to
and height
equal to 1
and now we will place it
and we'll paste it in the canvas that
was of the gray color so that will write
the command
self dot the variable name user
underscore
name
and we'll place it
x equal to 330.
and y equal to 200.
save the file and run it and see whether
a text wizard has been created
successfully or not and before that we
have to run this function
Mouse entry
save this and on the file
that you can download oh it's all right
now it's not
Android
okay import an error
okay and we are not
the font
equal to calibri we will save this and
run again
yeah it has appeared so this is the text
widget in which we will write our OTP
and verify it now we'll make the submit
button and the recent rotate button and
write the functionalities for it
so the pattern widget is used to add
various types of buttons to the python
application python allows us to
configure the look of the button
according to our requirements and for
that we'll create a function
buttons and we'll write all the buttons
here that would be two buttons only
that is submit and check node
and first we will create a variable for
the submit button image
it will create the submit button first
we'll create a variable
and name it as submit button
and first we will
assign the image to that button
we already have this submit image in our
folder
we will use this image
called the photo image
sorry
so I'll call the photo image
and inside we will pass the file
address and
I use submit.pn
and now
the foot image object has been created
so we'll create the submit button
will create a variable
as the name of submit button only
and
to make a button we'll use the button
widget and inside we'll just pause
yourself and then the image that should
be appeared and that would be equal to
the variable name that is submit button
image
okay and now we'll set the command so
command is used to call the function
so what function does this button do
that would be stored in the command
and that would be equal to we will name
the function as check OTP as submit
return mode check the OTP only
we will create this function after this
pattern only
and now
we will set the Border
then
we won't make the work we will set it as
0 here
now let's place the submit button
for that we will write the command
itself to it submit button
place and
X would be equal to 440 and by equal to
and now we will start with the resend
button
resend OTP button
and after that we will create the
checkout DB function
so for the recent OTP button first we
will create the photo image object
that we will write a variable
is end
that P
and enter this into image
and pass the file name
only
PNG
now we'll create the button
for that we'll write the command cell
don't descend
OTP variable
and
button widget
and inside pass self and then the image
that would be set as the button image
that would be equal to the variable name
of the
photo image object
that is
OTP image
okay oh yeah
by shooting at us
so I'm going to be image but
okay
Mr coma
now we will set the command and that
would be the function
that will store the functionalities that
this button will do
and name the function as
we send OTP only
and call that would also use servers
pass itself there
and that would be applicable to check
out if you also
and now let's set the coder
equal to zero
for the reason OTP
image and now we will paste it
and we'll place it at 420 comma 430.
so that would write the command
itself Dot
resend
OTP
indoor place
and set x equal to 420
and Y
foreign
and run it
so it's saying that the check OTP
that's what I attribute here
so first we'll create those functions
only check OTP and the recent OTP
so first we will create the resend OTP
function
so find it
and inside
we will paste the same as we just write
the commands to get the OTP
these are the commands
that it pasted
so this is the resend OTP function now
we'll create the checkout DB function
for that
will write
function name that is check OTB
and password to that
and inside
then use prey
so if any exception occurs we would get
it easily solved
and here
we will create the variable with any
user input
get it stored in integer value
so it will convert the text Network
string which have passed as the body so
it will
take the text and convert it into
integer
send input
take that value from the user underscore
name
you would be writing the OTP there only
yeah
now we will write some conditions to
check if the OTP is correct so we will
get the message box popped out
and put that we'll write the command if
serve to user input
is equal to equal to
integer value of self.n
then we will make the message booked out
is import the message box
class also
as we have already imported all the
classes from the decanter but again we
will import it
and if this condition goes to
we want a message box
to show info
and inside we have to paths the shown
for
and
we will make it as verification
successful
so you could write anything like the OTP
is verified
write verification successful
and
now if
itself
Dot and
so the OTP would be done there
else
would also pop out the message box and
for that we'll write the command message
box
to join form
and inside we will pass the variables
show info and
we will get the indication as strong OTP
now
we will make the exception here as we
have used third right Loop you have to
use the accept block also and here also
we will use the message sorry
for
inside will pass show off
yeah
that's good
tell us invalid OTP
and here we will import a message box
class
so that we will write the command
from take into import message scopes
so as you can see that we have created
both the functions that is check OTP and
recent OTP
now
I will save the file
and run it
is
thank you
okay
now we'll save the file and run it
as you can see that the decanter window
has popped up and I have received the
OTP on my mobile phone that is 1856
and I will click on the submit button
so it's showing from OTP
yeah we will resend it
and put the new dps2851
click on the submit button it says that
the verification is successful so we
have made the verification OTP
GUI successfully and you could add that
timer also in it
for that I will just copy paste the code
for the timer
uh I will also provide the source file
in the description if you want you can
see there
fore if you want to know how the timer
is made
you could just see another video in the
description or on the I button
just
copy paste the code
so this is the runtime of function
so you can see that the timer has
started and it's for the 10 minutes as
to Elio default tokens are valid only
for 10 minutes
and received another OTP we will resend
it again
and it's 7848
and click on the submit button it says
that the verification is successful and
if you want to make the first page
you can see the source code
I will make it available for you guys
I will make
foreign
class and imported the program 2 module
and we have installed the module sub
processes and we are calling the import
class
and here we have made the class generate
OTP
and inside we have set the geometry and
configured the color as white for the
first window and we have made it
that the window could not be resizable
that's why we have passed
the folds and false arguments to the
resizable
function
and here we have created the labels
as you would see in the
first window and the button generate OTB
so we will save the file
and run it
first we'll pause this
now we'll save it
and run the file
foreign
logo
so the file name is
I will replace that
save it and run it again see the first
window that is
OTP verification and OTP is ready for 10
minutes and click on the generate OTP
button generate OTP then click on
generate OTP button and it would
redirect to the second page that is
verifiable tipping so we have done with
the project if you are looking to be one
of them then yes you are at the right
place introducing you with Celtic post
graduate program in Ai and machine
learning let's take a quick walk through
with this amazing program some key
features of Caltech postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning include pgp
and AIML completion certificate from
Caltech ctme master classes delivered by
distinguished Caltech faculty and IBM
experts Caltech ctm is circle membership
earn up to 22 CEOs from Caltech ctme and
more few skills of this program include
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and gain expertise with the
tools like python chat GPT tensorflow
Keras and so on so hurry up and check
the complete course details from the
link in the description box
let's dive in and get started with some
python interview questions number one
what is the difference between shallow
copy and deep copy and you can see with
shallow copy we have object one which
has child one child two child three and
so on and object two which has child one
child two child three a deep copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the child objects of the
original object therefore changes in the
original object is not reflected in the
copy copy dot deep copy creates a deep
copy shallow copy creates a different
object and populates it with the
references of the child objects within
the original object therefore changes in
the original object is reflected in the
copy copy.copy creates a shallow copy
and you can look at this if we make a
change to child one it's only a pointer
so if you make it in object one it'll
change the channel one and object one it
will also make that change in object two
number two how is multi-threading
achieved in Python oh this is a good one
with multi-processing and
multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading and python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when we
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model drawn out
where the user initiates the Django
which initiates the URL which initiates
the view what they're going to view and
you have your model and your template so
the model of data whatever data model
you're pulling goes into the template
and then goes back up the pipeline to
the user and the important thing to note
is there's a template the front end of
the web page this is what they're going
to see there's a model the back end
where the data is stored so you can keep
the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying formation that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and Maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over nested list so numpy's a
module you import almost always see
numpy import numpy as NP numpy is
written in C such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module list on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists I would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our Jupiter notebook any IDE
will work if you're going to do a set of
these of interview questions taking a
quick look at code is always important
we have our import and of b as NP we'll
go and import time here's our list list
sub for Iron Range of 100 and what we're
doing is we're going to time it so we're
going to create a list then we're going
to create a numpy zeros array and you
can see here look how quick you can
create this numpy zeros array here we
are appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
float or integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type on it and then so if
we take in and we create a tl1 time
equals time and then we do for I and
range of 100 for J in range of 100 L of
I J equals L of i j plus five so we're
just doing a simple calculation on our
array and sub arrays this is an array of
arrays and we'll do the same thing with
tl2 tl2 time dot time tl1 equals so here
we have our final time on that and then
we'll do this with an array array op and
this is what I really love a equals a
plus 10 and then you can just print it
right out so you can see right here with
the numpy array we're doing the same
thing if I run this our time is
significantly different here we have
0.09 and 0.003 so you can see that the
time drops significantly when you're
running this on a numpy array versus a
list array also important to note these
times aren't going to be they'll change
each time I run it depending on what I
have running in the background so there
we go number five what is pickling and
unpickling Macy's me how many times I
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a byte
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as deserialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard Drive
pickle it and then you can unpickle it
to bring it back into another software
program or to use at a later time how is
memory managed in Python number six
python has a private Heap space where it
stores all the objects the python memory
manager manages various aspects of this
Heap like sharing caching segmentation
and allocation the user has no control
over the Heap only the python
interpreter has the access you have a
nice little diagram here here's your
program there's your interpreter we have
our Heap memory management on the
garbage collector going off of there
number seven are arguments in Python
pass by value or by reference arguments
are passed in Python by reference this
means that any change made within a
function is reflected on the original
object so you can see here def function
of l l of zero equals three L equals one
two three four function L print L and
you're going to get three two three four
because we've passed l in there so it's
a pointer here we have def function l l
equals three two three four l equals one
two three four function of L print L
because in this function I have assigned
instead of operating on a piece of L the
list I've consigned a whole new value to
that list or L it then at that point
we'll create a new object so if I make
changes to the object it's going to
change it in the outside the definition
if I use a variable and I assign it a
completely new value like L equals three
two three four that will not show up
when you're outside the function number
eight how would you Generate random
numbers in Python to Generate random
numbers in Python you must first import
the random module the random function
generates a random float value between 0
and 1. the random range function
generates a random number within a given
range and you can see here one is the
lower end times the upper end and step
two so it'd be one three 5 and so on as
far as the options in the random
generation number nine what does the
double forward slash operator do in
Python the forward slash operator
performs Division and Returns the
quotient in float for example five over
two returns 2.5 to do a double forward
slash operator on the other hand Returns
the quotient in integer for example 5
double slash returns two five divided by
2 and you drop the point five number ten
what does the is operator do the is
operator compares the ID of the two
objects and you can see in here where
list one equals brackets around one two
three list one equals list two equals
true and you have the double equals in
Python of course and you can do list one
is list two where list two equals one
two three is false this two is not the
brackets one two three it equals it but
it's not the brackets and if we do list
three equals list one then list one is
list three equals true number 11 what is
the purpose of past statement the past
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area you
can also do a function like this you
could do function whatever your def
function name brackets colon pass so it
goes into the function and does nothing
but it's a placeholder number 12 how
will you check all the characters in a
string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here a b c d 1 2 3 is all number
output equals true and the second line a
b c d the at symbol one two three the
pound symbol is all new output equals
false so I really just want to know
about is all new all numerical Alpha
numerical number 12 how will you check
if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all a number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean re match
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the ABCD one two three and
so we can do an re dot match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we get an output true and
if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in Python there's lists tuples
and strings python equation makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your Tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn S1 plus S2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function L strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here space space python
dot L strip leading strip Python and you
can also do strip which releases leading
and ending of course there's also the
ending set number 15 how will you
replace all occurrences of a substring
with a new string the replace function
can be used with strings for replacing a
substring with a given string syntax
string.replace old comma new comma count
replace returns a new string without
modifying the original string hey John
how are you John question mark replace
John with capital j o h n one and then
you can see right here hey John how are
you and since we designated with the one
just says we're only going to replace
one of these 6
what is the difference between Del and
remove brackets on lists Del for delete
Dell removes all elements of a list
within a given range syntax Dell list
start to end remove remove brackets
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax list remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list one to three
it will delete the first in this case b
one two it doesn't do three remember
that one two so it will delete B and C
and you end up with a d where if we do
remove B from the list and we have an a
b b d it's only going to remove the
first B number 17 how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for Loop to iterate through the
list number 18. differential between
append and extend up pin adds an element
to the end of the list you can see right
here we have a list one two three four
and we have pin four and we end up with
an output one two three four and extend
adds an element from an interval to the
end of the list and we have here list
equals one two three list dot extend
four five six output is one two three
four five six so if you want to append
an array to the end of another array you
want to use the extend number 19. what's
the output of the below code justify
your answer this is a great interview
question because these are the kind of
things that come up when you're proofing
code def add to list value and list so
we have value in and a list in or List
equals an empty in this case an empty
list list data pin value return list
list one equals add to list one list two
equals add to list one two three empty
bracket list three equals add to list a
and then we want to print them list one
equals and you can see the formatting we
have a place holder list one list two
and list three so when it prints list
one we get one comma a and what you want
to notice here is that list one and list
three are equal why are they equal well
when we passed the information to the
add to list we passed value without
passing the list equals brackets without
passing a second value what this means
is that list as we have it if you don't
have a list it'll start off with empty
list which we append the one to the
second one list two we appended a value
to an empty list so we're only going to
be one two three doesn't matter what the
list was before we've already assigned
an empty list and then list three here's
the tricky one we're adding a to the
list but because we didn't designate the
list list is a shared value in other
words it doesn't reset it and we end up
with list one equals list three one
comma a default list is created only
once during the function and not during
its call number number 20 what is the
difference between a list and a tuple
lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where I have list equals one
two three square brackets denote it's a
list list of two equals four and I print
it out I now have one two four if I do
the same thing with the Tuple I get an
error because you can't change the Tuple
one two three into one two four you have
to completely reassign Tuple to a new
value what is Doc string in Python doc
strings are used in providing
documentation to various python modules
classes functions and methods and so you
can see here we have def for function
add a b and this is a doc string we have
the triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b returns some and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing document string method
2 help on function add in model main
this function adds two numbers and so
you can see the code down here has two
very different in values the second one
is basically a help menu there's our
help menu number 22 how to use print
without the new line the solution to
this depends on the python version you
are using in Python version 2 you can do
print Hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have Hi how are you in version 3 print
hi comma end equals and it'll add a
space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally just want to put a space to
put a space on the End Print how are you
and now we get Hi how are you number 23
how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma Max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is to split by D
default is space so here we have an
example we have a variable red blue
green orange and we want to split it by
commas and we only want to do the first
two so if we print the list now you'll
find it has red blue and only spread it
split it the first two times and it gets
to the third one and just groups them
all together green and orange if you
leave the two off you'll split the whole
thing number 24 is python object
oriented or functional programming
python follows object oriented Paradigm
and you should really know in depth what
they mean by object-oriented Paradigm if
you're doing any interview for scripting
languages python allows the creation of
objects and is manipulation through
specific methods it supports most of the
features of oops which as inheritance on
a polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyworded arguments it's in both our
iterable objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal two so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
Python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this this
means I could return a function if you
want to move it from another function I
could create a function and treat it
just like an object I can assign it to a
variable I can pass them as arguments to
other functions number 28 what is the
output of print nay underscore
underscore name justify your answer the
double underscore name double unders
score is a special variable that holds
the name of the current module program
execution starts from main or a code
with zero indentation thus double
underscore name double underscore name
has a value double underscore main
double underscore in the above case if
the file is imported from another module
then double underscore name underscore
double underscore holds the name of this
module number 29 what is a numpy array
and we briefly touched numpy array
compared to a list early in processing
speed now let's go ahead and look at
some of the more specifics a numpy array
is a grid of values all of the same type
so if they're either all float all
integer all string and is indexed by a
tuple of non-negative integers the
number of Dimensions is the rank of the
array and the shape of an array is a
tuple of integers giving the size of the
array along each Dimension number 30
what is the difference between matrices
and arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and it's a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n maximum values
in an empty array we can do one way to
do it is to take our array sort it then
do minus n colon that means we're going
to do once you've sorted it you can do
minus in in would equal then the number
of indices so it's not the actual the
letter N colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and I'm going to say the D
is out none of these and let's look at
NP dot concatenate versus NP dot v stack
concatenate would put one set after the
other so you would end up with probably
give you an error because one set is one
two three and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and and one
array one two three the array of arrays
onto the end of that what we really want
to do is stack and by the ways you can
actually switch there's variables you
can put into concatenate obviously they
can change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really we're looking for is v stack
v stands for vertical versus the H deck
which is horizontal and if we do a
v-stack we can simply do train set comma
test set and stack them together and so
we have C resulting set equals np.vstack
train stack test set both option A and B
would do horizontal stacking but we
would like to have the vertical stacking
option she does this again you could add
the axes in and use the concatenate to
stack it the correct way number 33 how
would you import a decision Tree
classifier in sklearn we have
sklearn.decisiontree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
have last part happens to be correct and
it's really just a vocabulary knowing
where is the decision tree classifier
stored what module is that a part of and
it is of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
asterisks around name comma where and
then we have DF equals PD data frame
aabbb x x u u comma 21 1650 33 columns
equal name and age so let's take a look
and see what they're looking at we have
just glancing at the questions they want
to know is it the original data frame or
is it the copy of the data frame and you
can see here that one is view of the
original data frame and two is a copy of
the original data frame two is a view of
the original data frame and one is a
copy of the original data frame both are
copies both are views and if you're
working with pandas you know that unless
you specifically in certain things tell
it to do it inline and a lot of
functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so C both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp.csv using pandas which of
the following could correct it so here's
our error Trace back most recent call
last file input Line 1 and module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unit code and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import
matplot Library Pi plot is PLT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is at width equals
three line width equals three LW equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is LW equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot Library Pi plot Number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary Challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we're
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index
side of our data frame to a given list
so this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that it's external and we have a data
print to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in Python the function
is used to copy objects in Python we
have copy copy for shallow copying and
copy deep copying for deep copy number
40 what is the difference between range
and X range functions in pi python well
this is a good one we have matrixes and
arrays with a matrix the range returns a
python list object X range returns an X
range object and with arrays an x-ray
returns an x-range object X range
creates values as you need them through
yielding the key here is that X range
Returns the values as you need them so
it actually processes it post like if
you have for x or for a variable in X
range it is processing them as you need
them zero to nine it doesn't create an
array zero to nine it just hands you
zero then one two three four one at a
time number 41 how can you check whether
a pandas data frame is empty or not the
tribute DF dot empty is used to check
whether a panda's data frame is empty or
not and so you can simply create a we
have down here import our pandas is PD
we create our pandas data frame equal to
an empty array and is DF dot empty comes
out as true one of the catches you got
to remember with these vocabularies is
with empty along with some other pandas
setup whether you need the brackets or
not at the end number 42 write the code
to sort an array in numpy by the N minus
1 column this can be achieved using ARG
sort function let's take an array X then
to sort the N minus 1 column the code
will be X to X to colon n minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as NP we'll
create our array our numpy array which
is uh one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns in
there and we go X of X and so we take X
of all the rows first entity well in
this case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot ARG sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one our sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy or pandas and have my
list and see here we have my list equals
list of a b c d e f g over all the way
through so my list now makes a list of
that for array we have NP dot a range to
26 my dictionary will create a
dictionary with a zip my list my
arguments so I'll just use the numpy
array we just created with my array to
go into the dictionary and the solution
is simple with the PD dot series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have instead of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there and playing
with three different terms to get the
answer we want 45 how to keep only the
top two most frequent values as it is
and replace everything else as other in
a series so again we're working with
pandas because if you're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 and the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
we're random integer numpy random random
integer one comma five by twelve and so
the solution for this is we go ahead and
we've created a PD remember the capital
S Series solution we're going to print
the top two frequencies and that is our
series dot value counts and then we take
series values count dot index of up to
two so we're going to take everything up
to two and then we'll do the series is
in so if it's not in the first two then
it's going to equal other and this would
be something you'd want to write down on
paper if you're if it looks confusing
take a moment pause the video write this
down and see if you can figure out how
the logic came together and try to throw
yourself a couple other little logic
puzzles like this number 46 how to find
the positions of numbers that are
multiples of three from a series and in
here we're actually going to use a numpy
to solve it the first part series lets
you know it's going to be a panda series
and if we come down here we have NP dot
ARG where this is a vocabulary question
series with remember the percentile 3 is
the remainder so if the remainder equals
zero then we're going to generate that
string where the object divided by three
equals zero has no remainder so then we
know it's a multiple of three number 47
how to compute the euclidean distance
between two series and and this one's
really cool because we have our Panda
series p and Q and what I like about
this one is they give us two solutions
you can go with and really you should
kind of know both the first one would be
yes you know what the euclidean distance
is and that is we can take the first
series minus the second series squared
and then sum them up and then we do the
square root which is the same as taking
the power to 0.5 doing the power to 0.5
is easier than doing the square root so
a lot of times you'll see that as a
switch but you could have also done the
square root and use the math in there so
there's solution one you should know
your euclidean distance and then
solution two is the numpy solution so we
have
npa.linal.norm that's how we're going to
compute our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it 5 minus one when
this creates a 25 by 25 data frame and
so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping -1 going the reverse Direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to overfit your model and
the answer is yes is definitely possible
one common beginner mistake is retuning
a model or training new models with
different parameters after seeing his
performance on the test set my favorite
example of this is you have your script
put together and you keep hitting the
rerun button until you get the answer
you want not taking the answer it first
gave you or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which python library
is built on top of matplot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seabourn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs so here we have
reached to the end of this video on
python full course if you like this
video consider subscribing to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn if
you have any questions do feel free to
add it in the comment section below
thanks for watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign